[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you I do recommend Meetup to a lot
of my friends that are looking for
different things wine tasting movies
book clubs meet a lot of new people a
lot of new friends and make you more
social
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reputation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
God he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon Him
wow no way he forgot to play G5 oh gosh
once that white knight comes in it's
gonna be game over
dingley red nose first hand with the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame then he's on fire
right now he's back in the zone man
there we go Penguins wow wow wow ding
has leveled the score
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
foreign
it is a bitterly cold snowy day in
Astana but inside the playing Hall here
at the Saint Regis Hotel it is warm and
comfortable and all is set where the
fifth Match Game of the 2023 fide World
Chess Championship between dingley Wren
world number three and Yana pamushi his
opponent the world number two it is a
pleasure to bringyouchess.com's
broadcast of the world championship I am
your host Grandmaster Daniel narditsky
alongside me today is of course world
number six grand master Anish Geary
Anish good morning to you this is a huge
game
good morning another day for us here and
another exciting round coming up as the
players have warmed up traded some blows
and are back to even
they are indeed traded blows is a good
way to describe it as we look at the
scoreboard the current score is two to
two but it was wasn't always like that
nepo struck first but ding struck most
recently the first game ended in a top
seed trophy draw then a very confident
Victory by janapamnushi that was
followed by a confident draw by ding
recovered all of the momentum in game
four with a stunning exchange sacrifice
Rook takes D4 and a clean conversion
Anish both victories both nepo and
Bayonne uh and by ding involved an
exchange sacrifice what do you make of
that
I didn't think of it actually but indeed
it's a very common Motif uh sacrificing
in exchange that's so smallest material
sacrifice you can make almost after
sacrificing opponent it's very common
and especially at the high level
nowadays it's become a thematic thing
earlier it was much more surprising when
petrosan you know introduced this uh
Motif uh on a large scale people were in
O and then topalov uh brought it to a
whole different level also a big
exchange sacrifice guy and nowadays you
know it's just a matter of culture to
sacrifice and exchange often uh to you
know to convert things and as we had
seen in both games uh sacrifice of the
exchange was the decisive blow indeed
and I hadn't occurred to me until you
mentioned that the good point actually
well ding played so confidently in the
last game it was a very different ding
than the one that we saw in game two
nervously getting up all the time going
to the rest area uh and playing the kind
of Chess that uh we're just not used to
seeing him playing he is back on track
and now the ball is very much in nepo's
court well feed a Master Mike Klein has
been doing yeoman's work over in Astana
bringing us behind the scenes coverage
of the player's mindset now more than
ever we need Mike's wisdom to know what
the players are thinking and how they
are feeling going into game five Mike
Klein the floor is yours
thanks guys so far in the world
championship we've seen everything come
down to two words comfort and momentum
and right now ding Loren has both on his
side he's more comfortable at the board
he's more comfortable at the press
conferences even according to his own
words and he's clearly even more
comfortable with his surprise second
Richard Rapport we definitely have a
tale of Shifting momentum Jan napomnishi
was better in round one he made his
breakthrough in round two but in the
next couple of games it's been all China
because ding was better in round three
at least nominally but now we have a
back and forth Affair will Yan Napoli
quiet the nerves and play solidly or
will he get back to what he did in his
one win play aggressively use one of his
remaining whites and try to retake the
lead in the match we will see for
chess.com this is Mike Klein and Astana
now back to you guys
foreign
thank you Mike excellent insights as
usual well here are some more insights
for you Ding and epo's match-up card
which we have discussed uh really since
the start of the match how evenly
matched they are only seven feet eight
points between them and you know one win
for nepo one win for ding their
classical head-to-head is still very
much even a one point lead for Yonder
Palm issue but let me ask you a question
posed by Mike in his report Anish is the
momentum on ding's side how will nepo
recover given his Misfortune in uh his
world championship match against Magnus
Carlson we all know what happened after
that Marathon game six is the memory of
that game and of his response to that
game going to haunt him
to an extent definitely I told you at
the start I think as soon as young would
lose a game he could get all these
flashbacks but the situation is
different there he was facing Magnus
Carlson first of all you know in
mountain mountain of a challenge uh well
not to say the ding isn't but Magnus of
course is a special player dominating
the Chess World for a decade uh or more
already at this point and uh there Jan
was trailing after that loss and that's
a whole different situation when the
status quo is not on your side it means
you have to you know you have to get
some action going you have to win the
game you have to take risks now Jan is a
much better situation even though he's
feeling awful that he lost that previous
game when he gets the time to come down
look at the scoreboard he will still see
that everything is okay in fact even if
he starts coasting now plays solid if
the match continues with for example a
bunch of draws it's all fine for him the
situation uh is still under control and
I don't think he will Panic just yet but
of course if he loses one more game
today or
um or perhaps the next one
that would certainly be a very very bad
news at the same time he has the white
pieces I think he's done some prep and
maybe if he strikes right back today
momentum will shift back into his corner
and my client will give us a very
different report next time so I'm not
you know it's all it's all relative but
momentum is with one player until uh
until the other one wins
it is indeed and you know the
nostradamuses of the chat they were
singing One tune after nepo's win in
game two the match is over ding is not
gonna more of the same after Tata now
those very same nostradamuses are
singing a completely different tune the
match is over nepo is going to lose
let's not overstate the case the match
is tied there's an absolutely impossible
to predict uh what's going to happen in
uh the match or in this game but I think
one thing is for certain nepo's opening
choice is going to be very telling
because uh we're going to really get a
sense of the kind of position uh that
Jan will strive for something tells me
an age that we are going to see one E4
by yawn something tells me that when you
lose a disappointing game you want to go
back to your roots you want to go back
to the kind of position in which you
feel comfortable precisely because you
want to avoid the Specter of two defeats
in a row is that a fair prediction
uh I agree with all the points you
mentioned at the same time the problem
is uh very often you would wish to play
one E4 but you need these ideas as ding
said in the previous press conference uh
I I guess you remember at some point
when he was asked you know you played
the D4 C4 You're Gonna Play E4 and ding
smiled he said you know it's not about
the first move
it's about what ideas you have I think
Jan would rather have ideas in one E4
obviously but if the team hasn't come up
with something too interesting and if
they have better ideas perhaps for
example I guess the cars but that um
ding has played in the previous game
then you'll have a choice you know do
you rather play one E4 get a more
familiar position but no particular gray
surprise no great idea or do you go for
the Carlos but where you have some
interesting new idea in this Rich
position but uh you know you're less
familiar with the pawn structure so this
is the kind of choices a player has to
make of course if he had a choice uh he
would go for one E4 but not sure what
the team could up for him we'll see I
think the Carlsbad that Ding has played
also offers you know a very rich play
many pieces remain on the board
structure is very closed perhaps some
New Concept somewhere some new maneuver
Jan could uh and Cork and his team has
some time it's been two days with the
rest day in between as well so
definitely possible for them to to dig
into that also we don't know what Yan
has prepared before the match perhaps he
already had something ready for example
in the Italian opening that he was
waiting to use and maybe now it's a good
moment to use that so we don't know that
as well so makes it quite difficult to
predict
but uh you know if I have to play The
Devil's Advocate a new uh predict one E4
I'm happily taking one D4 is a
prediction I think my odds are pretty
fine here
indeed and I think a case could be made
for uh either Choice obviously you made
a good point about not using up all of
the aces up your sleeve and saving uh
perhaps your best preparation in the
most needed moment right the moment when
you really can't afford a loss and you
can't afford an uncomfortable position
out of the opening so I'm personally
very very excited about what we see in
the first 10 moves and for those joining
the world championship recently who
wants to know what is at stake well why
is it called the world championship
again well that's because the world
champion title is at stake uh and that
title is the most coveted title in all
of Chess but there's also a 2 million
euro prize pool with the champion
earning 1.2 million of them and the
loser earning 800k of course the
champion also earns the right uh to
defend their title in the next World
Championship Match will that match be
against Magnus Carlson uh who will have
to basically start from scratch and win
the candidates tournament or will it be
against the same opponent well only time
will tell nobody could have predicted
that Magnus Carlson would not be sitting
in one of these uh incredibly
comfortable World Championship chairs in
fact he's sitting in a different charity
she's sitting in a poker chair I think
in Vegas so Magnus Carlsen kind of
living it up while these players are
duking it out over the chessboard
oh yes and you have you have to realize
these two they're so hungry for uh for
that title it would mean so much for
both of them
and uh Carlson not playing is a
opportunity a small win of opportunity
because of course it's easier to
overcome someone who you so evenly
matched against then beating the Magnus
Carlson who's dominating chess for so
long and so they both you know came very
very well prepared ready
and you could see the pressure on both
the players uh ding was very open about
it Jan didn't talk much about the
pressure but you could see from the
mistake he made in the previous game
pressure also gets to him as well and
this is indeed a unique opportunity
there are many tournaments you can win
there is a lot of money you can make you
know in all sorts of ways uh but winning
the World Championship this is every
chess player's dream and yeah it's it's
definitely a special event for these two
players and you can tell you can tell
from just the vibrations within the from
the playing hole that you can see the
the tension the way in which uh the
players uh their body language the way
in which they play and the moves they
make you can tell this you know the
attention is really really high there
it is indeed I mean to go back to the
blunder that decided uh the previous
game Jan failing to play G5 instead
getting his Knight to D4 too quickly
allowing that exchange sacrifice on Z4
after which the game was completely over
unfortunately not all blunders are
created equal some blunders you make
they change the evaluation but you can
continue to fight as much as Jan wanted
to fight and tried to continue to fight
the game was completely decided uh Not
only was the technique straightforward
but it was you know ding was playing
pretty quickly after that the result of
the game was decided after Knight D and
Jan plays quickly right that's been his
character attribute really since the
start of his chess career and in a
tournament as important as this you
don't necessarily want to arbitrarily
change your playing style as we we see
the handshake there between the players
but I think it's fair to say Anish that
Jan he played too impulsively in the
last game and perhaps even in the game
that he drew with the white pieces where
he played D4 so maybe slowing it down
just a little bit in the early middle
game you you think that's the kind of
coaching that he might receive from his
team or do you think they're just
letting him solve problems on his own
I think this is not the moment to
change Jan's personality you mentioned
he was perhaps too quick in the game he
lost perhaps the quick in the game he
drew but he was also very quick in the
game he won and remember we spoke about
it there that this Rook takes G5 came
very fast the next moves now it takes D4
F6 everything came very fast as well and
I told you already back then that you
know when it works it's wonderful but
just like that it can also not work and
then people criticize him this always
happens you know your strengths are
extensions of your weaknesses you cannot
play Fast where you know when the moves
are good and play slow when you need to
think it doesn't work like that you are
either one kind of player or another
kind of player and yes you have to
accept Jan for who he is he's a
brilliant player plays very fast but
sometimes the consequences are
um yeah that's you know he plays also
too impossibly in position where he
should take a little bit more time you
can't have it all
that is uh that is a tale of life I
think you can't have it all uh but the
player that young already is uh is a
brilliant player he's won the candidates
tournament twice and he's definitely
capable to win this match as well I
don't think the the coaches and his team
is going to tell him you know how to
play chess they uh should come with
suggestions in the opening they should
tell him uh what what are the opening
ideas they have cooked up and then let
Yan take it from there
agree completely they basically want to
take a back seat they want to provide
moral support you don't want to over
analyze the game you want to give the
player the space that he needs in order
to recover the way that he wants on his
own terms and Jan's conversion in game
two was honestly one of the most
brilliant stretches of Chess that I had
the honor of watching the speed with
which he was executing all of the top
moves and sacrificing The Exchange that
is the yawn which is going to have to
show up in this game of course the
distinguished guest making the
ceremonial first move this time we'll
see who it is I think this individual
just shook both players his hands and
the game is about to begin it is 2 59 PM
local time over in Astana as the players
look at the cameras for one more photo
shoot and I believe that the e-pawn has
been moved two squares forward it will
be retracted and then Jana Pam issue
will himself execute the first move
and here we go the Moment of Truth the
first important moment what will we see
from the laboratory of yanapamnushi and
his team on the first move this will
decide a lot of Niche it won't decide
the result of the game but it will
decide the course of the game at least
in the beginning
oh yes already the first move sets the
course of the game as you mentioned uh
from my angle here I think I uh I saw a
D4 but I think that is not relevant to
what the guest has executed because I
think he's done it without consulting
Gyan and Jana has taken the move back
there was a symbolic first move now it's
to yeah onion to decide whether it's E4
or D4 I don't expect another move but
anything is possible nowadays players
are also versatile maybe anything let's
see let's see
well okay okay I lost this one I lost
this one parent Square you had the right
to first to pick the move first but I
think I would have picked D4
um anyway so yeah no good guess there a
ding will follow it up with E5 certainly
and then the big question I have is
whether yarn is going to repeat the
Spanish or perhaps he cooked something
up um in another variation Italian or
maybe some wicked wicked scotch or
something like that
you'll see ding is taking his time but I
think it's more of a formality he's just
uh taking a moment to get you know to
get
get into the game but E5 of course
happens
E5 happens Knight F3 is immediately
on the board thing following up with
Knight C6 no Petrov for us today and
this is the second Moment of Truth
Bishop is off to B5 so we have another
Roy Lopez and we remind you that in the
first game of this match yon played the
Deferred exchange he dropped his Bishop
back to A4 as he just did here and then
took on C6 uh in two moves will we see a
more mainstream Choice by Yan I think is
the next big question Anish
yeah I guess in the modern chairs at
this high level you don't repeat this
kind of ideas twice the opponent had
time to prepare an antidote so Jan will
play something else he plays D3 first
very uh very very mainstream stuff the
big question is after B5 Bishop B3 and
then D6 or Castle the main question is
what sideline has Jan um hooked up there
there are lots of different options
there's the A3 the A4 C3
um some Bishop D2 systems lots of
different things and Tiana has played uh
mostly A3 system but I guess for this
match he might have prepared anything
else we are about to find out I'm quite
excited looking forward because this is
one of the most relevant theoretical
tabias in the modern chess
indeed and you
said that young played A3 here he plays
C3 there was a time when the move D3 was
considered a sideline of course Rook to
E1 uh is in formal terms the main line
but I don't think D3 can be referred to
as a sideline anymore uh it's been so
popular and so common at the top level
that we should probably refer to it as a
second main line but here we see C3 by
janapamnushi that's an interesting
choice so we have the mainline position
with the difference that rather than a
rook being on E1 there is a Pawn on D3
how common is this
yes and indeed so the maximalistic
approach that white could take is to go
rookie one with the pawn still on D2
that will be here
and then go for the C3 D4 setup directly
as we pull up the uh analysis board here
um but
as a theory is uh as established after
q1 B5 Bishop B3 short Castle ding plays
this opening called The Marshall and
before white gets a chance to go for D4
leg strikes in the center with D5 and
then the the play involves spawn
sacrifice and as you know the analysis
have shown that this is not so simple
for white the bishop comes out the queen
comes out black has lots of counter play
in many of the variations black or
against the pawn or has excellent
compensation very often the bishop gets
trades for the Knight and then black
gets the visual pair advantage
and simply plays Spawn down for a long
time but without uh any trouble just
manages to hold the game because the
bishop pair in an open position could be
often worth almost as much as a pawn so
uh all this big Theory here basically is
the reason why
the players realize that okay playing C3
is not so simple so maybe let's go for
lines where you go D3 like D3 here or H3
first or A4 first and then let's save D3
after Bishop B7 and then at some point
the questions become okay but if you
play D3 here why don't we play D3
instead of rookie one and don't pretend
like we want to go D4 in one go so this
is all um yeah common knowledge by now
at the top and that's why D3 is a big
system uh it turned out you don't need
necessarily to go for C3 D4 to fight for
the advantage you can also maneuver
first and go for D4 later or not even go
for D4 there are also plans where for
example bishop retracts and you go for
B4 and A4 keeping the pawn structure SS
and then in the center but
um what Jana has played the the system
with C3 and H3
it's an interesting system and you you
will uh you will tell us a lot about it
because you know after Knight to A5
Bishop C2 followed by C5 the standard
way to fight for the center even more
what white often does is going for D4
and um
and that is a one of your favorite
openings I believe the [__] in
Spanish with the tempo up for black so
you will certainly take this uh but uh
the players you know who play the
Marshall they're not so comfortable in
these close positions after let's say 27
and D5 they choose to um often to avoid
it and so ding played Bishop B7 instead
and um Jan followed it up with A4 I
think
I think this is my game against alireza
erosia who played this
who played this rare combination of
moves against me in a
in an important game which is not online
but it was on the screen in uh
like it was in real life but on the
screen in in one of those Champion story
events I think it was in
in the US in Miami and
um very confusing system I think after
Knight A5 which is the standard way to
play
and there is a retracted the bishop to
A2 oh
so yeah very uh
very funky
funky stuff ding should still be
prepared but he has to try to remember
because it's very confusing you can play
a A4 already here
um you can also play maybe you can play
for also here it's all very confusing
you can just always you always have
these different D3 C3 A4 moves in
different order uh and you have to try
to with black try to remember what's
exactly your prep what setup you go for
yeah just like in the Italian and in the
Carlsbad Napa has chosen a couple of
systems where it's just immensely hard
to remember the right setup to play with
black and we've talked a lot about the
fact that these players are not immune
to human influences like forgetting uh
forgetting your line or forgetting
what's in your file and we've seen both
players essentially mix up their prep
most recently Jan mixing up this rep in
the last game very confidently putting
his Knight on F4 in the English and then
it turned out that that would have been
the correct move if ding had chosen a
different system so we're still well
within Theory it's just that Ding has to
remember which move he prepared against
this particular combination of moves so
a2a4 uh is a very typical move in the
Roy Lopez this is an idea that is
applied essentially across all of these
lines whether your Pawn is on D3 or D4
you often see white playing the move A4
and really highlighting emphasizing the
weakness of the B5 Pawn I think a lot of
people will be tempted to play B5 B4 uh
with black but if you do that too
quickly you weaken the whole complex of
squares on the queen side White Snake
can go from D2 to C4 typically in the
real Lopez whitesnite goes from D2 to F1
that's partially why you play rookie one
and we might see why play it anyway and
then the knight uh Maneuvers uh to G3
and you know in the ideal scenario often
jumps to F5 engineering uh counter play
and an attack on the king side so I
would say that white setup preserves
maximum developmental flexibility White
Snake could even come out to A3 white
truck could sit on F1 it could move to
E1 and Anish I think that's what makes
Black's position tough to play you just
don't know exactly where nepo is going
to develop his pieces just yet
yes uh
indeed white is trying to retain maximum
flexibility uh but I I do think the ding
he he's has looked at this extensively
because if you imagine you're preparing
you look at the database and there is a
very recent game between uh alireza who
is extremely high rated and okay myself
you know with a
it almost is still pretty high rating
there as well so the game would be
pushed very high in the database also
very recent last year and there was a
1-0 in that game because I eventually
lost it it was an Armageddon game and
alireza was very quick I lost that game
eventually and uh so if there is a one
zero uh played by alireza in a rare line
in your reporter you take that game very
seriously so I think ding has looked at
it and also his facial expression the
way he sits there I know ding it's uh he
he knows what he's supposed to do he's
just sitting he as I told you he likes
to take this 10 minutes of thought it's
a thing of thing to think 10 minutes
after
um his opponent selects an opening then
for 10 minutes he tries to recollect
everything he knows about it and then he
starts blitzing so ding is sitting there
awaiting his usual 10 minutes and then
he will execute a quick move indeed it
before makes sense Knight A5 another
important idea that I want to talk about
in general
now this is Bishop on B7 in this Pawn
structure and uh the bishop of B7 is
staring down this Pawn Yeah I think took
it less than 10 minutes late night A5
the point that I want to make Still
Remains valid the bishop on B7 is either
misplaced
and will potentially
uh head up back to C8 E6 or it will uh
activate itself with black striking
center with D5 Bishop A2 was the idea of
uh hilarious actually and I also played
C5 wow and that's the only game in the
database finish it's the only game that
comes up I just search this position
it's farrusia against Geary from August
2022. so now we know who the inspiration
was for uh Jana bombucha you always seem
to be involved but Bishop G5 which was
just played is a novelty alireza had
played Knight B1 to A3 which is the idea
we were just discussing
yes and I think the reason why I'm
always in the basis because we play so
many games now so many online games uh
so many tournaments I think I played 700
games in a year and so uh like whatever
opening you play my game will be there
so that's somehow oh I don't know why
that is indeed the case uh but um Bishop
G5 yeah so it's a matter of move order
so what alireza did in the game he
played 93 first now what will usually
happen
Wyatt wants to probably trade the bishop
for the night and get this Knight to E3
uh closer to the G5 Square
you can do that in different ways you
can start with Bishop G5 which is what
Yan did or what alireza tried he tried
to go Knight A3 first
Queen the seven and damage of G5 he gave
me the opportunity to snatch the spawn
by the way which I used and uh this is
actually a decent way to play
but then somehow I misplayed it later on
so instead of 93 uh Jan starts with
Bishop G5 the Knight can still go via A3
but it can also very well go via D2
rookie one Knight F1 and it's not clear
which route is is better there are ups
and downs to both these approaches
also the big question in this system by
the way is whether you take a b uh at
some point or not it's always a question
so black often plays a small Queen D7
sort of hinting at btx A4 ideas
um and then white you know is often
wondering whether to take or not also
white often uh is facing a dilemma
whether to take on F6 or perhaps wait a
little bit so yeah um Bishop G5 I think
technically a novelty but I believe not
not um shouldn't be a big surprise
because the computer uh yeah suggests
both these moves they are very similar
and I think should still be should still
be in in book but of course by now
already it could be a little bit vague
in his head what the move order was
very interesting description so Bishop
G5 uh is played in similar fashion to
alirez's move no pun intended but a
different move order which retains
flexibility as to the development of the
B1 Knight and it seems to me that b5b4
would make even less sense now because
White's Knight could essentially fly
through a different airport where I
could say Okay A3 is closed I could just
go Knight B2 F1 E3 and black
relinquishes the pressure on the A4 Pawn
um so the bishop is out to G5 very
positional idea right so this isn't
tactical he's going for the D5 square
and if he establishes control of that
square we know this from openings like
the Knight ORF where black often has a
weakness on D5 the last thing you want
is for white to to attain complete
control uh of the D5 square trade the
light squared Bishops and then put a
knight on D5 that would be essentially a
nightmare scenario but the other thing
that I noticed when you said white
doesn't want to take on F6 too early if
white does that then you allow black the
option to eradicate the weakness of that
square entirely by playing the move d65
whereas now uh that move wouldn't be as
easy to execute because the E5 Pawn
potentially is hanging so the way I
would describe this position is largely
strategic with a lot of these positional
decisions to make for both sides is that
accurate is the flavor of this position
largely strategic
oh yes I certainly agree with you I
don't see any big forcing variations as
you mentioned the only Pawn break that
comes to mind is this D5 move but it's
more often than not
um premature
um
indeed as you mentioned what white will
want is uh to get the Knight on E3 and
trade the light squared Bishops I think
white usually will gain control over the
D5 Square
but it's not the end of the world and
um
the problem white often will face in
these positions and I think maybe we
should not talk too much about them as
we will approach uh them eventually and
we'll have to talk about something later
on as well in the show so not to you
know not to tell it all at once but if
we do get there with the Knights on E3
and the bishop on A2 at some point a big
problem that white will be facing is
that there are two pieces that are
fighting for the same square that's a
common problem in chess
both pieces will stand beautifully on D5
Square you cannot have them both there
so this is uh this is one thing that
that will become relevant another thing
that might become Realms is the Bishop
from F6 will perhaps uh find some some
play on this diagonal or drop back to G7
knight from A5 often reroutes itself to
E7 fighting for that square as well in
some cases so lots lots of options there
to uncork in some cases also black is
trying to go for C4
trying to disrupt this diagonal and if
played in a good circumstances that
could be very strong but it shouldn't be
done prematurely because opponent C4
will be very weak
and
um finally I wanted to make a point that
it could also be sometimes interesting
to avoid the straight and move the
knight in some cases like I'm not sure
if it's good here it looks a bit
artificial probably I'll just go back
with the bishop but it is an idea to
stay away from this bishop text F6 trade
so lots of options here
for um for both sides lots of things to
think about again dings posture
is not his thinking posture this you
know is he is not very the handle is not
very deep in his in his head it's not
it's not there he's just here at this
the beginning of his head which means
that he is just trying to remember he's
just thinking he's not really delving
deep into the position because he has
looked at it already earlier but of
course yeah with all this bishop G5
Knight E3 and ab I it's quite vague um
also in my memory it's a little bit
vague because there are a lot of
transpositions and they're all similar
but you're trying to figure out the
differences you know what is the
difference well he hasn't taken he
hasn't played 93 How does it go how do I
exploit it
right and just like regular players GMS
need memory markers they're not just
going to remember loads of moves without
fully understanding why they're played
you know and in which position do you
play B takes A4 in which position do you
play Knight F6 to D7 and in openings
like the real Lopez and the Italian it's
harder to establish memory markers
because you have you know 10 or 15
positions that all look the same uh and
yet the moves that you play in them are
are different so again and again you
know just because he's just spent a year
preparing for the world championship
match doesn't mean that suddenly you're
going to remember all of the details of
every file as we've seen thus far I had
a concrete question for you uh on
YouTube we can continue discussing this
conceptually but you mentioned C5 C4 uh
I'm struggling to puzzle out what
happens if I try C4 in this position
trying to aim at the E4 Pawn before
white gets a chance to develop the
Knight
oh he put me on the spot there and these
are the kind of questions I I like to
answer with uh lots of time on the clock
so one thing that I'm seeing if I look
at it very quickly
so if I
play Knight A3 let's say
putting pressure on both these pawns my
idea is that if you take on D3 perhaps I
can take on F6
uh diffuse the pressure on the D4 pawn
and take with the queen and now I have a
decent control of this Square
I could also try to include a b Maybe
but then I was a little bit concerned
you have this bishop A6 option but it's
probably strange so maybe this is the
best way I just take 93 and if CD I take
take 23 this Pawn is weak this square is
still controlled looks good for white
yeah B5 is hanging D5 uh y can output a
bishop on D5 and you mentioned the
problem of two pieces contesting the
same square uh when white controls D5
with the queen and the bishop that
problem is largely limited because
Bishop D5 looks so nice it leads forces
the trade of Bishops and then why we'll
have the Outpost all to the Queen the
9993 has a different job for the time
being it's attacking the B5 Pawn yeah
that makes a lot of sense so the
concrete attempts to solve Black's
problems uh raises more questions than
in answers
um which means that Black's move is
probably going to be on the slower side
of course Knight to D7 is the only other
way to do something concrete and to
offer a trade of Bishops you mentioned
that that's likely premature so you're
pointing out Queen to D7 perhaps black
should also consider throwing an H6
although trading the bishop for the
Knight is something that white might
want to do anyway so that could
potentially be a loss of a Tempo but
it's not like there's one candidate move
here uh or one clear correct move
yeah I mean it's not it's not a position
where you cannot uh you cannot afford a
misstep I think H6 as you mentioned I'll
be very careful about doing that it
could be extremely
um
it could make white extremely happy
because imagine if white wants to take
one F6 anyway and you lose the whole
Tempo also with H6 you potentially
slightly soften up your structure
because in case of an eventual trade
maybe you want to put the pawn on G6 and
then drop the bishop back to G7 and now
with the pollen H6 well this
okay it's very hard to say if it's
useful or harmful but it's it's early to
tell and I I'm very skeptical about the
move like H6 I would think twice before
making it as you had mentioned also I
want to take a brief uh step a brief
moment to go back and um to talk about
soon Bishop B7
which was not given at all of course
because the bishop is um well very often
well placed on C8 and here black had
lots of options deeply should be selling
very quickly because it's his prep but
if you study this variation with both
colors you have to be aware of all other
options while black can also wait with
some waiting move like H6 or K8 black
can also go for 95 I think udanya I've
seen you play uh lots of spanishers I've
seen you play Move Like Bishop E6 in
positions like that I've seen you play
Knight to A5 a lot so I think
um
uh yeah it's it's not at all given that
Bishop B7 uh you know is is such natural
move it's if anything is actually very
double-edged move because the bishop as
I mentioned often uh is not ideally
placed here so yeah there was a moment
that we kind of skipped because it was
played quickly but um Jan has definitely
looked at Alternatives here as well and
so I did think so there was a an
important big moment that people the
players just uh hopped over and now
um we are here
ending is uh still trying to remember
takes already quite some time maybe
actually it's his thinking pause his new
thinking pause who knows because yeah he
takes a lot of time I think it's the
queen D7 that is very tempting uh
attempting to move but after 27 with the
Knight still on B1
I am wondering if Knight D2 is not
possible because if you go btx A4 with
the Knight on A3 I was really uh I was
really in control of this phone but with
Knight on YouTube White has Bishop B1
followed by Bishop C2 wow it's a way to
to regain also there are there is also
this idea of 55 55 yeah this is also an
idea I've seen are you regain the spawn
maybe even better here so yeah Bae very
risky with the Knight 22 1983 was
blocking the The Rook from from the F
upon so in my game against alireza I had
this position and I took an A4 and he
this was actually quite um
quite juicy for uh for me but I made a
big mistake later somewhere more like on
immediately on the next move he went for
some Knight H4 business
and I did something terrible there
um but yeah this is no longer relevant
as Jan started with Bishop G5
2792 yeah it's a it's a question how
black should proceed and then also why
exactly if he played Queen D7 so ding is
trying to think uh I mean if you look at
the position from uh
you know from a human perspective and
you try to fight with the D5 Square this
move 97 makes a lot of sense now if you
trade I
positionally I'm kind of happy with this
trade I would think
I would think I'm happy because uh you
know I traded a pair of Bishops my pawns
are on the dark squares
I guess Bishop E3 feels more principled
now if you go back with the Knight white
got this move for free
because you went here and back to here
and you went here and back so winning a
temple like that is kind of nice for
white I guess although the bishop only
three it's not clear how well it's
placed so these kind of thoughts are
going through ding's head he is already
having his head head hands wrapping his
head I guess he doesn't recollect and
now he's just trying to think and make
sense of this position
he has indeed and he's now spent 13
minutes and Counting so that's more than
his traditional 10 minutes I'm
remembering my file thing and almost the
entire time nepo got up from the board
immediately after playing uh Bishop to
G5 the novelty and he's been pacing next
to the board right he hasn't gone to his
rest area where we're used to seeing the
players he's been pacing back and forth
near the board we've seen his silhouette
appear a couple of times so kind of an
interesting Behavior there I wonder if
nepo is excited uh to reach this
position because if he took a very very
deep look at this with his team and
there we see on uh walking around there
with his hands crossed and he's about to
come back to the board because H6 has
indeed been played that's a big middle
move we'll get to it in a moment but I
wonder if net was excited to reach this
kind of position and I wonder if his
team looked at H6 the niche
is
yeah you know he's already played and uh
indeed age six is uh is one of the
suggestions of the computer
uh Queen design was the other C4 D5 by
the way were also quite possible the
computer doesn't hate them as the
computer doesn't hit 97 but H6 is the uh
yeah it's it's a fine move here I was
skeptical about it because I told you
often why it wants to take anyway but in
this case I I didn't see how to force
the trade window the white would just
play Knight D2 so yeah Jan takes quickly
a b quickly as well
as I mentioned earlier it's always a
question you know whether you take or
not I don't immediately understand
why you have to take perhaps before
becomes an option
when the a file is now closed and you
have to deal the consequences of these
positions so you too can play 92 and uh
now yeah the Knight
will probably head to E3 via F1
and yeah these positions are I am quite
familiar with there are different ways
of of playing uh here the price of a
move is not very high once again a
positional game and what I what I think
was Jan's choice for this game I think
he has drawn some lessons from the
previous White games and he decided not
to chase
um you know not to chase some big uh Big
Ideas in some weird openings instead he
decided to focus on himself and play
what he's most comfortable with this is
really his home territory one E4 is what
he played
um and
you know small positional Spanish slow
Spanish I should say by the way that
bian is not one of those people who
played Spanish all the all their life I
should uh tell you that I don't know if
you know that but uh do you know what is
the opening that young played his entire
channel was he a scotch player
uh sort okay at some point he migrated
to Scorch but it's much worse than that
much worse I can tell you
um
not that bad not that bad okay you play
something he has adjustable course on
King's cam but it's not that bad I can
tell you a story when I was so it was
the match to Apollo figures kramnik
played at that time so we speak 2006 I
was 12 years old I was at the training
camp and then Jan uh who was 16 years
old he um he came to that camp and he
gave a lecture on the opening that he
always played
and uh that opening uh was the E4 E5 and
D4 or D4 he played this against me in uh
our chest had come Blitz matches all the
time and then he would take with the
queen
yes yes this is the central opening or
something it's called he he plays this
all his childhood this ridiculous system
which which is why he is extremely good
in positions with more space in this
kind of positions uh the Marx he binds
the affili doors is extremely good and
comfortable in these positions and here
the line uh goes something like that
some old lines I think he used to play
some Queen G3 some Rook E4
um I don't know some of the play some
nonsense are for whatever I don't know I
don't even know what they play it's it's
it's some old stuff that Jan was showing
us the night sometimes goes to H3 some
kinds of all kinds of nonsenses
basically here
um so this is what Jana's played is
entire childhood so it's not like Yan is
like super uh big Spanish guy yeah it
was much later already when he has
matured he switched to the mainstream
Spanish and of course now his experience
there by now
um but uh yeah it's not it's not
entirely his uh
he is a comfort zone in his home uh
territory his home territories this is
this kind of nonsense but um yeah no
this is the Spanish now we have
basically we have a very standard
Spanish and Jan should be feeling very
comfortable he looked at this position
in depth I have also looked at them
um I can say that even though black has
a weak D5 Square
they're not not so bad for black Magnus
Carlson has a
he has played these type of positions a
lot he gets them from a different move
over he was getting them from the
Sicilians you can see it appear in a
different order or something like that
yeah a lot of games by Magnus in these
Pawn structures where you have this hole
on D5 and Magnus has shown in many of
his games starting from 2019 from this
match against Fabi in 2018 and in the
next years that he played these Pawn
structures he plays it here he can also
play it through from this order and you
know this um this D5 Square it doesn't
win you the game the square alone black
has plenty of play even very often if
everything nothing happens the D5 Square
you just cannot win because of just one
one weakness so not the end of the world
for black
but of course ding is taking his time I
think a knight at some point should
retract back to C6 its job on A5 has
done it allowed C5 to be pushed forward
it's time to bring the Knight back but
also sometimes you want to bring the
bishop back to G7 and it's important uh
well to decide in which order you want
to do that
and you know this fashion car of
Sicilian which I see some people
mentioning in the chat another opening
where you weaken the D5 Square you
violate all common positional wisdom you
know someone like capablanca would have
probably looked at the opening and
cringed over maybe I'm not giving him
enough credit but this idea with G6 and
then dropping the bishop back in F7 F5
uh can be incredibly dangerous and you
know this fashionikov is an opening that
has withstood the test of time so the
rule is often like you say one weakness
even if it's a glaring weakness like the
D5 Square uh one Outpost it rarely
decides the game of course one could
argue the B5 Pawn is another weakness
that could eventually make its presence
felt if the knight uh Retreats from A5 a
white cut have queensy one and B3 at
some point to tickle the pawn and of
course you don't want to play B4
prematurely and weaken the C4 Square you
don't want to make too many weaknesses
on the light squares in the queen side
uh because you might not be able to
handle all of them so Knight bd2 nepo
going for a position that makes it more
comfortable he's up now 26 minutes on
the clock so while we've been talking
ding has been taking another pretty deep
think it's now up to six minutes uh as
he decides whether to coordinate his
Rooks with Queen D7 whether to work on
his King side with G6 and to my
uninitiated eye Anish d6d5 is a move
that has to be calculated I'm assuming
that there's something wrong with it
concretely or maybe it's just that white
trades everything on D5 and plays Knight
E4 but I would bet a silver dollar that
Ding is at least partially considering
the move D5 assuming that he's out of
his preparation which uh I think given
his thinking patterns he is
yeah certainly if you haven't uh uh if
you have never seen the position D5 is
the first thing that comes to mind you
want to solve the problems immediately
although we already mentioned that these
problems are not so severe and I think
one of the main reasons why this um
D5 square is not such a big problem it's
because we have two pieces that you'll
want to get there so after night of 193
we have to choose either the bishop or
the Knight I think if you do get to
trade the Bishops and establish Knight
25 you will be definitely much better
you can see it on the application for a
while but uh what often will happen is
now it comes to E3 we go Bishop D5 the
bishop uh will hide from the trade uh
ding 196. yeah D5 the only thing I can
say is that I feel it's a little bit
uncoordinated at this moment the 195 is
a little bit weird there are all sorts
of like here
um as you mentioned all sorts of uh soft
you know soft pawns here
um the Knight is a little bit weird
Bishop also not very pretty I I don't
see what's wrong with this immediately
but I can imagine that there are some
tactical flaws with that
um also it doesn't solve your problems
entirely
you still have a big D5 Square even if
you trade the uh even if you trade this
Pawn for example and you still have a
bad Bishop let's say here you still have
the bad Bishop uh staring at this the
spawn this pawns become soft with D5
you've weakened the E5 and C5 pawns as
well right so it has some downsides as
well
um I think meanwhile played 96 young
played Bishop D5 very quickly so Bishop
D5 before uh rerouting the Knight
maybe The Rook will not go to E1 maybe
it will right away go to A1 at some
point maybe this is the idea sometimes
and
um well ding taking his time but I don't
think dings is entirely out of prep but
he didn't really expect this for this
game so he is trying to carefully you
know carefully slowly play he did the
same in the last black game if you
remember in the uh Carlsbad he also
didn't rush it and he reached a position
that he already knew he already played
against me actually uh almost an hour
later and it was fine he had enough time
eventually Jan caught up with with him
on the clock so ding not rushing it just
trying to spend his time there was also
Carlson's approach if in the match if
you if you remember Carlson was never
chasing Jan's clock he was just
spreading his two hours
evenly across 40 moves just playing his
own game ignoring Jan who has his own
pace and this is a smart approach
because when you uh playing someone like
young who is so fast keeping up with him
is first of all difficult secondly it's
unnecessary sometimes his quick Pace
backfires so you just have to spread out
your own time you have your own game to
play just make sure you don't end up in
crazy time trouble what is the young
situation if Jan still has talked two
hours on his clock or not it's none of
your problems so ding is just taking his
time and I think he's facing it out
decently right now and here here yeah he
has a choice to make once again
yeah and I mean the time control is
pretty vast you have two hours for the
first 40 moves and there's a classic
feed a Time control that's 90 minutes oh
the 30 second increment and that's it
you don't get any additional time so
it's almost as if uh
he's thoughtful 30 plus minutes and he
still has an amount of time that you
sometimes start with in a classical game
of course after move 40 you get an hour
added to your clock as we pull up the
time control there and then another 15
minutes after move 60 but the the flip
side is that there is no 30 second
increment until move 60. once move 60 is
carried out uh a 30 second increment is
added so you don't want to bring
yourself down to your last seconds
because you absolutely could get flagged
with uh no increment but I think you're
absolutely right right now the most
important thing for dink is to make sure
that he solves his opening problems not
to keep up with Jan on the clock and the
move Bishop D5 I think has revealed uh
and put in stark contrast the problem of
the Pawn on B5 because Queen D1 and B3 I
think it's more than a one move threat I
think it's a serious problem for black
to deal with because if it's met with
Queen B6 then for the first time this
game tactics start to appear with a
knight coming to C4 that's possible with
the queen on B6 being x-rayed and
undefended so if black is forced to play
the move B4 White's Knight sinks its
teeth into C4 and then both whites
bishop and whitesnite have found ideal
posts so would it be too much to say
that Queen B3 is a threat in this
position at the very least positionally
the other thing is uh too much I think
it's a perfect point and I think it's
it's yeah it's it's a big big threat uh
that said it's black to move so I'm sure
you can uh deal with it in multiple
multiple ways the first of all the
easiest is to just take on A1 then Queen
will be deflected from from that square
and then after you trade you can move
the queen to D7 or B6 and then take the
a file back with Rook A8 that seems the
most tempting
um here you could also start with Queen
D7
after Queen B3 maybe I have Knight A5
I'll never do they move the queen then
you if you move it to a two I think I
have Knights six back also Knight C4 is
there oh okay you don't want to have the
queen here x-rayed by The Rook so 95
yeah yeah okay yeah you and you claim
that you improved your queen a notch
yeah you can claim that and then you can
bring this Rook somewhere and bring the
Knight here and the queen back and fight
for the a file eventually you can
certainly try to do that
um I think yeah both are possible I
think it's up to ding to to decide
whether he wants to bring the queen out
I think also to B6 probably possible now
mb395
wait is there Knights
oh you're considering the exchange tag
Rook takes A5 yeah
yeah dinka's uh solved this problem of
community in the most direct fashion he
just traded on A1 and after takes takes
he just plays Queen to seven yeah now
you don't have the queen B3 move and
rookie rookie just is coming
I think so far ding has played in the
most uh natural way I think this is also
what the computer was suggesting as its
first choice so I think kind of prepared
and now Jan will continue blitzing
I suspect
yes he will and rookie one is already on
the board Jan playing the world Blitz
Championship here in the world champion
in the regular World Championship now
all of Yan's moves have been pretty
natural too you know both players have
uh you know picked off the low-hanging
fruit in this case we've talked about
this maneuver from the start rookie one
Knight F1 Knight E3 and of course the
Knight ultimately would like to sit on
the D5 square but from E3 the Knight
could also access F5 or G4 so it's not
like D5 is the only post for the night
and the most natural move by far I think
for ding would be Rook f8 to A8 sending
the Queen off of the a file that's why
ideally you want to occupy open files
with the Rook not with the queen because
the queen is very easy to chase away and
the next choice for yawn would be where
to put the queen in the event of Rook A8
and maybe you don't want to play Rook 8
because maybe you decide the queen isn't
all that good on A1 what do you think do
you think are you expecting Rook A8 from
ding
yeah uh
difficult to say I do think when there
is one open file and there's one Rook
mm-hmm although we talked about it in
one of our earlier broadcasts in some
cases in some cases you uh you don't
want need to occupy that open file but I
think here it's too tempting not to be
played Advocate is is kind of an
automatic move uh I think for me and I
want to mention that the fact that yam
plays so quickly uh it's not necessarily
a great uh not necessarily a great news
for for his fans because that means that
Ding is following the very main line of
his prep and that is a good sign for
ding meaning that Ding just makes all
the best moves and Jan remembers that
they because you usually when you
prepare you remember best the main line
right so thing is just following the
main line but main lines usually end
with the equality in the end so uh dings
just following the main line the main
path no surprises they're too young but
uh well you know as so far I think
managed to stabilize the position
the only question is of course how will
he deal with the long-term threat of uh
the Knight appearing to E3 and I I have
something to say uh about it but I want
to see how the game progresses first of
all I want to see if you think uh what
thing we'll choose and also I don't want
to give too much away
um about this position uh too early on
of course we have to space it out but
Rook A8 is very likely and my intuitive
guess would be Queen A1 to C1 not
because I played too much bullet and I'm
thinking of some later sacrifice on H6
but that might be an idea I can't listen
if the Knight does appear on you it is
because of that of course especially the
bishop on E5 creating ideas of the
moment H6 was played I was thinking of
ways to get a queen to G6 or a knight to
G6 that is one of the most classic
bullet ideas out there and it's very
easy to miss so I think it's safe to say
a niche and maybe I'm jumping the gun
here but with the bishop sitting on D5
with a pair of Rooks traded I don't
think F7 F5 that plan which is so common
in this vashnikov which we talked about
earlier I think that's become unlikely I
think black will focus his attention on
directly solving the problem of the D5
Square Knight C6 back to E7 to me uh to
my kind of primitive positional uh
glance seems like a very tempting move
to just forcibly uh evict the Bishop
from D5 and to control that square with
the with the Knight so that whites
Knight doesn't as easily land there
yeah
um I just want to first point out that
Queen C1 that is like your instinct it
would never occur to me to put the queen
on C1 because I like I am completely in
the positional mindset here I'm not even
dreaming about any attack so uh what I
was thinking after K8 is uh to go to D1
because there I have potential to
control the light Square so I have an
entirely different uh end of mindset
here uh not not to say that there's a
difference between between the moves but
yeah just very different way of thinking
yeah you you see some Queen appearing
here I just I don't even think about it
here like I I I'm you know my uh
complete uh
complete blindness for any tactical
potential is telling here but uh the
movie mentioned 97 now it's a very
serious move it's of course you uh
establish better control over the D5
square but you allow a trade of Bishops
and uh don't forget
although the position is somewhat closed
black still has a bishop pair so giving
up that asset is uh
is a Pity and now white has a potential
to at some point get a knight on D5 of
course you will probably never let me do
this but if that ever happens you will
regret having traded these Bishops
because as I mentioned earlier the fact
that Knight and the bishop are fighting
for this one square is no longer an
option and now also if you go for D5 at
some point I have seen games uh I have
seen games where
white just remains with the Knight
against his Bishop black even got D5
but uh
white would get some lights uh light
squares I remember there's one thematic
game here between every Lamy and um
he played against a Chinese player I
think it was jujiner I think it was a
and it was a very instructive game
they've got this structure and at some
point Aaron played the movie H4 and then
Azure had to play H5 and she didn't and
so Irvin managed to get even more light
squares under his control and he won he
won a beautiful positional Gamers all
these light squares are becoming weak so
uh these kind of ideas uh become reality
what you could also uh try doing is
removing the bishop at some point and
then going for 97 evicting the bishop
this way and only after the bishop
leaves do you then potentially come back
to control the D5 Square having avoided
the trade of Bishops so this uh this is
also an uh an idea that a black has in
this kind of positions but it's all
about execution here so do you go for
the a file first or do you not go for
the a file that's a big question and
then indeed do you trade these Bishops
or do you not trade them that's another
big question the blacks blacks are going
to answer
and all of these questions are largely
conceptual it may seem like a relief
that the price of a move is as you've
put it before is not very high right if
you play Rook a you don't play rookie
that's likely not going to decide the
game in the next five moves but there's
the opposite side of the coin which is
that these types of positions are much
harder to calculate so it's like you
don't have all that much to grab onto
you don't know if arcade is going to
help you or hurt you because you don't
know exactly how the game is going to
continue
um in some sharp night or if the
position might be a lot more complex the
price of a move might be higher but the
lines can be easier to calculate because
there's more tactics there's more stuff
to grab onto and as I say that Rook A8
has been played in the Moment of Truth
nepo has indeed uh refrained from Queen
C1 and instead shifted the queen back to
its initial Square on D1 I will say in
my defense Anish that perhaps the queen
could make its way to H5 later on so I
wouldn't abandon entirely the idea of a
king side attack
of course yeah yeah but I don't think
the queen on Devon is a little more
natural because of this potential to get
out by this diagonal
um
yes so now the black has grabbed the a
file again the same question remains so
do you trade
um the Bishops or do you not now Bishop
C8 is no longer
enough you need to also move the Rook so
you could consider going like Rook a 7
or k6 followed by Bishop C8 and Then
followed by 97 this kind of plan
um
a little slow but certainly possible
we'll see what dink's gonna do I think
he plays very confident and so far
actually he's playing all the top
choices of the engine starting all the
way from move nine all his moves are the
first line of the computer so I think he
is actually
well either he no feels his positions
very well but more likely he actually
slowly recollects his prep
you know this one weakness uh it's it's
a very very small uh something to hold
on to and
well if the bishops get traded maybe I
see some potential here if the Bishops
do not get traded it will be even less
so I'm not sure young yet got As Much
from the opening as he had hoped for but
it's still very very early to tell
because now it's actually the critical
position for things so far all his moves
were very natural it is actually here
that he has to take a decision or show
what he knows because yeah this is the
Moment of Truth do you trade Bishops do
you not trade Bishops and if not then
how so um I would say that so far uh it
was it was all kind of a preface and now
it's time to to start the game
and if you are trading Bishops apart
from 97 there is something to be said
for Knight C6 to d8 trying to get the
Knight around to E6 of course uh without
the supervision of black snipe the D5
Square becomes even more of a problem
and Knight F1 E3 D5 could really make
black pay and then the second question
if you if you aren't moving or not from
C6 then what are you doing how are you
improving your position of course G6 and
Bishop G7 I think has to be considered
for one thing it moves the bishop away
from F6 which means that if White's
knight ever does land on D5 or on G4 it
won't do so with Tempo this might sound
like a very remote consideration but
that's how you have to play in these
types of positions right they're very
concept conceptually heavy uh there's no
threat and there likely will be no
threat for the next couple of moves so
you're gearing yourself up for what's
likely going to happen four or five
moves from now so G6 is a candidate move
are there any other obvious candidate
moves that you think ding is considering
you mentioned moving The Rook for from
A8 and then playing Bishop C8 trying to
move the knight from C6 without giving
away the bishop pair that seems pretty
tempting to me as well
yeah so I I would categorize the moves
into three uh categories so there is the
ones trading these Bishops Knight E7 or
indeed Knight d8 to E6 there is uh black
trying to evict the bishop but not
allowing a trade which is then moving
the rook and the bishop in some order to
some squares is A7 or A6 Bishop to C8
First bishop C8 or Rook to A6 I don't
know and Rook to A6 first feels a bit
more natural but I don't know it depends
also on how you respond to Queen B3 and
there is the third category of moves and
that is G6 because G6 you are basically
trying to uh first improve the the
bishop a little bit get out of the way
and now you still face the same question
do you still trade Bishops or do you uh
still not trade Bishops so this is just
postponing the decision in a way so uh
yeah one of these three options will be
chosen by ding
very possibly that he has already looked
at this uh earlier as I mentioned
because so far even though he takes his
time he plays uh all the all the best
moves according to the computer and um
well very possibly he already made up
his mind and now he's trying to
recollect which which of these three
different approaches he thought was the
cleanest because you would be surprised
uh well you know I mean the viewer would
be surprised as to how deeply players
are prepared in general in chess
nowadays and uh it is impossible to
memorize everything which explains also
why they always think so early but I am
almost
uh 100 sure that Ding has this position
in his file and it continues on and on
but of course you have so many long
variations uh in your prep that you
cannot memorize everything and uh
sometimes you even you know you look at
something for a day but then uh like
half a year later you completely forgot
what what it was and but it is there and
you often it is there at the back of
your mind so you think that oh you know
Brooke A6 Bishop c897 yeah what an
interesting idea
uh you think but it's not that it's it
came from your creative brain is it was
there somewhere in one of your files and
it's somewhere at the back of your mind
so you will kind of think and you come
up with ideas that you've already seen
so I do think that Ding has looked at
this and I'm not surprised that he did
but of course he doesn't know which of
the I don't know 500 different opening
lines Yan will play with the weather too
by the name so the Carlsbad here
um one of the 20 different uh
anti-martials or one of the 20 different
Italian lines so there's so many lines
for ding he doesn't know what to expect
but at some point he had looked at this
and uh slowly he's taking his time but
so far he's making all the all the top
choices of the computer and now well
we'll see yeah what approach here he
chooses whether it's a bishop trade or
not
and very likely he's just trying to
recollect
um in any case it is very all very very
uh slow very very little even if you get
the worst scenario
you know you still have a solid position
because I mean even here if the Knight
appears on D5 well first of all it will
never really appear on D5 yeah because
this night this Knight is just not
making its way there so this is not a
horrible position by no means and uh
yeah so how do you even how you can try
you can try to maneuver maybe you three
maybe yeah you're you'd somehow get the
Rook on like here and then to a on the a
file maybe you trade the pair of Rooks
maybe you don't maybe you
maneuver this night somewhere I really
don't know where maybe you go H4 and
after H5 uh let's let's make a waiting
move uh you maybe have some Knight G5
ideas okay see this by the way is maybe
something
attacking here if you move the Knight I
move the Knight here I got something uh
then I will you kick me back
but I already established my knight you
know so this kind of little position of
Victories are possible
still a long way to go even if the
Knight is here even if the Knight gets
traded uh it's a long way to go because
this Knight is then very unlikely to
make its way here
but dink starts with Bishop to d8 Aha he
solves the bishop uh in a different way
I've seen this idea as well earlier
before instead of G6 Bishop G7 he
retracts the bishop to d8 that's also
also very possible
so this is like the third category of
move he's not trading uh the light
squared Bishops he's not moving the
rookies instead solving as you said the
problem of the dark script Bishop the
benefit of this move is that it opens
the path for the F Pawn not suggesting
he's gonna go King h8 and F5 but uh he's
he's taking that vulnerable piece off of
F6 so now Knight G4 Knight E3 to G4
potentially wouldn't come with Tempo and
as you're indicating the bishop could
swing its way over to B6 and aim at the
F2 Pawn again all of these are remote
possibilities he's not playing C5 C4
anytime soon but he's gearing himself up
for uh potential scenario so do you
think that that Bishop is going to make
its way to B6 if it was black to move in
this position uh what would be your
subsequent step toward improving your
position
so uh how I would see the bishop ending
up there I mean I don't think it will
land there immediately but what I could
see happen is let's say I play Knight F1
which is probably what Yan will play and
I should eventually get rerouted then
let's say I will
um try to do this ambitious uh plan of
keeping um
the Bishops away from from a trade and
now uh
I'm trying to to engineer it somehow
well let me do it in some weird order
let's say I go here yeah Knight comes
here and wow after D4 at some point
after default at some point maybe not
here because upon saying but somewhere
here the bishop could suddenly play a
role on the diagonal as you can see
in some of these positions so let's say
here Bishop is quite active even though
the spawn is hanging but it's it could
it could work in in this kind of
position and Jan played already Knight
F1 right and did ding already reply yes
Knight F1 has been played once again
instantly on continuing the bloodshot
his moves and Knight C6 to E7 so
category one category three move
followed by category one move offering
the trade of Bishops which is very
likely going to be accepted by Yan
although I wouldn't rule out Bishop D5
back to B3 I mean you could say listen
my Bishop is aiming at F7 that pawn is
particularly vulnerable because it's not
protected by a rug but the likeliest is
Bishop takes B7 followed by 90.
and John's play is really easy I think
that's another appeal of this position
Jan is saving some energy by playing
quickly of course this is also in his
prep but even if it wasn't I don't think
he would be spending you know 30 minutes
on each move because there's essentially
only one button that you can press right
which is to improve the placement of
your knight
and there's the whole point of going for
this opening and going for this very
small idea uh very little little little
plus the slight weakness of the D5
Square
um because the play is very easy Jan and
his team know that uh not little can go
wrong when it's easy to play it's hard
to make a mistake and of course yantry
is the Bishops I think it's an
achievement for white I think it would
be uh it will be outrageous to not trade
them I think White's really happy to
trade them and I think black could have
gone out of their way removing the brook
and the Bishop from the diagonals you
remember here as I proposed to remove
the broken Bishop from diagonal to then
chase the bishop away and if black
allows white to trade I think White's
very happy to trade I think it's the
first step to uh to Improvement for
white uh I think the bishop on B6 makes
sense if white goes for D4 if white
doesn't go for D4 it's hard for me to
see this bishop doing very much well
maybe after a potential C4 somewhere
Bishop could have a future on A5 but
yeah long long way to go it was also a
visual 107 was also definitely an option
hard to say what is this bishop on d8
um yeah it's also subtle and
um but I have to say the trade of
Bishops I think is an improvement for
Jan's position and I am kind of
optimistic for him and now also the
clock is in his favor
yeah I think a little something there to
work with also you know on the king side
so
I think GCB 57 uh was safer now the
reason I say it is that okay let's say
already I have an idea of Knight H4 so
let's say you make a waiting move I can
play Knight H4 and I want to trade this
Knight
which would be huge that would be huge
if I get to trade tonight and
established Knight on D5 but if you now
go G6 preventing Knight to five then the
bishop looks really awkward yeah with
the pawn already on G6 so I'm not so
sure whether dings Bishop d897 plan is
so accurate
to me it looks a little unnatural but
let's see let's see how the game will
proceed yeah it's important to see how
ding is going to follow this up but
things looking pretty comfortable for
Giannis Bishop to B6 is indeed play ding
completes his maneuver he's now down 45
minutes on the clock so
he still has plenty of time over an hour
but you know nepo getting everything
that he wanted out of this opening
almost all of his time still left
virtually no risk there's never
absolutely zero risk but uh he gets to
play and squeeze this tiny Advantage out
potentially for the next 40 moves so
buckle your seat belts folks we are in
for a really interesting middle game as
Jan tries to justify his opening choice
and reach the ideal scenario of good
night versus that Bishop but we will
take this opportunity as Jan returns to
his board and you will presumably Ponder
his next move to take our first break of
the day folks this is going to be a long
interesting and very important game the
match is tied 2-2 the momentum currently
on ding's side and nepo trying to
reclaim that momentum with a vintage
positional win you're watching the feed
8 World Championship 2023 this is game
five and we'll be back with more nepo
positional squeezing on the other side
of this short break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
the partner of the Champions chess tour
and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem
so do you think you have what it takes
to compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the eBay World welcome
back to the feed a world championship
World Quant is an official partner of
the chess.com broadcast of the fide
World Championship they're a global firm
that builds complex mathematical models
to identify market inefficiencies now
world's brain is bringing together its
International Quant championship and the
chess Community to hunt down the next
generation of Quant Finance Specialists
because nobody knows how to analyze a
position better than a chess player
right if you think you have what it
takes register for the international
Quant Championship head on over to
go.chess.com iqc or use xlam iqc in the
chat that's xqc with an I rather than an
X folks we hope you're enjoying our
coverage of the world championship
between dingley Wren and Yanda pomnishi
Grandmaster Anish giri Grandmaster
Daniel nerdinski bringing you coverage
of this very important game five whose
importance well it cannot be overstated
the score is two to two the momentum is
on ding's side and trying to really cool
down the Flames of ding's momentum with
his opening Choice Anish as we examine
this position and as John advances to
spawn to H4 which is an idea that you
had mentioned in reference to G6
grabbing space on the king side trying
to fully establish his dominance over
the light squares if you showed you on
this position at the start of the game
and you said this is what you'll have
after 23 moves I think he'd be more than
happy he'd say sign me up
yeah I love it and I'm pissed that Tiana
has played the move H4 so quickly
because I was so proud of this idea that
I that I you know wanted to to show
because I think H4 is a beautiful move
and it's extremely strong here but Jan
maybe he's still prepared or probably he
just understands his positions really
well because H4 is a fantastic idea and
I really love it as I had mentioned
earlier
black wants to go H5 but here it's met
by Knight G5 which is just very
dangerous with the black Bishop so far
away from the king so I think with H4
followed by H5 Knights heading to F5 I I
think it's a disaster from black already
this could get incredibly unpleasant
this is the first time when if you say
what are White's next three moves if you
give white three moves the game is over
like if the Knight appears on F5 and the
Queen on G4 then made threats on the
king side are totally insurmountable
because that's the downside of black
transferring his Bishop over to B6 his
Queen on B7 his Rook on A8 all of the
pieces clustered on the queen side like
that as primitive as this point sounds
his King is essentially exposed and I
think Jan is saying listen I'm not only
about the D5 Square I'm not just a
one-track mind I'm also going after your
king and going after the F5 Square
yeah I I think things have gone wrong
for ding already I think uh the
combination of trading Bishops
as well as Bishop Dave Bishop B6 plan I
think it's just been very wrong now the
only thing I would I can suggest for him
at this point is I like this idea of C4
it's a very nice positional idea opening
this bishop I think you can't do that
immediately because of takes and queen
takes on D6 maybe preparing it to Queen
C6 what do you think
yeah I was actually going to ask you
about the immediate C4 you're right the
Knight on E7 hangs at the end of the
line
well let's take a look at Queen C6
because if he does in fact play C4 and
he does it without losing material
trading the B6 Bishop for the E3 Knight
is it a fair assertion to say that that
cools down uh White's initiative here
oh that would be a dream come true and
let's perhaps take a look at the
analysis borders would delve deeper into
this uh stuff with Queen C6 I think
Queen C6 to me seems very tempting also
keeping an eye on the B5 Pawn here
and now I well if you are going to allow
me to trade the bishop for a night let's
say let's say if we get this I think
this is just an absolute dream for black
I think black's doing very fine here I
don't see any problems any longer as the
one night getting traded means there's
no longer an issue with the D5 Square
surprise the bar is still with white
here I really like black but okay maybe
Knight H4 still keeps some initiative
but uh I think I think here uh instead
of H5
C4 is probably too drastic uh uh what do
you think C4 is that
well in your old move Bishop A5 could
come in handy although Bishop A5 is a
one move threat just rookie two and the
a file is closed and then BC could
actually be met by DC because Queen
takes C4 obviously fails to Knight D5
and white wins material
yes this was my point the only thing is
of course it's rookie 2 is slightly in
the way of the queen potentially heading
to G4 and actually that's a big pity
because I really want my queen on G4
after H5 Knight H4 but it's maybe uh
maybe good enough maybe it's good enough
uh anyway besides C4 maybe there is an
even cleverer move let's let's take a
look at this position uh I have this
Knight d2 move sometimes
I don't need knighted chicken 95 95 9295
is of course like my dream but sometimes
you have to be realistic the dreams
don't always come true 92 Maybe
you can you can you can indeed and um
I I forgot about that and now you um can
defend this Pawn if needed this also
looks okay for Black Knight D2 actually
doesn't uh help okay maybe C4 indeed B
B3 even still allows C4 so maybe Queen
C6 should be met with C4 at least that's
and I also just want to point out that
this intermittent with uh let's just
make Show an example this Intermezzo
with CB it never works because the
bishop has two instruments so it's it's
not um
not an important uh Motif here but yeah
a quizzes 64 uh it looks like at least
C4 is some sort of a commitment from
White side it uh opens this diagonal for
black
changes the post structure somewhat
after bcdc all the people on this little
backwards the b-file is open maybe this
gives back something to hope for besides
Queen C6 uh are there other moves you
you have in mind here perhaps for black
well thinking of the pawn breaks the
black could prepare I think the idea of
D5 is condemned I just don't see any
Universe where D5 actually works even if
you even if E5 was defended as you've
been pointing out D5 actually opens you
know it closes some doors it opens
others and I don't think that's the
brake flag should aim for B4 uh
obviously makes things even worse it
weakens the C4 Square F7 F5 could black
try to prepare that with Rook f8 is that
crazy he does play Queen C6 in the
meantime yeah this was quite wild indeed
uh sf5 is uh extremely committed allows
Queen B3 check also it's technical it's
just not feasible but indeed he's played
56 56 is uh yeah the the most natural
move it's so tempting to try to make
sense of this bishop here and uh well a
logical play by uh Ding and I'm really
curious if Yan will actually go for this
very drastic measure normally you try to
I think in this kind of
uh in this kind of Spanish use you try
to not take the measures as drastic as
that but maybe in this particular case
it's it's good um who knows
yeah this says C4 it can meet C4 with D4
so for example here
can do this
and I still retain some advantages in my
position because the bishop is still
although it's nice they're now looking
at our our Pawn targeting it it still is
somewhat uh locked in here at Knight H4
Knight F5 still is on the menu and D5
Square still is available to my knight
so this is also possible to consider an
edge the bar doesn't hate it either so
maybe that is a way to play
um yeah it's crazy to me it's crazy to
me that the bar was giving point two
there and it was giving 0.2 after black
plays C4 and trades on E3 that's why you
can't you know with small advantages you
have to be really careful because not
all small advantages are the same I
think the advantage white has after C4
D4 is just so much more actionable than
the one that white has after you know
Pawn take C4 and after black takes on E3
because this just seems like a much
easier position to play for black now
maybe Knight H4 and queen G4 and Rook G3
comes really fast and but I'm skeptical
I I mean even you know first of all
black and yeah drop the queen back to D7
and yeah Black's Pawn structure isn't
visually appealing but how are you
really going to attack the D6 Pawn so
this is I think the quote-unquote worst
case scenario for Yan which actually
tells you how good his position is that
even if black achieves everything that
he wants you know White's position is
still a little bit preferable
so C3 C4 is one option I was also
thinking about Queen to E2 uh trying to
stop C4 directly but maybe that doesn't
stop C4 uh Pawn takes C4 Bishop takes E3
and I was thinking Pawn takes B5 because
now the Desperado sack isn't quite as
effective and white retains the extra
Pawn what do you think about that I love
it yeah I love it I love it I uh
I didn't really realize that you have
this resource actually and that that
makes me love the move Queenie too
because I I like not committing to
things I am married
World Championship commentary yeah but
uh when it comes to when it comes to
pawn pushes I like to not commit to too
many so I don't want okay I'm okay with
C4 but I also see lots of disadvantages
with it so I run the note and I also
rather not allow you to go C4 and
immediately D4 I mean we can but rather
notes so in that sense I really like the
move Queenie too because I think we keep
all our threats alive
while black can insist on preparing C4
somehow but Rook C8 is like that's a
huge bummer because now you know I can
grab the a file which is huge
wouldn't do that and otherwise
hard to say some there's always this
move okay too there somehow trying to
put some pressure but it could also it
could also be just a waste of a waste of
a move frankly so you you don't know if
you you want to play rookette 2 in many
of these positions
yeah very pleasant choice for for Jan
here uh I think he will be salivating in
the prospects of choosing here he played
very fast so far so I expect him to
still be in the
in the mood to play fast though having
said that he looks very focused and I
think he might as well take some time as
this is a very very crucial moment he
has lots of options and he doesn't want
to sell his position his Advantage also
too short my favorite so far is Queen E2
but we'll let letian take his moment
there
and it's probably the case that Jan is
not only deciding on a move to keep his
Advantage he probably knows that he's
better after C4 and better after Queen
E2 he wants to unfigure out what type of
Advantage uh he wants to have what what
exact type of position he's aiming for
but yeah the reason I like Queen E2 is
because it keeps the structure and it
just uh keeps his foot to the pedal H5
Knight H4 Knight F5 uh is still a threat
that black has to deal with and it's
just very hard for black to figure out a
robust way to secure his King side so I
think the start of this game uh is going
excellently for yawn obviously the
previous game went excellently for
dingley Ren who scored uh his first and
thus far only victory of the world
championship match leveling the score at
2-2 as Jan Ponders uh his next move and
presumably young will take a pretty
significant think let's take this
opportunity to listen in uh to ding
sharing his thoughts in the press
conference two days ago after the
previous game here's ding
yeah disclaimer
I guess I
I meant myself to uh to fully con fully
focus on the game and it went the
results was what as I expected
and
yeah it's uh I can say it's the most
important win so far since World
Championships is a totally different for
example let's say candidates
obviously dingley Wren and we take a
look at his incredibly impressive
Chester resume there he is currently
world number three he was world number
two until he was replaced after Tata
Steel by someone named uh Jan napomnishi
but Anisha I want to Echo your point as
we Feast our eyes on his achievements
which is that it's very important not to
over psychologize in particularly in
these in these tournaments and in these
matches which are decided 99 on the
board they're decided by specific moves
but obviously emotions and psychological
mindset it plays a role too
oh yes for sure but um just to you know
to say what I always say and you already
mentioned you know
of course the momentum is with ding and
he looks uh very good
you know he's a very shy and a modest
guy but what you've seen now I was a
very confident ding on the press
conference as confident as he can appear
I mean he is of course always
downplaying um you know his his
greatness and he's being very modest and
uh required but he is feeling great at
the same time well how great can you
feel when you have no you know when you
have a weakness on on D5 and there's no
nothing works for you really and you
have the set position so I think it's
very important
um to to look at the position on the
board and I I think the opening has
worked out like majestically for Jana I
think he couldn't have couldn't have
hope for this in his wildest dreams like
ding has chosen the most uh
uncomfortable setup with Bishop d897 I
think this is really at least optically
this is the clumsiest set up from all
that I that I could uh would see from
all the options that we were looking at
this is really the one that gives young
the most opportunities and uh yeah well
the situation on the board uh really you
know less ground for young to take
control of the match again but this is
an important moment this is really when
uh this move and the next three moves I
think they will really really determine
whether Yan will be able to extract the
most out of this position
and I think finally it's safe to say
that Jan as we see the feature chat
there is out of his prep is out of his
file
you mentioned that you know this
position may still appear in his file
these files Go incredibly dip deep and
often often times to move 30 move 40. so
you never know when uh you're actually
out of the file I would also add that
not only do humans have a tendency to
forget but at least in my case we have a
tendency to convince ourselves that we
remember
um I read an interesting study recently
that uh so-called flash bulb memories
when you think you'll remember where you
were when something important happened
for example you know uh 911 right you
think you remember that day that's
actually a lie you don't actually
remember where you were 15 years ago but
you convince yourself you remember I've
had so many games where I'm absolutely
positive that this is in my file and
that I had just looked at it I come home
and uh I had invented something
completely new and in fact uh I had
confused the file 10 moves ago so
I think it's very very important for
that reason to take your time and to
admit to yourself when you're out of
prep because it's a lot better to think
on your own and produce a move on your
own than to try to remember the file and
end up playing a move that's even worse
than one that you would have played had
you thought independently is that
accurate
yeah it's a good point and in general
memory is a fascinating topic and not
only not only related to chess but as
you mentioned there's this phenomenon
where you remember there's also this
phenomenon where you tell yourself a
story and you
form that memory so you remember the
story that you tell yourself and that's
no longer the truth so you have also all
sorts of cases of you know people
confessing to all sorts of crimes and
because they were under pressure and
then suddenly think that they've done
something exactly yeah I mean looking at
this position is not a crime though and
but that said that said uh I don't
expect Jan to be in book Because as I
mentioned uh earlier black had so many
options in particular starting from here
I mentioned Bishop c897 I think a very
reasonable setup uh Rook 821 on 97 right
away 98 that you mentioned also G6
Bishop G7 and then 97 also Bishop C8 and
Rook A7 here so many different
interesting setups
and we can see here on the now support
would end uh the the one that Ding has
gone for which is Bishop d8 and then
Knight E7 in this version here also
Bishop C8 Rook a697 was a plan so all
these different options that Ding could
play I think he chose just one of them
and very likely this was one that Jan
didn't prepare deeply maybe he still
knew the movie H4 but maybe his prep
ended here he could have come up with
the move H4 on his own it's a very
tempting move I also thought about it
myself but but uh yeah well by now he's
certainly out of book and um this is his
moment to to deliver his team is waiting
with uh you know with the baited breath
there they've done their job they're
they've you know given him uh that
wonderful position and not only is the
position nice and pleasant it also fits
his style it's played in The Horizon
from the 1e4 Spanish variation variation
of he's so familiar with that he's
played in the recent years a lot so
they've done their job and now they're
there in front of their screens waiting
for Jan to to build up on that and
actually build an advantage
and uh get something tangible and uh
yeah it's it's it's now is the moment of
truth in a way as young recovered
actually from his loss uh is it the
usual yarn because so far you know uh
following prep and bringing knight from
F1 to E3 anybody can do that you know
um people are studying our chess book
courses they also can follow on the
arrows you don't have to be uh you know
young kind of player but now it's really
the moment to show
um the world that Jan is a great player
it's his moment to shine and whether he
will find and make something of this
position that that is the big question
yeah so right now our big candidate
moves are c4 that might be White's most
committal move because it actually
changes the pawn structure uh and then
there's of course you could ignore the
possibility of C4 and that is the least
appealing at least to us you could play
H5 and you keep a tiny Edge but it seems
like Black's position is much easier to
play uh and I think the move that we're
probably leaning toward is Queen to E2 I
saw some people in the chat also
suggesting Queen to B3 which is more I
think appealing to some people visually
because the queen controls more squares
on B3 on the other hand after Queen B3
the move C4 comes with Tempo and it
might still actually be possible
definitely it would have to be
calculated
yeah that same variation after Queen B3
C4 DC4 Bishop E3
uh CB Bishop to King F2 I'd rather have
my queen closer to my king here I feel
because their Queen's five check
is uh we can make the most on the board
I think because it is a likely line
let's take a look so Queen B3
I'm not sure of course the pawn
sacrifices are very difficult to
estimate yeah but uh
I don't like unsafe Kings and here I
don't know B6 or C5 let's say B6
where you you go to G3 Maybe
or F1 or wherever you go of course maybe
white is probably probably I was because
you know I was kind of hoping for some
F5 but before if I cannot play because
it's pinned D5 is also maybe not not it
although maybe I can go D5 but uh yeah
well um I would rather have the queen on
E2 in this position
maybe that one is also good so in this
position I feel like my queen is uh
closer to the king although yeah it's
your question it's a question if being
too close is is also good because here
you do get a five ideas but intuitively
it feels not more natural this one and
also after Queen B3 I have a question
okay maybe I don't need to go C4 maybe I
can prepare it because now c4 it come
with a huge Tempo on the queen
so you'll have to respond well if uh
here let's say that's what I mean is
let's say you make some move and make
some move you make some move
now I have uh I have some time to react
while if we do it here
the queen is threatened so uh black
gains the tempo essentially on on this
kind of stuff so I'm not sure could be
three to me feels a little bit
counterintuitive because I feel that I
don't want to be targeted by C4 I want I
want to have that extra half a Tempo in
reserve but it's it's a big question
especially what I what I wonder about is
this position I think it's it's far from
given that this is clear for white don't
you feel
oh yeah no far from clear because that
five is coming as you said and there's
mating constructions with black knight
appearing on G3 and it's one of those
things when you have a decision like
this uh and you know that you're better
to begin with
we talked about this in a previous game
I always feel like whatever decision I
make doesn't matter which one I'm always
going to regret not making the other
decision so I could totally see myself
going for this position saying man I
didn't have to have a situation with an
unsafe king or my opponent has counter
play I could have played C4 on move one
and be chilling with a slightly better
position then you play C4 on move one
you lose your advantage and you say man
I could have had an extra pawn and I was
afraid of phantom threats against my
king so you know these decisions are
always so hard to make and to not regret
and in the meantime H5 has been played a
niche whoa yeah and uh and when you said
Daniel we like it at least I wanted to
uh to respond there that's okay we don't
hate that either
um because it's D4
yeah yeah likely I think D4 is the is
the follow-up yeah you know at least
with H5
you uh you're playing in the most
principled way like you don't want to
waste time we need to you say what you
want it's a waste of time let's be let's
be frank there it's a waste of time and
I'm really not not sure Jan is
salivating at the prospect of this
position he thinks he's better like you
said he's indeed better and now he's
better but he has to deal with the weak
King why what for after H5 C4 D4 well
there's no question of Wiki 94 still
coming the fact that the bishop is
looking now at our opponent it's an
abstract it's a very abstract uh uh
thing and I'm not sure black can exploit
it actually so I I don't dislike H5 at
all I wouldn't say that I dislike it
we'll still we have to see uh how this
plays out but uh so far definitely an
interesting choice there by Yan and
we'll see if uh we'll see if also we
have to see if DeForest is maybe maybe
he actually wants to go DC and maybe he
sees why the computer also likes it for
white I mean maybe maybe it's this
position for example
um
he wants Knight to D2 and
well ding ding ran back to the board
like literally ran and he's already
played C4 so we're about to find out
whether nepo wants DTX C4 with an ultra
simple position we'll only have one pair
of knights on the board or whether he
wants to keep some spice uh alive with
D4 it would be more in nepo style I
think to play D4 and anishi also might
be tempted by the prospect of applying
pressure on the E5 Pawn so he might feel
like not only does he retain the idea of
Knight H4 Knight F5 but he's also
forcing black to respond to the threat
of D takes C5 and D4 is already on the
board ding now has to figure out a way
to keep E5 protected he can do it
directly with you know Queen back to C7
I like the look of Rook a to d8 uh to
x-ray the queen and to take the sting
out of D takes E5 and one thing I'll
tell you that worries me about nepo's
Choice especially if flag plays Rook to
d8 is the prospect of black playing D5
in response to White Moving the Knight
away from a F3 that pawn on D4 is ultra
defending but once the Knight moves away
from F3
white also has to reckon with the
prospect of e takes D4 and the
possibility of black setting the center
on fire by creating a pawn cube with D5
yeah and that's a good point you have
certainly have to address the threat of
Knight h4s you have to address third of
DTX E5 I I liked the uh little facial
expression never made after D4 sort of
implying like I don't know what you what
you're planning doing what I think uh I
think you're in trouble here and of
course D4 honestly it was an absolutely
only move in human terms allowing Bishop
takes E3 trade is outrageous the fact
that the computer suggested it uh you
know it goes to show that humans you
know we all think in a very different uh
way we have our pattern recognition and
we're very inflexible uh the engine see
so many more factors that are for us
very hard to comprehend of course D4 is
the move and you play it instantly and
confidently and now it's uh on ding I I
think yeah Rook d8 well one thing I I
have to say is that with upon having
made it to H5 already which usually is
not the case well here if I ever get my
knight to F5 oh boy you'll suffer so I
am very worried about black but indeed
for now maybe Rook d8 intending 94 D5
as you have suggested well it's but is
it even can I not still go Knight to
five there
yeah you probably can I mean that's
total tandemonium the position suddenly
gets very tactical there there's a fork
thread on E7
that has to be calculated very carefully
but it seems like black is risking a lot
more
yeah what I want to say exactly you have
to calculate uh but
the the price of uh you know the
calculation the price of your mistake
for black it's very high if it works out
for white it could be a really bad news
for black so I don't know Rook d8 also
somehow counter-intuitive stepping away
from the open file into a closed one
maybe maybe this is this kind of
desperate move you need are there any
other options so okay taking only four
is uh bad because of Knight xt4 I think
that's pretty clear cut yup taking on D4
I think taking on D4 is actually an
option so it's a most natural one as
well perhaps don't you think I was
worried about Knight takes D4 and the
Knight F5 and if you trade Bishop for
Knight then I take with the queen and
that position maybe I miss evaluating it
looks really really unpleasant
ah okay uh yeah interesting uh
my instinct was that it's uh
it's somewhat of relief for black of
course I understand that we are still
better I agree with that certainly but
at least there I got rid of your your
knight so my other Knight controls this
key F5 Square so I felt that at least in
and we can maybe pull down and pull up
the analysis boards to look at this
position in more depth as it's quite
relevant one after ad I actually expect
a CD
but maybe you're right let's see Knight
D4 Bishop D4 24
yeah the bar is uh well it's it's
somewhere in between of course yes I
understand you're better because you
applied pressure here your knight is
very good uh at least well Knight F5 is
not a big threat anymore as my knight
defends it I don't know how bad is this
end game after Queen C5
how bad is it
well white could also play yeah takes
takes in Rook D1 I guess H5 is hanging
there so probably white should play this
primitively are you bad also the fact
that you got the spawn H5 even in the
end game it's a very nice clamping down
this black pawn structure and well yeah
I don't wanna I don't want to suffer in
the same game I have to say it's it's
worse than I had anticipated it to be at
first
what are my other moves can I try to
activate my Rook or I'm worried about E5
tactics
oh yeah oh yeah now we're speaking my
language if I have D5 though that keeps
yeah and I'm I'm attacking the spawn for
what it's worth and um
maybe workable maybe workable
uh just to be just to be sure can we
dismiss the option of CD is that so
terrible because I I was actually
thinking maybe CD I don't think it's
terrible at all I think you know
instinctively giving black the pawn
majority felt a little bit of he maybe
d65 here
uh can be considered
yeah
I think it's it's it's you know
unpleasant everywhere and White's got
the luxury of the choice it's like that
old you know Russian anecdote
uh where you know A man gives his
friends two two ties for his birthday
and the next day he comes out and he's
wearing one of them and you know the
punchline as well you didn't like the
other tie
the point being whichever one you would
wear uh you want you don't like the
other one so white is spoiled for choice
but it felt like Knight takes D4 keeps
all of the advantages and eliminates a
lot of the counter play now you are
right and that Knight D4 is also a much
more practical choice in this situation
Jan wants to play without risk the
entire uh from the start of this game it
plays a very uh comfortable opening the
one that he's familiar with uh he wants
to stay in his comfort zone after a
difficult previous game which is also
the understandable and probably the
correct way to go and here a CD you
create an imbalance for all you know
things can backfire one day the C Pawn
can queen or whatever and after Knight
D4 well the only imbalances in these two
pawns pretty much and there you create
this exponent is weaker in our
centralized Pawn on e4 and here black
has to suffer uh well without much hope
of taking all the initiatives so I think
94 as you mentioned that that is the
better practical choice and um yeah
indeed an admission of uh admission of a
failure of the opening somewhat since
the position that arises
it is quite clearly worse for black
maybe not much but it is worse and of
course with the black pieces at first
you want to pretend you are not worse at
all that you equalized sometimes well
you have to accept the minor defeat and
if we have to choose between Rook d8 or
Ed
I don't know it's a difficult difficult
Choice
um
yeah I don't know what else what other
moves out there I think de is actually a
is simply a threat actually so the pawn
is just hanging and well what else your
knight has no moves but let's be clear
about that this bishop shouldn't move
either
um the queen you don't want to bring it
back oh it's it's on C7 at least uh
covers the D5 Square somewhere it's not
in the uh it's the performance no no no
no no no no no no no they have six yeah
no way no we can we can everything even
further so by process of elimination you
either go 84 or you make a move with the
Rook maybe you might look at two or ketu
but here probably is just going to be
one so I guess Rook d8 or uh Ed are
simply the two only moves this move B4
is not really a move is it
yeah I just just take the four even Pawn
takes E5 yeah exactly yeah it's it's
nonsense it's nonsense and just to be
clear is that actually a thread because
Queen E4 in the end
we need four in the end and then I guess
our old ideas Knight takes C4 yeah then
Bishop F2 though King F2 and oh you're
still there you're still better but no I
have Queen H
you are probably still better no matter
what yeah but it's not the end of the
calculation there but okay it's let's
say that you want to address this threat
of d
yeah I mean yeah I mean no matter where
you turn white is better and and the
depressing thing is that you know the
worst case scenario for white is
equality the worst case scenario for
black I mean it would not be an
exaggeration to say that a couple
inaccurate moves uh and black is facing
maybe not a lost position but a an
advantage that continues to grow so this
decision e takes D4 versus Rook d8 is an
incredibly important one ding is now
under an hour so he's definitely at
least feeling somewhat the pressure of
the clock he's got 15 moves to make
before the time control and the last
thing I'll say is obviously decision
fatigue which is the thing right when
you have to make decision after decision
and the decisions only escalate in
importance you start to get tired of of
your position and the decisions are
certainly not becoming any less
important with now several concrete
threats on the horizon D takes E5 being
one and Knight H4 Knight F5 and queen G4
being the other
yeah yeah no good good point what what
is your instinct so what if you had to
take a decision now which move would you
make Rook d8 without question he takes
D4 Knight takes D4 maybe I'm not giving
it a chance but that position just looks
sad to me
interesting yeah yeah now let's take a
look at Rook dates in a little more
detail as doing is pondering by the way
he is dropping uh further on down on the
clock and 54 minutes
uh it is of course a lot of time but you
have to realize that it's move 24 and
the next few moves are very very
difficult and potentially he's going to
face an unpleasant position similar to
the one he faced in the first round
their time might be crucial so I'm not
uh optimistic for doing but let's take a
look at true dating the analysis board
perhaps as we can delve deeper into what
are the thoughts uh ding is uh having
after this so
um isn't that the chord that we're
looking at yeah we're looking at Knight
H4 right
we were looking at H4
and you also have maybe it takes D4
first
you mean in this position yeah followed
by D5 Maybe
but we're looking at D5 right that was
the
it was the line and then we said Knight
F5
is possible
24 position yeah it takes days Queen F6
I thought was the most natural and I
didn't see actually a problem here for
black even though it's very shaky
so now yeah because G7 is protected so
Queen G4 doesn't have a clear point he
takes D5 not possible drops the Knight
and D takes E5 that seems like the most
reasonable you take back on E5
yeah opens the diagonal for the bishop
by the way which is a big plus but I
think we take C5 FS it looks pretty fine
for black action now the bishop is
activated so maybe Rook d8 Knight H4 D5
is not so terrible
is there another move than Knight H4
well I would point out that D4 D5 is
maybe not out of the question but very
close because this is exactly what black
wants the prospect of taking on E3 and
then maybe even playing F7 F5 so White's
Gonna Keep that pawn on D4
Knight H4
seems like the only logical continuation
to me but if D5 works out for black
concretely maybe that's exactly what
ding is calculating right now
at the same time at the same time uh
black doesn't have a clear next move
actually so maybe you can do something
slow maybe Queen to C2
perhaps
renewing the threat of did I C5
is an option but now ed4 is much more
tempting because you no longer can
recapture with the queen this position
becomes very attractive for black even
even D5 here
yeah yeah absolutely so even even D5
yeah yeah no just it just was not the
idea
um so yeah Rook did becomes a big uh
favorite in my mind is 45 here I had
some options I also started with Ed
and maybe something maybe three or
something trying to pin the game there's
tricky moves here but
I have no the email bar seems to oh yeah
yeah but it's different it's because
it's different not now of 95 if you go
Queen F6
uh no but it's just a different position
and you just take Queen F3 and I mean
somehow it's not the same it's just not
the same
okay
maybe maybe
looks tempting
93 maybe just 1994 simply just pick up
let's just collect oh it's beautiful
beautiful idea Knight G4 Forks the queen
and the pawn on E5
yes yes yes so okay okay so Knight H4 uh
is a thing ed4 of course is is a
question here as well and I was hoping
some Knight to five business very
tempting oh this looks tempting now
Queen G4 coming extremely and you look
at the evil bar to zeros well imagine
having this position with the twin
threats of 97 and queen G4 you know good
luck figuring this out maybe take stakes
in like Queen E8 or something but but it
looks kind of lost to me to be honest
like I mean same equal okay but I I
would think with black that I could just
be lost here or close to like a YouTube
maybe I'm maybe maybe something okay
foreign
was a thing with a fork so maybe what
you mentioned the screen eight move but
okay I mean well you need but it's this
so dubious Queen G4 or not yeah wow 96
you don't care
wow okay wow very impressive very brave
typical right where the engine just
gives zeros and and ding has no idea if
this is lost or equal or what
so we always have to remember this right
he doesn't have that starting reference
point we know that this is almost equal
to begin with so likely if the evil bar
doesn't change we're going down the
right path thing is no idea if he's
going down the right path or if he's
blundering so it's totally
understandable that he's investing time
he's got 50 minutes on the clock and
he's about to make a very important
decision so you folks do not want to go
anywhere because this is a decisive game
the score is two to two the stakes could
not be higher and this decision uh on
move 25 for dingley Ren could not be
more important as he attempts to at the
very least draw the game and maintain
his momentum we're gonna take this
opportunity to go on another break when
we come back hopefully we will have some
clarity on ding's Choice you're watching
the 2023 feed a world championship we'll
be back with more action from ding nepo
in just a couple of minutes
today we're going to go down into the
New York City subway set up a table on
the subway platform and see if we get
some strangers waiting for their trains
to play chess with us
all right I'm gonna see if I can get
anybody
[Music]
sounds like he knows what he's doing a
little bit
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good got the chess.com app
do you ever play on your phone oh yeah
he said he barely played I'm a teacher
what do you teach chess I'm just kidding
self-defense
take medication
what's like lesson 101 of self-defense
one what are you listening to right now
train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran what is the meaning
of life it's funny because like what I'm
doing I feel like doesn't align with my
philosophy on what the meaning of life
is but it's like obviously spend as much
time with family as possible the best
person you can be get closer to God not
to be evil to each other
good game thanks for playing
I'll see you in a self-defense class
when Damon first approached me with the
idea of teaching children to play chess
I thought you want to do what
okay whatever you want to do
um I'm behind you I support you but how
are you gonna do that and the more we
talked about it the more he laid out the
plan we tried some things and 15 years
later we have fabulous program
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
we are back at the feed 8 World
Championship where Jana pamishi is
honoring this very important moment a
couple of moves have been played since
we went to breakding has made the very
important decision to take on D4 Napo
has indeed recaptured with the Knight of
Niche now we have not debated for a
while uh the evaluation of the position
clearly nepo has been in the driver's
seat really ever since the opening this
was a real Lopez where ding he made the
questionable decision of trading light
squared Bishops and ever since then his
position has been unpleasant big
question is how unpleasant and with his
last move Queen C6 up to C5 I think the
answer is quickly becoming very
unpleasant Anish
yes he took the decision
um sort of an in between one he did take
on D4 but only once this occurred to me
actually I wanted to discuss discuss it
at some point and I expected him to
bring the queen to D7 keeping the bishop
uh more active with you know with the
site on this diagonal now the queen kind
of blocks the bishop but I guess what he
wants is to keep an eye on this Pawn to
keep an eye on the fifth rank certainly
a sensible uh attempt although very
dubious one I mean if you imagine that I
will get the opportunity to go Knight F5
not only do I get a monstrous night
which is like positionally an
achievement because I can be routed back
to D5 but also there might be some
direct threats against the king now what
ding is hoping for is the rough Knight
F5 takes Knight takes there is quintax
F2 for now that is true but uh since the
bishop is blocked and uh Jan can well he
can make a move with the queen first
maybe Queen two F3 I think F3 is the
most tempting Square protecting the F2
Pawn
introducing the idea of Knight F5
I I don't know I I think it looks really
really nice for it and I want to just
make before we continue looking at just
just a small note just small side note
because I have been watching a lot of
our Championship matches uh in the past
a few in the past few years and I have
to say that so far this match is really
quite remarkable because in every game
so far we have a full-fledged game and
both players especially the white
players playing with the white pieces
they managed to get quite something
going from the opening and that is what
I find remarkable because
The Narrative has always been that oh
you know the theory gets more and more
dried out and the Carlson you know was
telling oh you know I'm so good I'm so
strong but you know the theory I cannot
play but you know I'm really the better
that all of them you can see it you know
because I'm uh so good on in the chess
but yes it matches it's so hard because
that's all prepared now you see that's
well well prepared but every day there
is a game mm-hmm
and we've talked about this in previous
rounds the fact that there's a different
narrative that states will openings
aren't as interesting anymore because a
lot of doors have been shot you can't
play The King's Gambit and true some
doors have been closed but guess what
you have a game like this in the Rue
Lopez where engines I think helped yawn
find a very interesting idea and the Ry
Lopez as a whole has been completely
reignited right the flame has been
enlivened in the rulopas and the Italian
not only because of computers but also
because of uh the creativity and the uh
innovation of top GMS but also because
computers have shown completely new ways
to play Old openings the real Lopez used
to be played in exactly one way right C3
D4 you would get the Knights of G3 now
you have all sorts of different ideas
sometimes the dark Squad Bishop comes
out to D2 so you know there's different
sides as you're saying to this narrative
but let's try to figure out how
objectively bad this position is for
black we are aware that the engine
assigns a relatively modest Edge to why
right and one part of that is that
Knight F5 isn't possible immediately
Queen F3 Anish I think without any
question is the most natural move not
just because it reinforces the
possibility of Knight F5 but also
creates the rather tempting possibility
of E5 uh with a discovered attack
against that rook in the corner
yeah I mean it's uh it has everything
going for it and the question in this
position is uh basically if you are
looking at it I I guess I'm at least
that's my impression if I was looking at
this position the only question I would
have is why not Queen F3 and that's what
I would be thinking about and probably
there would be no no reason not to play
it I am thinking maybe doing
well Rook A2 would be quite quite um
quite bold but actually possible because
Rook on A2 well it's it's contributing
here on the second rank applying
pressure on the F2 potentially so I'm
thinking of a variation the queen of
three maybe it's time for us to pull up
the analysis board because we've been
staring at the question for quite a
while and so if I play Queen F3 uh Rook
A2 if I'm going to go for Knight F5 move
is really contributing so this is not uh
not not so stupid at all and
um
what about that said that said is very
it feels very dubious in worst case I
can protect the Pawn With The Rook but
maybe there is a tactic here or
something uh direct we can we can go for
you know me too well I'm thinking of
Knight F5 takes I was thinking of taking
on a five of the Pawn in order to
potentially be able to play F6 in
shatter Black's hitting position so like
let's say Knight I'm not sure which
Knight off the top of my head let's say
an idea five Knight takes F5
the evil bar believes that white is
winning in that position so I wonder if
there's maybe 1995
to open the F5 score for the queen we
should show I think the line Knight
takes Pawn takes what happens if black
takes on B2 now with the F5 Square
unoccupied it's made in two queen F5
inducing G6 and queen takes F7 is made
and black is just way too slow right
even after black takes B2 it's not like
black creates any threats against
White's King so white just comes a lot
faster here
yes I mean the idea you mentioned with
ef was very strong but Ed with Ed is
just a better execution of that and this
is even more yeah so on okay two is
indeed as outrageous as it heals I am
briefly wondering if he's able to swing
the queen across here or here and then
try to trade the bishop for one of the
knights this is also why move earlier
like my instinct will be to try and get
rid of a knight
um and suffer
but or at least keep an eye on the night
so you understand would keep an eye on
tonight qc5 is very risky move after
Queen F3 I don't know Queen E5 and queen
G5 do they work not sure at all feels
very very beautiful black
yeah I mean there's so many options here
and Knight F5 is still possible Knight
G4 and E5 that yeah
superficial but could be very strong you
hit the Rook on a you hit the pawn on D6
and man whites Knights have so much
potential here so much attacking
potential and Jan probably holding
himself back right really yes for sure
extracting the lesson of the previous
game and this time he has plenty of time
on his clock really digging deep making
sure that there's no hidden opportunity
here such as Queen G4 which I think also
has to be very seriously considered
because then Knight F5 will come with a
mate threat and in some cases you could
even sack the pawn enough to with check
so that it's not like Jan is just you
know sitting here uh and and you know
investing time thinking about what he
wants to eat tonight I think he's
confirming making sure that there's no
more juicy opportunity than uh Queen F3
and speaking of Jan taking his time uh
and Yan's approach to classical chess I
sat down with Yan a couple of months ago
so as he's taking his time uh to confirm
that Queen F3 is indeed the best move
let's listen into his thoughts on
classical versus Blitz from the
interview that I did a couple months ago
here's Young
I mean of course it's more entertaining
to to look I don't know some three three
plus o and flogging each other but uh I
mean okay I think I used to be quite
good at this as well yeah but back then
and maybe I can also you know
get back to some of my Esports skills
but your priorities have shifted yeah
absolutely absolutely so I mean in terms
of enjoyment for me yes so I really find
a good classical game which you're not
necessarily win but you have like a big
Clash so you like spend a few hours
thinking about something really really
interesting to try to also get into your
opponent's head so how is he thinking
what is he planning and when it just
happens everything is happening you know
I mean and in three minutes you have a
result okay that's uh quite favorable
for our time overall but uh I think it's
you know leaves most of you know almost
every Beauty behind the scenes
Jan is obviously an incredible Blitz
player and incredible rapid player he's
played ding in Rapid so many times and
sometimes when you watch yon play
classical it is like watching him play
rapid but I think it's awesome I think
it's awesome we have someone like Jan
who's played quickly throughout his
chess career and it's really really hard
to do I mean that's why you don't find a
lot of grand Masters who regularly play
quickly in these long time controls and
largely get away with it I mean John
sitting here at the world championship
oh yes and Pistol he has slowed down of
course a lot in the recent years he as
you can see now when he smells an
opportunity and it's not obvious to him
he is taking his time you made a very
good point um that he could also
consider Queen G4 I really like that
idea of sacrificing the F2 Pawn
so he indeed does have uh have a choice
and he also understands that in a
position like that
if he makes the right choice this could
be a huge winning opportunity he
understands that the position really
looks very very good but between a
position that looks good and a victory
on a scoreboard there's this large large
gap and sometimes overcome that Gap even
Jan has to take a moment and you see we
see now you know the modern neon the one
that is trying to balance this quick uh
talented uh but uh very sometimes very
superficial uh play with this in
thinking Yan who is going deep and tries
to get into his opponent's head as he as
he mentioned
back to concretely discussing the
position but one more General point I
want to make is that a phrase which
comes to mind in reference to this
position a phrase that's used Often by
commentators and annotators and is often
mysterious is critical position right
you hear well this is a critical
position uh and you hear the phrase or
the common wisdom and critical positions
you have to take your time what exactly
is a critical position well there isn't
one exact definition obviously it kind
of means an important position but what
does important mean in this context
my favorite definition involves a
position where making the right choice
is likely to define the results of the
game whether it's a win or if you're
defending a draw and this is definitely
a position where the right choice is
going to have a bearing on the result of
the game
and speaking of that it's like John hurt
us Queen to G4 is indeed his choice
would you like and this is a product of
going too deep
um or just deep we'll see the bar didn't
like the move I mean I really appreciate
that you found this move
um it's a very creative idea
but it is really that is the the one I
move that you find when you go beyond
you know you go slightly Beyond because
of course in a Blitz game Jan would have
played Queen F3 without a thought
like even an ebola look at this
game even more so in a hyperbole game he
would probably play Queen E2 because he
would Mouse deep queen of three so you
know there of course of course Queen F3
is the move that you make but but the
classical game you know you have the
opportunity uh to delve deeper to and
and that that caused him to to find this
idea of Knight F5 that you mentioned
because now if let's say we once again
show this through K2 roketo yeah Knight
F5 maybe we can pull up the analysis
board quickly because this line is a
little bit longer and this is what
attracted nepo to this line because
people might be thinking oh Queen G4 is
a mistake what was he possibly thinking
this is the position he was aiming for
Queen takes E1 is not a check anymore
and there's just no good way to defend
G7
but yes indeed and this is of course
such a beautiful idea and in general of
course Queen on G4 is more threatening
because after Knight F5 you have a
threat of Checkmate well
after Queen F3 you don't have a thread
of checkmate.95 so pg4
like it's sort of a more aggressive move
and if it has a tactical the
justification then it also seems to be
better so I can totally understand yeah
I'm thinking this is a better move I
would guess the defense would have
something to do with them yeah just
between E5 which is also very natural
now the other advantage of Queen F3 in
fact
is that besides preparing Knight to five
it also prepares E5 and after Queen E5
maybe this Knight G4 idea was uh quite
strong because now E5 is there opening
up uh The View on The Rook but also the
Knight on G4 yeah uh has yes and indeed
dink
use the opportunity and cost for 25. and
that's another downside of Queen G4
which is that Queen E5 is ultra natural
it protects the G7 Pawn takes this thing
out of Knight to five and this is what
I'm most curious about what on Earth is
Yan's intention after Queen E5 because
he must have seen this move this must
have been the main move he considered
and there must be some concept some
creative idea that Jana has in mind I
was thinking Queen G4 to D7 uh could be
a thought to Target the pawn and the
Knight but it doesn't even really
threaten anything and I think concretely
after Queen to D7 black and play Bishop
takes D4 CD and then Queen takes E4 and
because the Rook on E1 is undefended the
Knight on E3 has nowhere to drop back to
and open up a discovery against the
queen so
does he still want one Knight of five a
niche maybe and is he tempted by Knight
takes H6 threats that doesn't seem
dangerous either because black could
just move his King
what gives
sometimes you miss a move uh you could
have just missed 25 altogether
but maybe he has certain idea in mind
maybe it's on Knight F3 I thought but
the Knight on D4 is doing such a good
job but even Queen E6 actually becomes
viable
maybe the Knight F5 but while it's no
longer so clear I don't think Knight F3
is tempting F4 doesn't F4 doesn't work I
assume yeah quit X E4
simply simply there yep right yeah I
think Knight C2 Queen takes C2 yeah look
yeah yeah yeah yeah Knights into Quick
62 is also what I thought so I think
um even by the way in the worst case so
I think this is just not working I don't
see it sometimes it can be simpler than
you know it can be as simple as he just
missed just he just missed 25 uh that
could also be
oh I don't know the fact that he's
taking his time
Knight I think he was moving his Knight
let's see Knight back to F3 is on the
board
good call Queen E6
I mean like Knight and F3 in itself is
badly placed right uh I mean from F3
it should go to F5 so ignite basically
takes a step back from a better position
so Queen E6 becomes now very uh very
tempting getting a Tempo on the um on
the White Queen no I mean end game
splack should be happy
with the space here in the bishop and if
Knight F5 I thought about just taking
take in Queen F6 and then this Knight is
basically
um basically dominated by the bishop
although the computer likes this maybe
Queen E4 is there yeah going for some
weak squares yeah and maybe Knight F5
can be met with the immediate Queen F6
it's scary but I just think white is out
of ideas like Queen F6 here
maybe keeps the structure the way it is
yeah you're right that's better not to
give the Queen the square on e4 because
this Knight on F3 is no longer as
threatening as to us on D4 where it
could open to F5 and what about Queen F6
directly then by the way it's another
question I have
I think also very solid I mean E5 D
takes E5 is a dead end
no I mean it's so clear that white has
not come close to squeezing the most out
of this position Queen D7 now I think is
a little bit more appealing than it was
in the previous move but it just seems
like going in the wrong direction okay
one
I have all kinds of ideas
yeah I mean it of course maybe why they
still for choice but I was kind of
hoping for so much more I was thinking
we're gonna Crush but uh we're not
crashing here I think very likely Jan
maybe saw some issue with Queen F3
just to briefly go back to this point
just to demonstrate what he might have
considered because in that position by
the way after E5 D5 I didn't see a
finishing blow here so maybe he was not
convinced with this position for example
well Knight ABS check has to be
calculated but it just yeah I would play
Devil's Advocate and say just
intuitively this just seems so much more
juicy than let's say the position after
Knight F5 Queen F6 which could arise in
the game I wanted to sneak in a point
though because I know ding is going to
make a move and it's gonna be too late
is it possible that nepo did indeed miss
queen E5 maybe because he was so fixated
on the battery the black built on F2
that he forgot to consider Queen moves
could it be the case that nepo missed
Queen E5 realized that he missed it as
ding was thinking and decided to take
the strategy of playing quickly to
nonetheless convincing that things are
going according to plan or am I you know
doing too much speculating
I know you're probably exactly right uh
you are probably exactly right and
um that is likely what what happened he
probably saw this diagonal here I
thought the ding's point is to IVF to
Paul so he first thought about Queen F3
and he uh some move well I mean I don't
know maybe it was a move like rookie
eight or whatever he he didn't think
about 25 probably he thought it's not so
simple he was calculating Knight F5
takes takes a queen comes to E5 there
this may be demonstrated yeah because it
didn't happen in the game but it could
be relevant to his thinking process and
maybe he thought well you know in this
position I'd rather have my queen
already on G4 so he went Queen G4 and
indeed he just missed the smoke 25
altogether very likely and uh then he
will realized okay time to go for Plan B
Knight F3 you know it's um reminds me
somewhat of the first game there to uh
opening was played very well he's built
up a big advantage and then when the
time came to make something of it
started taking the time and slowly
started making wrong decisions I think a
similar kind of pattern happening here
as well he's definitely given up a large
portion of his Advantage but we will see
still plenty of life in the position
maybe there will come a second wave of
um of the attack after Knight to five
maybe he'll be able to still get an
advantage because I still prefer White
Knight over Black's Bishop but of course
this is not what could have been yeah I
think white is still not risking that
much is clear black spawn structure is
still inferior uh even if you know the
evil bar now gives essentially all zeros
and Knight F5 follows instantly so NEPA
whether he saw this or not uh that
doesn't change his speed of flight and
it's kind of ironic at each that the one
move in this game on which he actually
took more than let's say three minutes
uh turned out to be a maybe not a
serious mistake although I would call it
a mistake I think it is a serious
mistake because Queen F3 would have led
uh even objectively to a clear advantage
and now the position if ding can play
Queen F6 which is not necessarily a
given that can be a hard move to play uh
because it can be hard psychologically
not to just take this Knight off the
board but if you play Queen F6 we can
safely assert that nepo's Advantage from
an objective point of view has been
erased
yeah and it is not uh new at all the
idea of overthinking uh is is not new
people you know making mistake after a
long thought is the most common thing in
the world it happens a lot because first
of all yes when you start to overthink
you know your question your thinking
process you start uh looking too deep
into things and also sometimes just the
fact that you are thinking long it means
that you don't understand what to do and
that well even though you spend more
time you still don't know what to do and
you make a mistake so nothing new there
uh it's very common to make an
inaccurate mistake or an accuracy after
a long thought but before we
before we sort of talk about this
narrative for too long let's first uh
let ding make that decision here because
if he takes on a fight which is also
tempting after EF could have six Queen
E4 we saw the situation okay it could
still get out of control for doing as
the queen from E4 can aim for all these
weaknesses
um the black has on the queen side
instead of black has to really find this
move queen of six I believe and it's
here that uh ding should actually be be
fine although yeah still still questions
maybe takes queen of five live
yes but
E5
maybe if I have somewhere Maybe not
immediately
um maybe somewhere maybe 25 first
um
well The Bishop's quite stable here
these pawns are also nicely placed this
is definitely an advantage for black
compared to how how it was there yeah
but maybe you know we still have a nice
light Square play here with the Knight
on the king side the spawnage five there
is some aesthetic value and wise
position as well so maybe still some
Advantage some small edges there but uh
after Queen F6 which I think ding will
find yeah very little will will be left
from Jan's of Jan's advantage
and with the King a lot safer right a
pair of knights is gone black doesn't
have to worry about getting checkmated
given things time it's just so much
easier I think to make the value of each
move the margin of error increases for
dang so 40 minutes uh now for you know
12 moves doesn't sound like all that
little now now that the position is
clarified and a minor pair of minor
pieces is going to come off the board I
think we are going to see Queen F6
um and it's an instructive moment right
I think a lot of people would be tempted
a knight takes F5 just because you want
to take the Knight off the board and you
want to double white spawns but the cons
of this move greatly outweigh the pros
the fact that you open up the e-file and
White's Rook is uniquely positioned to
take advantage of it the fact that you
open up these prospects for White's
Queen uh those two things make Knight
takes F5 a serious positional and
accuracy and we are about to see a move
by ding he was hesitating there let's
see if he can maintain his composure and
play the best defensive move Queen E6 to
F6 simply keeping the status quo and
defending against the maid on G7
yeah I think uh if you make a mistake of
Knight X5 you do that quickly because
superficially that was like my first
thought I just thought you know I take
uh take take and bring the queen here
and Knight is dominated and then I
realized always second Queen E4 is there
so you can sort of make this mistake
quickly but once you already think for
as long as dig thinks use notice Queen
E4
and then I think you realize that okay
whatever the issues after Queen F6 are
they are not as big as the ones after
Knight xf5 first so I think ding will uh
after some time play Queen F6
uh
all although I have to say also Knight
F5 EF could have 624 it doesn't look
lost for black either
no
and you you know you have some potential
Financial D5 D4 so maybe you'll then
think I'll go to B8 Bishop C5
to try to stabilize and maybe have some
before ideas that don't doesn't look
terrible actually frankly and uh when
you trade on F5 you also diffuse the
potential E5 ideals you know
because after Queen F6 you you have some
E5 idea somewhere after take stakes and
queen to F5 and to D5 so
not an obvious choice here by no means I
have to say
for example uh so let's let's make this
on the board just to see what uh dick is
calculating through here 95 EF could
have six green E4 so Rook B8 I guess
Queen to where even Queen what is
exactly the problem
um well Queen D5 and then maybe Knight
d294 seems like an option
let's let's maybe uh indeed
yeah not not shocked not shocked I mean
I'm not shocked uh it doesn't look uh so
bad to me to be very honest
I agree and I think people the chat
should realize like we're not talking
here about the difference between a
winning advantage and an equal position
this is gradations of an advantage white
is better everywhere but after Queen F6
White's Advantage we thought was
minuscule here maybe nepo has somewhat
more practical chances one question
though nepa's gonna take back with the
pawn as soon as he comes back to the
board
is Queen F6 Force like Queen D5 runs
into F6 and that's game over
Queen D7 looks really awkward as well I
think ding might play Queen F6 right
away
yeah yeah I think I think kind of
success is essentially forced although
as you mentioned 27 I realize it's a
possibility too but it's
no it's it it's like it's an alternative
basically sometimes you look for an
alternative for the sake of looking for
an alternative this is one of those
moments
um that said
are some advantages to that move you
keep control of the D5 Square so for
example Queen E4 is not met by D5 so 27
actually is not
out of the question at all and it might
be the best move now that I made it and
Rocky a becomes a possibility can be
swung to F6 actually Bishop da Bishop F6
could put an end to White shenanigans on
the king side so
dang the again and you made a great
point the fact that he is thinking tells
us he doesn't believe that Queen F6 is
totally automatic no but you are
actually right I I didn't sequence the
seven as a possibility and in fact uh if
he plays Queen the seven it could even
be that taking on F5 was the more
accurate of the two uh you know the
gradation between all this 0.20.4 okay
now he went for Queen F6 the more
natural one of course the more natural
yeah you know 27 was the top engine move
actually it was it was the only way to
keep a position close to equality now
I think once again the size of nepo's
Advantage is comparable to what it would
have been if he played Queen F3 instead
of Queen G4 of course the nature of his
Advantage is now a lot more positional
whereas after Queen F3 there he would
have been tactically better but I mean
this has got to be a relief for yawn do
you think he realized that black comes
close to equalizing after Queen F6
immediately
I think I think to be honest
um from a human perspective and I'm
looking at this position I don't have
the engine moves let's say I see the
evaluation but from my human perspective
I feel that okay code F3 was the most
scary like I think I I could be on the
verge of losing theirs like maybe I
exaggerated dangerous but I would be
like Queen FC would be like a huge huge
issue uh after Queen G4
I would think that after 95 Queen F6 I'm
slightly worse after Knight X5 EF 27 I'm
slightly worse and f95 EF could have six
on slightly worse now I would have to
try to compare which of these slightly
verses are more slightly and which of
them are more worse but I've noticed an
engine I don't know what 0.2 what's 0.7
what's 0.4 like
it's hard to say I see that there are
advantages and disadvantages to all of
these like here the advantages I keep
your phone uh in in full control and in
check yeah you don't have any Dynamic
possibilities you don't have E5 you
don't have F6
I control your Pawn completely your
knight is uh kind of controlled as well
my Bishop controls the D4 square
9294 is a very long route and also an
abstract one that for now with the queen
on e4 so I think what ding did is the
most stable way to play so I I think I
could even see myself do the same thing
uh to be very honest
I could see myself making the same
mistake
so I wouldn't be too harsh uh on uh
anyway yeah I think it's just very
difficult and
well you I like with D5 and not the
bishop C5 you could start 1994 I also
really like G3 King G2 I have this
obsession with yeah maybe even G4 by the
way very G4 right if you're already you
know move ing your king away from the
diagonal maybe G4 uh just captures more
space and creates the later potential of
G5 so I wouldn't abandon given the fact
of the night the presence of the night
the idea of a king side attack later
down the line absolutely and I think the
main advantage of the move G4 over the
move G3 that I see is that uh for
example after Queen D5 Bishop C5 G4
B4 I can take Queen takes C4
and after bcbc my F5 Pawn is protected
so it guards the F5 Pawn uh as well
which is I think a very important uh
thing I think G5 let's say is still
early G5 is a long way to go but
protecting the F5 Pawn is nice and after
G4 I can also potentially go with my
queen to um 2 C6 I really like this
construction because you know this move
is weakening a bunch of squares but all
of these squares there okay they're uh
protected by the Knight so after G4 I
control all of these squares on the king
side and after King G2 even more uh
basically after kinship 2 I will be
controlling all the squares around my
king
and literally I actually would go so far
as to say that if it would like to move
here before would come very close to
solving All Black's problems tactically
because C takes before Queen takes B2
and if you play Queen take C4 to your
point the F5 fun hangs and that looks
incredibly charged so G4 is not only an
aggressive move it's also prophylactic
because you're protecting the F5 Pawn
taking this thing out of B4 there's
probably other ways to defend against
before but I think it's crucial for nepo
to identify that as a threat because
Queen D5 doesn't actually defend against
before I think that would be a serious
mistake which would Fritter away uh the
remnants of White's advantage
yes and exactly that's the exactly the
point after 25 Bishop C5 was a mistake
indeed before is actually the threat and
indeed G4 is uh right now immediately
the best move I think at least okay we
have to check with the computer later
but from what I see uh I think G4 is the
is the way to go here and I think ding
has underestimated that because after G4
I no longer see
um
a move for him which uh which is
attractive as before loses the pawn and
if you let me improve my position
further G4 King G2 I'll stabilize even
further I will find a way to improve it
at some point you know I will be
penetrating with my queen I can at some
point try to enter with my Rook
very very juicy position for Jan uh
yandere and okay we have to say it
anyway it was nice for white
but uh this yeah now I can I can sort of
sense why allowing EF was not the best
of the ideas and I am looking forward to
see yam play G4 because I think from a
human perspective once you see G4 you
cannot resist
yeah I mean because it accomplishes so
many things and what makes Black's
position art is just there's no end
point to the suffering it's not like
okay I need to make a couple of moves
and then I'll be able to trade off a
bunch of Pawns and I can stabilize and
it's not even like white is attacking
and if black defends accurately you know
he will be fine Black's weaknesses are
chronic Black's Pawn structure is
inferior Black's minor piece is inferior
and as you point out white has so many
easy ways so much low-hanging fruit that
he can pick off the tree G4 King G2
Queen D5 Knight F3 can travel from D2 to
E4 White's Rook controls the most
important open file
man I mean I don't want to overstate the
case I think an engine would draw this
100 times out of 100 obviously
but I think you're right I think ding
you know he was so happy to rid himself
of the immediate problems with his King
that he might have underestimated the
other types of problems in this position
and his King may still face problems if
white tonight ever reaches E4
I think it simply means G4 I think the
way I think uh plays chess is a very
concrete uh very concrete way he is
calculating a lot
and uh I think he was simply calculating
this position and he saw that before
he's coming so he calculated Queen D5
before he calculated G3 before and he
was content I think G4 uh escaped his
relator because it's a very weakening
move usually speaking but here somehow
with the Knight on F3 and these spawns
here everything is completely under
control and uh this surprising move G4
it just escaped his attention I'm sure
if he if he saw it coming he would never
go for this position now I realize why
all the Alternatives were better
only now that I see G4 do I realize okay
I better had been to go Queen to seven
at night if I better had been to go
Queen F6 instead of Knight X F5 so it's
all you know the chess is kind of a
weird game where often you combine these
positional factors such as the good
night
say for King weak squares with concrete
moves
and this is a good example of how this
concrete move G4 suddenly makes the
whole thing work and okay black of
course still has uh I mean there's first
of all there is no clear threat and
that's a big thing that
um that black has going for him is that
uh
rookie two best move actually according
to the engine same exact idea he's
protecting the B2 Pawn ah okay after B4
C takes B4 there's no follow-up we Chad
was actually saying that rookie 2 is
preferred by stockfish G4 was also good
a rookie 2 is computer best and nepo I
think he smells it wow what a moment and
he delivers in the critical moment
wow yeah uh I got a bit excited there by
the pretty pretty move G4 but actually
rookie 2 serves the same purpose and is
less committal maybe G3 King jutu is
actually
more flexible not weakening at all uh so
wow yeah Rocky 2 is a strong move let's
see okay Bishop C5 Bishop C5 is a move
trying to stabilize the position but it
doesn't really create a threat of before
no well wait sorry
it does now the Creator thread up before
well I think Now's the Time for G4 now
is the perfect time to reinforce the F5
Pawn
yes I have to yeah because before
it's a threat now because previously you
could play C takes before now of course
uh the way to meet before is Queen takes
C4 so you need to reinforce the F5 Pawn
I have a feeling nepo will play G4
pretty quickly because he's understood
that what he needs to do right now is
take the sting out of B4 and then he can
proceed just to improve his position he
has carte blanche
and do you see uh do you see why G4
first was less accurate
um so I'm trying to understand why uh
rookito first was miraculous I don't
quite answer this is some concrete the
evaluations were very very similar so I
think it might be virtually identical
yeah because I guess yeah basically as
long as you prevent it before it's also
important to realize that probably the
time is not such an important factor any
longer because black doesn't have any
counter play besides this idea of before
so as soon as you take it out of the of
the way and I'm glad that G4 Still
Remains relevant would be Peter we spoke
so much about G4 we've sang so many
praises to the move and I'm glad it
Still Remains relevant in this position
because otherwise it would look
completely stupid but now yes G4 still
has to be found and it is indeed a
beautiful and important move and I hope
Yan will play it quickly showing the you
know
it would be on style yeah quickly right
he would be such non-style and it
reminds me of the second game where he
puts pressure on the clock as well as on
the board and we call it a G4 already on
the board he played it instantly he was
just not at the board
such a juicy position and I love this
position white there's so much in
control is
oh if it's a juicy juicy position and
I'm fearing for ding oh this is yup not
looking good at all
and ding now has to figure out a way to
even like not doing anything Anish is
hard
would be way too strong of a word here
but Queen back to d8 maybe but that
opens up path for the F Pawn it closes
the Rooks control of the eighth rank not
a move you really want to play unless
you have to Bishop C5 back to B6 well
then the D6 and B5 pawns are are not as
well defended so not only does ding have
to figure out a way to do nothing he has
to come to terms with the fact that he's
not going to be able to play before
yes uh I I think
um one of the the thoughts you might
have is uh to nevertheless go before
the idea being that you want to simplify
even at the cost of the pawn after
before B takes C3 bxc3 maybe you can
activate the Rook with Ruby one check
very dubious idea of course told by Rook
C1 I don't buy it at all I don't think
it will it will happen I don't think
it's good I think at the end of the
variation I'll play King G2 and then I
will penetrate on the eighth rank with
my rook and the queen so I don't think
that is a good idea I think bringing the
bishop back is also harmful because
Bishop is really well placed as you
mentioned and I think by elimination I
would I would consider Queen d8 I think
28 is not terrible because also F6 is
not yet an idea I am maybe hinting at
the move G5
maybe and
I could well let's say if you make a
rook to move the Rook to D2 print into
file then I will have the opportunity to
go Queen it so I think 28 uh is is a
move that you could actually play
reasonably quickly I don't see a big
disadvantage
of it uh what do you think do you see
any flow with that
not tactically I think Queen d8 might be
met with Queen D5
to stop D5 uh of course yes queen d8
queen D5 uh is possible then actually I
have
maybe a rook A8 trying to but again you
know a problem with activating The Rook
I think it doesn't bring so much and in
fact you will allow me to activate my
own and when I penetrate the first the
back rank it will lead to Checkmate
because your king is stuck here uh while
if you penetrate my knight will protect
my my team for now so
indeed a very difficult position for
black what black wants is to trade well
trading Queens would be a dream that
would be fine trading roofs would be a
big relief as well but I think the big
problem for training vision for a night
is completely unrealistic so that's not
even talk about it but uh yeah I think
if I could jump with my queen to B7 or
if I could somehow magically prepare uh
like go like Cricket Cafe 28 so if I
would trade one of these pieces I would
be in a much better shape as black but I
think somehow swapping the pieces around
and trying to rearrange for such a trade
is difficult especially because if you
move the queen too far away from F6 then
F6 uh or G5 or both will be on the radar
so yeah a difficult situation for black
queen d8 perhaps but after Queen D5
that's the square one not sure very
difficult very very difficult position
for black
and I would also point out as
far-fetched as this may seem I think
it's an important tactical observation
the pawns on F5 and H5 create a
vice-like grip over the G6 Square why is
that important well there is this
scenario uh where even in the event of a
queen's trade black gets Checkmate it's
a for example maybe we can make these
moves on the board let's say black plays
Queen d8 and white plays King G2 let's
say queen D7 if white tonight is on H4
and I believe Queen B7 and I'm not
saying that white should play Knight H4
I just want to illustrate the concept
here there's a trade followed by rookie
8 and Knight G6 of course Queen G6 check
would also result in a Checkmate of this
kind because you have to take and uh
White's pawns uh should not be written
off yeah they're optically damaged
because of the double death pawns but
they also create massive tactical
potential whether it's F5 F6 uh or
whether it's a knight or a queen
appearing on G6 uh in the event that the
king is driven to H7 so
I don't think we're exaggerating ding is
in trouble and right now he's not only
choosing a move he's coming to terms
with a new task that awaits him not just
in the foreseeable future but very
likely for the rest of the game
yes and Daniel I once again have a good
angle on the players and I can tell you
I told it to you in a previous game and
uh
you know ding's ears are also turning
red and I mean I don't want to make that
point again
but it is a very good indicator of uh of
missing something big and that's what
happened to Jan after uh the spectacular
routes before last game here G4 is less
of a blow but it's still a very very big
one I think giving the time situation
and how horrible this position looks
ding is on the verge of the defeat here
and if he escapes this position that
will be a tremendous achievement in
terms of accomplishment for him
I am very very worried for him here I
think still the path to Salvation begins
with maybe
yeah but the thing is if you try to
improve your position it might uh very
quickly get worse I was looking at queen
d8 queen D5 maybe some Queen to D7 using
the dragon F6 is not yet possible maybe
I want Queen B7 trading the Queensbury
95. yeah it's um but maybe maybe it's
okay maybe 95 Queen E8 or queen E7 even
maybe it's fine maybe it's fine
no tactics there I guess just just not
and um
yeah black has to be very accurate if
that kind of operation works by the way
I could I could Escape potentially so I
have some potential there 28 I think is
the only chance to somehow solve the
problems immediately I don't see simply
any other move that makes any sense to
me but well difficult it's a long shot
to indeed and also yeah long shot this
condition can be some idea but perhaps
the the best black has at this point
yeah oh no sorry it doesn't work like
just to finish because you made a good
point this idea of media doesn't work
because queen d8 queen D5 Queen D7
um
threats because I can still take and the
point you made earlier check at Knight
H4 that will just be made oh wow even if
it's black to move you can't get the
Rook off of the eighth rank so that's
such a debilitating feeling right that
even the best case scenario results in
Checkmate so you hypothetically can't
even get any of the heavy pieces off the
board my guess would be ding's gonna go
for B4 at some point I don't I I don't
think he's gonna have the you know
patience is the wrong word maybe he has
to play before at some point try to open
up the queen side and deflect White's
attention away from the e-file and the
King side the question is is when you
know now or maybe after queen d8 queen
D5 but if I had to make a guess I think
ding's gonna go B4 at some point
well
I'd be skeptical I understand what
you're trying to do but you're basically
just giving me a pawn and yeah
I I think that's
that's not going to help very much
I think giving giving upon no I think
what I was thinking is the the likely
was after Queen D5 to go Queen to seven
nonetheless but not with the idea could
be someone with ideal rookie eight
because rookie I think it's safer I
think I can afford to trade uh Queens
because I the Rooks because I get to
keep control of the back rank so I think
Queen d8 is the uh the way I think
before it's too desperate and I think it
doesn't solve your problems you will
still end up with the same problems you
have only not have a point just down a
pawn yeah exactly I'll have the
conversation so
think your best shot is Queen D7
followed by rookie which makes me wonder
if Queen D5 is the best move
but
if I may interject with a tactic uh we
can make the moves on the board Queen
theater is has been played Queen D5
Queen D7 I can play King G2
and what happens if I wait for rookie in
and then play 95 and then try to take on
F7
no I guess that doesn't work wait why
does that lose
because apparently yeah because after
Queenie Queen E7 white does nothing I
guess
uh even Queen C7 I'm just wondering like
Knight of seven is not
ah is it oh is it or is it a check
waiter
I guess I can't take up my idea was
Knight takes F7 Rook takes rook and then
some sort of Discovery but I guess I
guess there's nothing good here Knight
H6 King H7 Queen G8 King H6 and the King
runs out to G5
so why instantly sorry absolutely
yeah but after Queen D7 okay Queen Seven
is the only move that gives black hope
okay also Queen f8 is of course
um the similar purpose but yeah now
these squares are really very vulnerable
and I suspect
s move like F6 or G5 becomes extremely
juicy
yeah that's the benefit of Queen D7 I
guess you're keeping an eye on the F5
sure yeah Queen design is better because
idea is that F6 I will collect here that
was the idea
yeah very important for Yan not to fall
overly in love with the prospect of
winning the game tactically and to
remain patient
yes
what is the best move here you could
even give up
the file or you of course even if you
trade Rooks you still keep an advantage
I suspect
but uh
this would be somewhat of a relief for
black don't you feel
well at least morally and of course
that's certain Queen takes C5 but Rook
D2 black and move the queen aside maybe
the E7 yeah yeah it's an achievement for
me to have grabbed to have grab control
of the e-file even Queen C8 also to keep
an eye on the G4 Pawn this would
definitely be a huge achievement for
black to control the e-file the file
that matters so much I think King G2 is
maybe slow so Master 27 but we already
have this position on the board at the
queen developed so now ding has to play
Queen to seven and we reach the critical
position I think here white has to come
up with a
with a good move
and maybe it is G5
maybe it is G5
yeah G5 does come to mind
and then if like trades and plays rookie
Knight F7 this one now there's Knight
takes F7 now Knight F7 Works in 95
checks yeah yeah it's nice
so is this one tactic update that I my
you know my contact day
well I'm a broken record that's all I'm
thinking Knight takes F7 in every
position yes exactly so well certainly
looks super problematic okay it
immediately uh but then
I'm wondering if there is a direct
finish because the computer is shouting
us at us but
I think is it 95 but now Queen takes up
five I think oh yeah F5
or is it just positional take G6 winner
G6 yeah yeah yeah yeah no yeah oh this
is completely yes paralyzed because
black is paralyzed of course yeah yeah I
was just thinking maybe the computer
wants something more but actually this
is a good enough like it's completely
tied down to the square this G5 G6 is a
huge upgrade uh yeah uh well
you're talking about Alpha zero earlier
uh get Alpha zero loves this kind of
Pawns yeah it's fantastic
so I think yeah I think Windows 7 G5
that is simply the that is simply it I
don't know uh I don't know why the bar
is not all the way up yet but as far as
I'm concerned my bar is all the way up I
think it's uh it's it's positional GG
here
if Napa plays G5 ding might have to go
to the bar in the hotel because this is
just incredibly nasty the time situation
uh is getting worse it may seem like
he's almost at move 40 but but no this
is move 34 and for the first time we're
actually looking at lines or black loses
so
you know the cost of a mistake is now at
an all-time high one more mistake and
the game is lost immediately
and this is the worst possible moment to
reach this kind of situation
yeah and again I think the bar doesn't
represent the difficulties dingness uh
facing
I'm thinking of a way oh maybe is it
King to F I'm afraid any move I'll
suggests the bar will just shoot up so
watch this
wow oh wow thank you uh I made it no but
I have I I spotted this idea of G6 Queen
B7 which is uh
a very lucky resource very lucky oh and
you're defending against rookie eight
with your king that was the idea yeah
I'm barely and I've trapped your queen
for a trade and and also there is no
longer a back rank issue because my
Kings defends itself
well actually this is probably the this
is actually the defense yeah so Queen
the seven G5 King f8 is findable I mean
I've I somehow found it but uh well it's
not easy very very desperate as well
what's crazy is that after King f8 uh
Knight E5 again you know I'm like then
that's all I'm thinking about I think
black still has Queen takes F5 and even
though Knight G6 is a check it doesn't
work because of FG of black defends the
queen so maybe 95 Queen takes F5 and
then some move
um but this doesn't seem like the right
path for white so being fate I guess
white six Ninja Four is there already it
gets messy
it gets messy they can can somehow
zigzag up to G3 but okay that has to be
calculated and that's exactly why nepo
has left himself with an hour
but yeah uh GH Queen to D2 is also sort
of a thing
but then maybe there is King G7
maybe this thing G7
maybe queen of five also isn't losing
wow very complicated lines uh very
dangerous for black but at this point if
it works for black it might it might be
fine so let's say now we are reaching
the point especially especially after
Queen 7 G5 in f8 where
a couple of moves will happen and either
white will win or black will will make a
draw we are reaching the resize the
moment
we are indeed and we have one more uh we
have to take a break so we will give
ding the opportunity to ponder his move
but we will bring you all of the action
as it unfolds uh we promise you that but
before we go on a quick break we wanted
to remind you that if you dream of
playing the fide World Championship
just.com has made your dreams come true
you can now challenge both World
Championship contenders in bot form
dangly Wren and Jana pomishibots are
available for play right now at
chess.com play slash computer so head
over there and let us know if you can
beat the bots of course uh first finish
this game use x Glam FWC bots in chat
uh and Challenge nepo and ding well
dingley Ren is pondering this incredibly
important moment he is in crisis mode
Jana pamushi is knocking on the door of
what would be an absolutely huge World
Championship victory that would send him
back over the edge and give him that one
point lead we will be back with more
fide World Championship action on the
other side of this short break
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the feed 8 World
Championship which is held in Astana
what the former world champion Magnus
Carlson weird to refer to him that way
is in Los Angeles where he is playing a
poker event along with other streamers
and influencers such as Alexander botes
and Agnes Carlson posting on Instagram
there saying Astana is calling so he is
watching the match very carefully
well we wish Magnus the very best and
the best of luck in his poker endeavors
and right now dingley Ren needs a fair
dose of luck in his fifth match game
against Jana Palmer Grandmaster
nishikiri grow Master Daniel nerdinski
bring you commentary of the fifth round
of the feed a world championship okay
since we went to break King f8 has been
dingleren's choice so Anish you called
it I think he is initiating a larger
strategy uh in which he wants to bring
his Queen over to B7 and the reason you
need to play King f8 is in order to
protect that E8 square with the King
what do you make of this move
yeah actually
sorry I just noticed the 95 option but I
was gonna say that I actually liking
afraid even more than Queen D7 to an
extent because with the black queen
still controls these uh two squares
and so he remains more flexible uh but
King on f8 is generally a good idea as
we mentioned already because of this
could be seven idea where the king
protects this important EA Square there
is an option of Knight E5 here uh
what do you make of that
uh 95 Bishop
takes F2 is a good option there because
after that we will trade a bunch of
pieces and I was hoping of course after
D5 to to win the full Pawn but this this
no longer works so it's actually taken
maybe start with kimchi too
in G2 is definitely a uh an option the
question is though after Queen D7 how do
you exploit uh
how do you avoid Queen B7 and how to
exploit uh that extra Tempo you have now
to come to make something happen
yeah that's the big question between B7
is definitely coming next now even in
the end game I think white would retain
some chances of an advantage but nepo
ideally would want to find a more
concrete way to cash in his chips in the
middle game
F6 doesn't work because G4 hangs with
check
if you play King G3 here maybe
maybe white shouldn't get fixated on
keeping the queen on D5 and should meet
Queen B7 with like Queen D5 to D2
but that is a step backward to be to be
sure so maybe King H3 no but then the
Knight on F3 hangs so King G3
Queen B7 and queen D2 what do you make
of that idea I think then I
I I understand uh you're going for the
second wave business here with F6 but we
have to
first of all
it's a very complicated position but I
was wondering about rookiee but I'm
worried if okay that you will take and
go F6 here and then collect the H1
that's the plan yeah yeah no it's
sometimes the second wave of the attack
is even more unpleasant than the first
you sort of you sort of defend and push
back the pieces for for a bit but then
you realize that you know it's still a
long way to go that said that said uh
okay
I am wondering like that's why do you of
course want something more than that you
want to go forward before you go
backwards
so I would still take a look at the
starting position
and see what what my options are here
because it's not
not obvious
not obvious how to
make something happen because if Queen
D7 I go Knight E5 you go Queen B7 I go
Knight C6
you have rookie to E8 yeah I'm just
wondering if I just give a give you a
move you have rookie 8 there
no you should also point out I would
also point at the queen C8 Queen C8 as
possible to to render 95 impossible
because it protects the bishop on C5
King F1 is nepo's choice
so deep let's think but I like I like
this I like this move because I don't
know what the point is but if you made
it
then um like I think it must be smart
I'm just trying to figure out why
you know uh okay tell me
no I don't I thought maybe he wants to
make Quincy with the immediate F6 but I
don't see a response there the queen
takes G4 maybe they're attacking rookie
seven rookie seven that's the response
oh he wants F6 oh yeah yeah that's what
he wants we should show that on the
analysis board so King G1 F1 why so that
black takes the G4 Pawn it's not a check
anymore that gives white a Tempo and if
you play F6 here which is a typical idea
I mean takes you for rates great find
rookie seven Queen H3 check is an empty
check King 82 in the black has to give
up a queen to stop checkmate
wow you know I I when I saw king of Juan
I knew this is an absolutely great move
I don't know why but I knew that okay if
the guy made it there must be some
brilliant justification and this is
actually quite brilliant stuff
this is really brilliant stuff king of
one um
now GF is GF uh is GF Queen D2 or what
is what is GF
that's the big question right also after
Queen c86 GF what's the follow-up here
that's well I mean I I can take my time
yeah I can even uh even if we envision
an end game here I can manage 495 like
somewhere the question is what is the
order so I suspect maybe Queen to D2
okay
and if King G7 maybe simply Queen F4 and
next I go Knight H4
and once the Knight lands on F5 the game
is over so black basically has one tempo
to do something about it
yeah wow it's just so and he plays so
fast also okay F1
if I would ever play King of one that
would be a very very long thing I can
tell you that
yeah is a special player of course oh so
much pressure ding has 18 minutes for
how many moves okay only five but these
are the five these are the five moves in
these five moves he can he can lose the
game
these are the crucial five moves and the
five most difficult moves that he's made
because again the price of a mistake is
now at an all-time high one mistake and
you let the Knight get into F5 and you
lose the game so the tactics are
starting at the most inconvenient
possible moment for dinky is most tired
and he has the least amount of time to
make time control
I think when your opponent plays King F1
uh very often you lose this game you
lose this game this is this kind of move
yeah this is this kind of move that wins
that wins games it's the move that you
100 missed in a situation uh where you
already looked like you are in the bad
shape King F1 is that one blow that uh
they can knock you down but uh full fate
in faith in ding here
he has some time on the clock and he has
tremendous calculator maybe he will find
the defense here these lines like for
example Queen D7 F6 GF Queen D2 I was
not sure about Queen takes G4 with xh6
yeah or maybe even in G8
oh
intending some counter checks of my own
so I was not or queen j7 yeah I don't
know I was not sure could you tell maybe
I go back I was not sure but let's just
say that it's it's not lost yeah it's
it's white gets something going
some kind of play uh commences some kind
of checks appear but it's not winning
and maybe if ding just
calls this what could be a bluff it
could work out but for sure the pressure
is on and yeah you know he doesn't
always make the best moves but he puts
pressure that's that's for sure
yeah now in 16 minutes sounds like a
long time but when you're sitting there
and you're digging you're calculating
you know five six minutes can go on
exactly one line and then you look up
you've got eight minutes and obviously
John hasn't calculated all of the
ramifications of King F1 you could take
an hour and barely scratch the surface
so he's using his intuition his
intuition is incredible and it's well
established that it's incredible but Jan
is risking I mean obviously by relying
on his intuition in a position like this
it might be possible that one of the
lines he thinks uh is incredibly
promising contains a hidden defense
maybe black and force the trade of
Queens uh in a certain position and make
a draw but
that's Jana punish you for you that's
what he does
yes but even what you said like uh it
ended with you know black making a draw
like how big a risk is that so
all in all a decent practical call by
yanto uh make this king of one move and
make it fast
and well I think I see the bar dips a
little so here the blusher Advantage
than this I don't know what was the
computer's uh approach computer's
approach was surely better but whatever
whatever it is the bar is still liking
white here and I think yes dink has uh
lots of questions to answer even if
everything goes well for dig
when everything goes well for dink he
will maybe make a draw but yeah the
situation is looking good for for Jana I
think a sort of a similar situation to
the game one except much better this
time for Jan much better I think ding is
under even more pressure than that time
Jan also has a lot of time he has 58
minutes if ding makes a mistake he has a
lot of time to pound on it
and if dink keeps uh responding well Yad
has time to recuperate and find another
question now
fantastic message by Slayer by the way
the ding is playing Minesweeper one
mistake and the game is basically over
not Queen C8 he actually moved his Rook
to C8
okay age
I think it's a desperate move I think
it's a desperate move I think he thought
uh Quincy and queen lose to this F6 idea
or something like that
um
might be G5 also maybe maybe Jan wanted
to go G5
um but Rook C8 is basically saying I
think the point is like this he thinks
Queen December Queen C8 are losing
because of F6 or G5 because I think ju5
is also by the way interesting idea now
that I
think about it again uh oh my oh my God
can I show you one variation on the
board it's absolutely
I don't know if it's relevant but it's
just so beautiful so after Queen C8
um
G5 Queen B7
can I play GH oh
and H7 oh I I cannot I cannot because
yeah I take the rook and then the king
E7 stops the pawn yeah I still couldn't
do one but I'm missing it so oh wow that
would be pretty but anyway something
along these lines so uh ding was
terrified of all this kind of queen the
seven F6 business and he played Rook
seed because he saw that he has no time
on the clock he has to make a move Queen
said he doesn't like so he keeps control
of these squares just makes a waiting
move saying okay I'm going to make a
move and beat me now literally I think
he's gonna go Rook C8 Rook B8 Rook C8
and he's keeping his Queen on d8 to
prevent F6 and to prevent G5 so nepo I
think now is gonna make some sort of
slow move if he can find a way to
prepare F6 or prepare G5 he will make
ding regret the move Rook C8 because not
only does Rook C8 not do anything per se
it also removes the possibility of the
queen trade along the AAA H1 diagonal
now Queen D7
I guess it might prepare Queen C6 but we
already know that Queen D7 runs into 95.
so I think nepo has a Tempo how does he
use this Tempo to prepare one of the
pawn breaks like F6 or G5 do you see
anything off the top of your head uh
that that efficiently prepares the
particularly the F6 Pawn break I think
is the one that he's aiming for
um well it's I think it's quite easy to
understand this position well not
understand but it's quite easy to to
come up with the move here if you look
at the position so you just you have
very limited options with white
your queen is well placed your Knights
well you can try rerouting it but I
guess you don't want to allow open H4
yeah so I guess by elimination you gotta
move the rook and you could try to move
it up here or you could try to move it
around the problem with moving The Rook
around is that even after you do that
it's still not clear where you uh landed
because all these crucial squares are
taken so I think Jinx defense is
actually sensible I think he's just
standing and uh waiting for Jan to to
show us and I don't see what Young can
show us because
rocking
Rocky foreign
that's very awkward but very awkward by
process of elimination I mean yeah maybe
but I even after that maybe I have some
okay it's possible of course yeah it's
possible the problem is now Queen F6
runs into Queen B7 that's another
downside of Rook C8 it opens up the B7
Square for White's Queen
yeah yes and uh
yeah yeah might well play rookie 4 I
like rookie for you
uh and if I make another waiting move
yep Rook B8 for example Rook F4 ah maybe
now Queen F6 yeah that was my thought
but uh maybe you can enter with the
queen somewhere like here
the bar keeps swinging back and forth
because okay we are humans unfortunately
yeah I mean this position is insanely
Hard to Handle I mean there's also G5 in
response to Queen F6 and then Rook G4
this might be going a step too far
though
no no the bar loves it okay I didn't see
this idea it's a very very strong idea
now immediately oh it's also young style
this is Young style yeah
yeah rookie four actually rookie 4 is
also a move um
it's a move it's not non-committal move
uh it's a sort of a risk-free move you
can make rookie for uh instantly without
any he'll make it probably instantly oh
my God yeah
and it is the top move and I think he
sees the idea of F6
and what you said about it being
non-committal so important because he
knows that worse comes to worst oh I
calculate Rook F4 it doesn't work big
deal right The Rook is on E2 it's on e4
it doesn't matter that's what makes
ding's position so depressing White's
moves are all completely risk-free
he is losing it I mean he's losing it
because this idea of standing and
waiting it doesn't work we tried it nope
so it doesn't work because of Rooker 4
and this G5 I think he is um he's he's
done here he's done here um a miracle
only a miracle will say I'm even
wondering by the way if I cannot play G5
here huh oh my God all sorts of sick I
mean sick tactics like I don't know like
H6 I mean all kinds of ideas come to
mind here
now this is really really bad you cannot
stand and wait here apparently with
black uh really bad bad stuffs coming
your way no this is this is over too
many breakthroughs and I think ding had
that one opportunity on the previous
move and he had to use it to get his
Queen to B7 come by her by hooker by
crook you know whether the end game was
defensible or not now that he's
forfeited that opportunity
Jan is gonna play F6 or G5 and he's just
gonna smash throw on the king side
yeah not not good uh not good for doing
um
this you know a remarkable match really
remarkable I believe ding will come back
by the way after this game as well I
think it's going to be an incredible
match and uh there's so many plots plot
twists and uh
it's early to speak of Jan's Victory
here uh on one hand but on the other
I mean I see so many ways for black to
lose so many natural ways tools I don't
see any way to defend I see the clock
situation I I think the yeah the the
chances are really bad for Ding and if
you can bet somewhere on Jan's Victory
uh put all the money there right now
because it's an opportunity of a
lifetime
because it's yes just looking really bad
for them
there's just so many enemies at ding's
door right now both on the board and and
on the clock and what a stark departure
this would be from you know the way that
Jana handled his loss against Magnus
Carlson I mean this match is unlike that
Carlson match in any way so I think it's
very safe to say and again not shoveling
dirt on ding just yet this game is far
from over but it's very safe to say that
this is a new yawn which is shown up in
this match and you know the rumors of
Jan's death after the previous game
those have also been exaggerated he is
not the same yawn who collapsed after
his you know 130 move loss against
Magnus this is a young who just doesn't
let individual results affect him and
he's already shown that in this game
but now he needs to finish it off he
needs a couple more accurate moves he's
got the time to make them
yeah uh
he's got the time and uh usually in a
position like that this is where
um whether he plays quickly or slowly
this is where Yan usually manages he is
great at finishing things off we have
seen it in this match I have to say
though
um
dink if we look back at his play in this
game I think it's been not very good
um
I I think the opening has gone wrong for
him he shouldn't have traded the Bishops
in that particular version and after
that he he had an option uh you know
after night F3 Queen E6 Knight F5 he had
a few options he chose what turned out
to be the worst one then once Jan played
this G4 and king of one he didn't
realize that he has to do something
drastic
now yeah he is in a very bad situation
so for ding standards this is not a very
good game
well it's how it how it's how it happens
in human years you know some games you
play well some MC don't play well I mean
it's nothing outrageous it's normal game
of chess and he tried his best but yeah
this is not not his his best game and uh
Jan on the other hand uh apart from this
one moment where he could have gone
Queen F3
well after after the after and before
that he played the exemplary game and
just playing a tremendous chess so far
and yes I don't see how this game can
turn around any longer but we'll see
maybe Dink and pull himself together and
find something uh find something uh
inhuman here that can still be a
defensive I personally don't see it like
as far as I'm concerned the position
looks dead lost uh it doesn't look dead
lost to me at first but now that I
noticed the threat of G5 it sort of
looks uh yeah it looks really bad to me
I don't know maybe some Queen C7 Queen
C6 is the only try but then F6 looks
devastating
no looks so just it's all really bad
yeah whichever way you turn there's
going to be something nepo has also
played with Incredible speed this game
and I don't think that he premeditated
it right I think that the position was
simple he chose a line that with clearly
defined plans he executed those plans
and he's used his intuition uh to make
important decisions thus far it's been
rewarded let's see though how long nepo
spends on potentially this final stage
of the game a move has been made it is
Rook B8 ding abiding by his strategy of
just making waiting moves and giving
nepo exactly what he wants Rook F4
yeah I think G5 was the G5 was the more
if I was the killer wasn't it yeah
because rookout 4 maybe allows this
queen B6 or queen C7 Queen B7 maneuver
because once the queen hits B7 it also
defends the F7 Pawn taking some of the
sting out of F6
also looks lost though after the Rook F4
Queen B6 F6 could be 7 queen of five
looks pretty lost to me
yeah
agreed but G5 is very much nepo style
and especially to play it instantly
you're aligned with H6 and Knight H4 was
incredible
that was uh yeah no at some point you
you helped me out there with Rooker for
Queen F6 to G5 at the moment you showed
me this G5 I realized I can do it
immediately and I think it's uh if one
of these two moves is wrong this is an
opportunity for ding because Jan could
pick the wrong one because
like from what I see both Luke winning
and young can by accident uh pick the
wrong one
I don't know is it Rooker 4 Queen E7 F6
Queen E6 that is the defense perhaps
six Queen E6 and then maybe
man
so many juicy options there for white
yeah and of course the options are
planning but maybe you're not completely
winning there let's say because of G5 so
after G5 I mean
you have to take and otherwise F6 is
crushing and after G5 IG Rook G4
yeah okay F6 is of course a blunder but
allowing Knight takes G5 also doesn't
look good you know you know what is the
what is key in this position is the
bishop on C5
it is a completed dead piece in a sense
if you look at it yeah it's totally dead
it's targeting the F2 Pawn is all it
does and it is very well like it's
sitting very well on C5 it's guarded by
the disrespond but it is a completely
dead piece if you don't somehow attack
the F2 square
with another heavy piece which is like a
rook let's say after before b0 B2 if you
don't do that the bishop is just not
contributing at all so after G5 and 0 to
G4
it's why it's Rook Knights and queen all
respawns attacking the king queen can
sort of protect somewhat The Rook can
try but the bishop is just on the other
side of the board it's like
this is well like this Polo G6 cuts it
away the pawn on C3 Cuts away so the
bishop can never come back anymore it's
sort of stuck on the left side of the
board not contributing at all so yeah
I'm not surprised that white has um
enough attacking potential here too to
win and maybe after G5 G4 maybe I can
play Queen F6
Knight G5 and into G8 and even there is
looks good oh six okay yeah I mean
I think uh this is your kind of you know
I think in a bullet game you would be
able to finish this one off here this is
just um
for a player with uh good attacking
instincts uh this is uh
this is enough Janis uh looking to the
side
I think Jana has a difficult Choice here
because uh Rooker 4 and G5 both look
very good
and I think he has to or he has to find
the most accurate way because he knows
that this could be the last important
decision in this game this could be
really all uh all you need to find yeah
and I mean G5 is less visually appealing
as we see the visual contrast there nepo
leaning back and now uh moving forward
with ding with his hands over his head I
mean he has to take every single second
here to calculate variations he's under
10 minutes uh and still has four
incredibly difficult moves uh to make
until time control G5 and Rook G4
doesn't produce the same visual effect
as Roka 4 and F6 but you just have to
appreciate that when the Knight lands on
G5 the combined attack of the queen and
the Knight on F7 is what absolutely
kills black uh coupled with the Rook on
G4 which supports the Knight and you're
right Anish I think your point about the
bishop on C5 is so important because you
can't judge a piece by how many squares
it controls right you can't just look at
a piece and say well it's sitting on an
open diagonal it's good you have to
always ask what role is a piece playing
what is it actually doing to contribute
to the position you could have a knight
in the center of the board that's
terrible because it's not contributing
speaking of contributing
nepo is contributing to ding's downfall
G5 is on the board ignore that sign that
engine is superficial G5 we believe is
the best move and I think it's going to
result in quick Victory possibly even
before move 40.
oh yes and G5 indeed was the best movies
also
um it's also the most direct one so when
you mentioned that the Rooker 4 F6 has a
bigger appeal I think that that's sort
of a stylistic thing whichever you
prefer which phone you prefer to push
but G5 I think is the more
is the more
um direct move and whenever you are
about to finish off the game you want to
knock down your opponent so you want to
punch you know and the punch is
basically a move like G5 or F6 so Rook
F4 was a preparation for a punch
while G5 was the punch and I think if
you're choosing between the two punch is
the way to go it's always a mistake I
think I have to interrupt you an issue
because a lot of people in the chat are
seeing that sign which says G5 is a
mistake that is wrong I checked with an
engine of high depth the engine takes
about 30 seconds uh but what you have to
understand is that when it first sees a
move it evaluates it superficially at
first it believes the G5 relinquishes
some of White's Advantage when you let
the engine sit G5 is actually the best
move at a high depth so even according
to the engine which uh doesn't pull any
punches G5 is still the best move you
should ignore that question mark which
popped up on the screen and it's gonna
lead to that post quick Victory please
continue
yes and
um G5 is not like completely winning
because of I think Queen D7 Queen B7
which looks totally lost somehow as well
but that is somehow only like somewhat
winning
instead the most natural move which you
think is the only move which ding played
8G this move is by the way losing
completely and now Rook G4 so basically
in a practical sense G5 is the killing
the killing blow so in a practical sense
even the Deep engine not deep engine
whatever it is besides the G5 as you
mentioned is the best mobiles
objectively practically it is the
winning one it is the winning move
because after G5 the only one you
consider is AG and then there is Rook G4
and now you realize that F6 is losing to
this Knight h4h6 beautiful we're gonna
have that on the game I think ding is
gonna play F6 again what else do you do
you don't allow an i takes G5 I think we
are gonna have F6 Knight H4
well I think the screen of 16 G8 might
be a little more resilient because there
after H6 I had some some hope still I
think ding season 8 I think Knight H4 H6
is kind of screaming at you
um even I saw it and okay if I see it uh
sure ding will see it
Rook G4 is on the board
and it's the moment of well it's no
longer the moment of truth I mean
whatever ding plays it's all over the
bar is completely uh it's all the way up
there it seems White's attack is as
crushing as it looks and positions that
look winning and also are winning are
usually one so
um this is all over and uh well what a
game I have to say ding made a few
mistakes but it's a nature of Chess
first of all mistakes don't come alone
and secondly humans make mistakes this
is why chess is a game we still play
this is why it's a beautiful game so
obviously ding didn't have a good day he
didn't play a good game you cannot play
a good game and uh and lose that's not
that's not just so of course it wasn't
things there but Jan he well he did
everything right and what a fantastic
win I have to say so far in this in this
match so many beautiful games just
incredible no this idea I mean G4 F6 we
are being treated to you know the kind
of Chess that we we hope to see in a
world championship match but haven't
seen in a lot of matches not you know
judging you know every match has its own
character its own flavor but I I'm
loving what I see thus far this is going
to send the ball back into ding's court
and thus far anybody who tries to
predict the course of the match has been
proven wrong anybody who talks about
momentum and how nepo is going to react
I mean nothing about this match is
similar uh to nepo's match against
Magnus Carlson and uh nepo he didn't
play mistake free but ultimately I think
his decision to go for a an opening he
felt more comfortable with
that is the decision that was the money
decision because 1d4 in that game it
didn't turn out well he learned his
lesson and now he's going for a position
that he just feels comfortable with yeah
it's objectively equal yeah ding should
have been able to make a draw with a
couple more accurate moves but he
succeeded in making ding uncomfortable
and in reaching a position that he
studied better and more deeply with his
team than ding did
and of course always good to take
inspiration from the game of initial
well I actually was on the black side
there so the one who took inspiration
was ding was Ding and he lost just like
I did but um yeah I mean we it's always
hard to say in hindsight it worked
majestically I think uh predominantly
what decided the outcome of the opening
was ding's very unfortunate handling of
it I have to say if you are a ding or is
a team member you are disappointed with
how it went you hope for better of
course uh this is
a critical line okay there are hundreds
of critical lines so that's not easy but
still his handling was particularly
unfortunate uh he really landed in a
very important position from the opening
so
definitely nothing to be happy about
there but from Beyonce we have a
tremendous
tremendous game so far and indeed uh
looking back at the reasonable
Championship matches so far this one
from purely a creative point of view
from a purely
chess games a point of view
um you know the beauty of the games the
the clarity of ideas and instructiveness
of them as well like every game can be
shown as in a separate lecture and
there's so much to learn from these
games from a creative Viewpoint
certainly one of the best Championship
matches we had seen in a long time and
I'm really honored actually to be
accommodating and having such a good
time here because not only are all these
these games uh you know ongoing and the
theory uh is far from Theory killing
these games but also they're just so
good and so so such high quality by the
player that wins and I think it will be
on that we'll win this game I don't see
how uh how it continues differently
no I don't either and ding he's now at
five minutes we're not at a stage where
you know he has some chances or he can
get into an end game he's literally
getting mated Knight takes two five is
coming White's moves are playing
themselves nepo has already seen F6
Knight H4 so he's done all of the hard
work now he just has to make the
incredibly obvious move moves I think he
would win this in a bullet game and uh I
just love the complexity of the
positions that we're reaching it's not a
coincidence that someone like ding
failed to handle the position that we
had today it was just so strategically
complex there were so many different
candidate moves and different options
and I just love the interplay of
positional chess and tactics that we're
seeing today the way that this game
transformed from a positional battle
with moves like H4 and a fight for key
squares to the final stage of the game
which is purely tactical G5 and Rook G4
we can see how positional play and
positional Mastery leads directly into
uh tactical Victory with a series of
breakthroughs and perhaps even a
beautiful night sacrifice if plays F6
yes and for for sure if uh Carlson would
be playing you know this this game we
would be
singing you know the songs for him it's
truly an incredible display of how
as you mentioned correctly how a stack
strategy and tactics work together and
it's really extremely often the case
that you build up a positional advantage
and in the end you clinch it by tactical
means this is just uh how it's done this
is sort of the textbook way to win chess
games build up a position Advantage you
build it up you sit on good squares you
bring all the pieces to the right
squares but then usually to win the game
you need that tactical breakthrough
and we see it here G5 followed by root
G4 and after F6 Knight H4 this is that
clincher
and yes it says all you all you can hope
for and it's just I mean I don't like
repeating myself but again just having
this position at the world championship
match uh playing this kind of game this
must be so satisfying you know I on some
occasions
play a game that is similar to one like
this one where everything is so
beautiful doesn't happen so often I must
say at high level with me like I'm not
able to do this that often but uh doing
it you know against player like Ding and
doing it at such a stage this is so
satisfying and we we see that happen to
dig in the previous game ding managed to
you know complete out I'll play yeah and
here young completely out plays ding
this is just two extremely strong
players with asymmetrics strengths and
this leads to just beautiful chess it's
really uh honestly amazing what we what
we are seeing I've seen many of top
level games and you know there are
plenty of wins and losses in top top
chess and other top tournaments but we
what number two and what number three
beating each other one beautiful game
one after the other that's truly truly
remarkable and it's amazing that they've
wrote the best on themselves at this
moment at this at this stage
we've had three decisive games in the
last four games and now the ball is back
into dings court and again he's down to
point and again he's gonna have to take
some inspiration uh from the fact that
he's already has a victory under his
belt he knows it's possible
but it's just amazing to see the initial
the momentum and the initiative of the
match continue to change hands now yeah
ding is uh facing a deficit but he has
the white pieces tomorrow so will he be
able to recover I think so to contribute
another incredible game I mean this
match this match has been amazing and I
can't believe we're only you know what
four games in this is only game five
this is the best of 14 match so NEPA
will have to continue performing at this
level for many many more days and Zig is
going to try to prevent that from
happening in the meantime we've been
talking ding has been thinking he's now
down to 90 seconds without increments so
this might be decided on the clock but
he finally moves he plays Rook to A8 and
that is an indicator of how bad his
position is he has moved his Rook the
last five out of six moves and that
simply allows white to do what to play
Knight takes you see that I see the
point I see I see the point uh I see his
uh his idea oh okay one Queen A8 yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes his idea is that 95
okay one if you go to the most natural
Square G2 that's Queen A8 uh offering a
queen trade which would be a huge relief
or black I'm wondering to
um to what extent that that is uh relief
because even there I have some ideas so
I have all this f697 ideas but that's
probably uh you know somewhat of a
relief
let's let's see I didn't see this idea
at all so
maybe Knight G5 okay one thing E2 is is
cleaner that's one question I have
that is probably also the there's
probably also the way by the way because
if you play
we need seven check though yeah now can
you sell a check
can't bring the king
um yeah it's okay
yeah I feel like in that end game your
idea King G2 Queen A8 like trade Queens
go F6 GF Knight H7 I think if I think
what just promotes the h-bond there
oh my God yeah it's incredible so this
uh it's quite hilarious this uh Bishop
is so useless also in an end game yep so
you mean that here I I think I see what
you what you mean I think you mean that
in this position I can even play Rook to
E8 and there is no stopping it's
incredible there's no stopping the H
Pawn the bishop is just so dumb here it
cannot go here it also cannot go here it
also cannot go here and it cannot go
here it is the study this is just a
study like wow and B4 doesn't do
anything because White's B2 Pawn that
pawn chain is what's holding the bishop
back King D7 we should show white just
plays H why can pre-move H6 I guess
Bishop E3 but essentially you will play
it you would say I know you'll Play
Bishop absolutely or Bishop D4 trying to
get a pass Pawn but King D7 H6 King
takes c8h7 is perhaps that's fitting
final position of this game because it
ultimately shows the incompetence of
Black's bishop and who could have
predicted that this position would be
decided by past H Pawn Yeah that's
exactly what I think is likely to happen
and if you know I think one of the
reasons why we saw that post bike uh
Magnus Carlson about Astana calling I
think okay whatever it is as we are we
can talk about him uh you know
withdrawing from the cycle and all this
and him playing poker and all that he
loves chess uh and he must appreciate
the games here and I think one of the
reasons he uh you know he mentioned
Astana is because he must have
appreciated the game so far he must have
enjoyed watching them whatever he says I
mean maybe he doesn't care about losing
the title anymore but from purely purely
chess aesthetic perspective from purely
perspective of the game these are really
nice games to watch and I think this one
as well is just a yeah it's it's a treat
and I I think uh even Carlson would
agree that this is a masterpiece and
especially if it would follow this path
that we just showed this end game it's a
very strange way to convert like I think
you should try to Checkmate in a
position like that I'm all for end games
but I would feel that there should be a
knockout blow but this end game it's an
absolute like you make all these 10
forced moves and in the end you trade
the Rooks and then your H Pawn is three
steps away from promotion Square this
full board full of pieces but black is
unable to somehow stop that it's a
remarkable remarkable line and uh I
wonder if the game will finish this way
and if it will you know your reputation
of a profit only will reinforce itself
no but this would be so so fitting that
black has been trying to trade Queens
all of this time and finally when he
succeeds it actually favors white
because white creates you know a past H
Pawn of all the ways that this game
could finish it would be almost
impossible to predict that you know a
past H Pawn I think how could you even
create a passage pawn and yet we see the
line and I think nepo you know he's such
a good calculator and you know for 2700
plus player this is just such an easy
line to calculate because it's all
forced there's literally no choice the
black has at any juncture if he doesn't
trade Rooks that doesn't help either
I don't think nepo is going to take too
long I think he's going to take within a
couple minutes at a maximum and I would
like to just note that after Knight G5
Queen A8 and that end game after takes
uh Rook takes
F6 GF uh we can maybe full of showed
briefly on the board because it's kind
of irrelevant uh relevant line for this
game uh either one extra reason why Jan
uh will certainly see it is that uh yeah
is that in this position besides trading
Rooks I think the simple H6 simple h6h7
also wins as uh rookie is inevitable
after that so there's no need to be to
be too pretty uh you can just go simply
H6 and only after D5 player rookie8
which is even easier and so Jan is
definitely heading uh for this afternoon
yeah I I think it's pretty obvious that
uh yes the line is absolutely forced and
a player like has gifted as Jan when he
smells blood for him as Child's Play
and I actually really like that Jan
doesn't take all that long in these
moments not you know criticizing anybody
for taking especially in a moment as
important as this taking 10 minutes
whatever to double triple check uh the
main lines but I love John's confidence
in his calculation and we almost never
see him take uh you know 20 minutes to
when Tuple check a line once he
calculates it once he feels confident he
just goes for it and uh he's got 42
minutes on the clock he's not even going
to use a tenth of them
yeah and as you mentioned quintupling uh
is not what he does he probably does
double triple check it but how many
times can you double check a line I mean
he sees it he he I think he sees it in a
Flash
and then he spends a few seconds to
double check it a few more seconds to
triple check it and then people say he
plays it fast but he'll be like put him
in fast I like I triple quadruple
checked it at some point I have to make
a move yeah and already 30 seconds
passed I mean let me make my move but he
is seen exactly yeah
he's just uh making sure because you
don't wanna you don't want to allow an
end game that holds but of course and
you you might want to check of king2 but
kingito is not so easy actually King it
doesn't win on the spot I don't see
um I don't think it too is easy at all I
guess can get two queen S7 Knight E4 is
maybe winning for white still but it's
nowhere near as forcing nowhere near as
forcing a skin to G2 and this end game
after takes an F6 in that end game also
black doesn't have a black is lost with
a margin yeah so black is really lost
there there is no hope
yeah it's not like the bishop stops the
pawn and then black creates a passer on
the other side of the board black
literally cannot stop the h-phone and
not an EPO I mean I just love that oh
he's gone kingy too okay you didn't see
that one and I guess mini 794 just ends
the game as well probably yeah yeah okay
okay it's a matter of tests we we just
went deep into one of the wins and
um we didn't go into the the other one
but it seems he has here um he has
luxury of choice here it looks at King 2
yeah it's Infinity 294 is actually
completely winning as well yeah it is
Queen E7 94 no checks and H6 F6 even
Rook takes G7 is a threat after Queen
e794 so ding having made the 40th move
which he's about to might just resign
after 94. because at that point the game
is over
well yeah I think he'll he'll have to
make a move of sorts but uh we are not
far away from uh from the end here
we are not far away from the end uh
it might be a little anticlimactic in
the sense that after Queen 794 the
players will take a moment because
they'll reach the time control but uh
sooner or later they the at the end well
the handshake will will come because
black just doesn't have a defense I
guess he will try some move it doesn't
lose on the spot but uh yeah I I don't
know maybe Queen E8 uh I was thinking
too he's a bit better trying to
yeah and with three seconds on the clock
move 40 has been executed
and dig gets up but nepo's not going to
take any time of 94 that one was
virtually forced
yeah yeah no he's completely in control
of it and I think uh when he had this
position 28.
when he had that position uh he
sucking A8 very quickly
and then he started calculating and he
realized that King 2 is winning
and so he didn't go back to kinjutu I
think that's just what happened so he
just uh he saw one and then they say you
know you don't need to see uh twins you
just need to see one win he just saw one
win and stuck with it now we are 94 will
probably follow
yeah the biggest threat that 94 poses is
actually Rook takes G7
followed by F6
so that's the threat which probably
necessitates Queen E8 and then you could
play F6 and H6 that's the secondary
threat because the pass Pawn is just as
strong
almost as strong in the middle game as
it is in the end game white preserves
all of the made threats and the white
king is incredibly safe that's the most
depressing thing for black is White's
King can even chill on F3 so 94 already
on the board
and ding has an hour but he's got
nothing to spend it on other than to
come to terms with how lost this
position is
yes oh certainly yes and uh
I'm looking at different ways of trying
to win this position
I suspect Queen E8 is uh
is the most
suspected some Mustang only move I think
yeah then at some point you can try also
unpinning the king maybe because then
you resume
yeah with the idea like Rook j86 this
would be an idea
oh nice I think we need King F3 might
actually be the easiest one even before
F6 yeah because after F6 ideas you have
to F6 GF there is Queen E5 uh idea so if
you start with King F3 then Queen E5 I
can take a knight uh takes C5 so
yeah I I can imagine uh the king of
three is the
cleanest solution
I think the beauty of this match is that
uh when it comes to winning
winning positions the players they just
show it to us
so far the conversion has been superb
and I have no doubt that uh Yan will
just finish it off
cleanly ding is in the rest area he's
looking at the monitor
you know seeing that Knight E4 has been
played and the process of coming to
terms
it takes a while you know he's going to
exhaust all of the options but
the reason it's so one-sided is again
because White's King is so safe it's
like even if you gave black two moves
even if black could take the pawn on B2
with Jack that wouldn't that would
change exactly nothing because White's
king would hide on F3
yeah Blake didn't manage to drum up
enough counter play it was very
desperate already when he did that his
defense has failed uh after the move
Rook E4 because defense of ding was
based on sitting passive in that
position
and he missed rookie 4g5 idea from afar
when it came basically his defense has
fallen and his attempts to activate his
pieces came way too late and of course
it didn't lead anywhere and I was
already way too desperate so yeah the
game that was lost already a few moves
ago and uh
here is is just a matter of uh
matter of yarn finishing the job and he
is known to to do this very well so I
don't expect any troubles here
has probably a few different ways to do
it I think in King Queen F3 Queen A8
maybe is the attempts
to to make to make few moves
yeah and then the Soul f6h6 procedure
can happen again
yeah again the end game can be reached
actually after all so
era
yeah Jan knows what the outcome of the
game is going to be
he's uh you know walking around the
playing Hall passing at the time
and ding I don't think ding is gonna
take you know 45 minutes that's not his
style either because who wants to do who
wants to sit there
you know he's gonna exhaust his only
option you know get on with it and go
home because they both want to go home
yeah of course but at the same time it's
not a position where you resign again
you see that you are losing but you need
your opponent to execute it on the board
before you resign I mean that's what
most players do that's that's how these
two play as we have seen so far they
don't resign once it's clear to them
they're lost they resign once
the due course uh has has been completed
and uh I think uh so there is a Move
Like Queenie so you make that move and
then Jan has to find the cleanest
finishing will take a bit of time
because it's important not to watch this
one
for example is not so obvious
why it loses so I think it will still
take uh take some time as neither ding
should resign nor should Yan um you know
uh
stop making moves so I think that this
will all commence but at the end of the
day yeah the game is predetermined as is
visible from ding's posture yeah this
this time you know we can safely
make inclusions based on uh ding as he
leans back and that's not out of
relaxation
nepo is also pacing the same route you
know from one side of the playing Hall
to the other he has not visited his rest
area he has hung around the board really
since the start of the game
and ding's face it really says it all
it's over
no he got out played today uh what can
we say he made a lot of mistakes
they've made a lot of mistakes and he
got outplayed and I think the trouble
began started early I think um on move
19 this bishop d8 followed by 97 these
two moves the sequence it was just not
good
he mixed he combined a few ideas
together he read out the bishop to B6
which is sometimes possible he traded
the Bishops which is dubious dubious but
sometimes possible but somehow all
combined it was not uh
not done in a coherent Manner and he got
an unpleasant position young founded
with H4 H5 brought the Knight over from
H4 to F5
and then ding had to already be very
precise and his uh first mistake with
Knight xn5 EF Queen F6 was punished
roughly and already then he was really
on the verge
that was a huge turning point and
sometimes when you look at games with an
engine you don't get a good sense of
exactly where the turning points were
because the engine's always optimistic
on the defending side right and
oftentimes the engine gives 0.6 but we
already believe that the Turning Point
has been reached and I really really
think that Knight takes F5 right that
impulsive decision to to capture the
Knight how do you play Queen F6 that was
probably the closest that he had come to
completely equalizing really since the
start of the game is that a fair
assertion that if we had to name one
moment right one critical turning point
it was when he played Knight takes F5
yeah maybe I I I tend to give more
importance to the opening phase so I
would rate the um Bishop d897 moment in
the opening as perhaps an even more
important one because that was what I
believe put him on on the defensive at
all that was the root of his problems
but of course getting a worse position
it doesn't mean you have to lose and
indeed yeah perhaps the biggest mistake
was uh taking and queen F6 I mean taking
Queen D7 remember that was the move that
you suggested I was actually a computer
like that actually that was maybe decent
but taking on Queen F6 uh that was a
serious mistake but yeah I think from a
perspective of
somebody who you know prepares so hard
and deepest ding I think
um the sequence of move 19 and 20 Bishop
the 897 that's uh that that was really
the the course of of his uh trouble for
the most part just didn't get out of the
opening with a good position
and there's been more decisive games
interesting stat in this match through
five games then in the first five games
of the last
um
uh World Championships since 2013
combined because in 2021 of all five of
the first games were drawn of course
Nepal loses the sixth game in Marathon
style that was the first decisive game
in uh Carlson carwana all of the games
were drawn Carlson karyakin only had a
couple decisive games and the first five
games were drawn as well the most
decisive match uh until this one had
been in 2014 against visionand where two
out of the first five games we're
decisive and here we're gonna have three
decisive games how much of a treat it
has been to commentate this match where
even the non-decisive games and this was
your point earlier Anish even the
non-decisive games were full of life
perhaps the Carlsbad game is the outlier
that was the only one I wouldn't even
call it lifeless it was full of
strategic ideas that game just never
really got off the ground all of the
other games either were decisive or
could have been decisive the first game
as well
yeah absolutely and you know we are so
spoiled that we are complaining about
the Carlsbad game but that was a rich
game in itself as well and uh uh it's a
tremendous show so far the players are
not shying away they um from game one
they didn't want a cautious start they
didn't want to waste the white pieces
I think you see that they're struggling
with the black pieces surprisingly and I
think it has to do with the fact that
there is so much to know right now every
time they have a position on the board I
know for a fact that they know that they
must know this because they work on
chess you know they work on their
opening reporter they they have a narrow
repair they're working on it they know
that there is so much now to remember
and of course they don't recall the
details and
they just cannot recall the details with
the black pieces and almost no matter
what white plays there is just so much
you have to prepare for with black and I
think that the fact that they are under
pressure with black both of them that
makes that pushes them to play more
aggressive with whites if you understand
what I'm trying to say like the knowing
that you have a black game to go means
that you cannot make a quick draw with
white because that doesn't only you know
you'll just waste an opportunity and
later you will suffer the next day so
both of them are using the white pieces
to the max both of them are unable to
memorize their huge opening reporter
they try to make it as Compact and as
simple as possible they're trying to
play Healthy lines they just cannot
remember everything and they land in
trouble as uh the theme of the match so
far is that white is just pushing in
most of the games why was uh getting
getting things going in the opening that
one game that Ding lost with white he
got some Advantage after H3 and move
four but okay that that backfired
eventually in terms of opening some so
far white is doing really well every day
and that makes me optimistic for ding
for tomorrow
knows he can bounce back he already
bounce back before and tomorrow you'll
have the white pieces so no need to you
know to get too depressed I think today
is not his day but maybe tomorrow he'll
strike back or maybe one of the other
white games lots of opportunities left
absolutely and ding was indeed able to
put pressure out of the opening in that
English game he played of course nepo
equalized at some point and then uh
committed that that terrible uh mistake
with Knight to D4 uh but it's amazing
the pressure that white has been able to
put in general in top level chess uh in
the Italian and the Rue Lopez like
really thinking about the last couple of
years the abundance of ideas that white
has trotted out in both of these
openings uh has really put black under
pretty significant strain and the
Marshall uh it solves a lot of the
problems that black was facing in the
main line were Lopez but as nepo shows
in this game and his top players have
shown in the last couple of years uh
lines with D3 aligns with you know A3
and Knight C3 tons of Sidelines really
post serious problems with black that
cannot be solved with uh forcing lines
and it's just a super exciting time to
watch top level chess contrary to you
know the exaggerated rumors about
classical chess being dead because of
the influence of computers
yes and uh also in the previous matches
I mean they were uh far from uh from
horrible uh the match between Carolina
and Carlson was fascinating as well uh
Magnus was playing this sharpsy Cinema
with the black pieces we had lots of
fights but somehow these games they
finished in a draw in the classical
portion and because either somebody
would miss a word or somebody would you
know show tremendous defense but uh they
were already you know they were already
exciting games there too but in this uh
event so far the players they converted
pretty well and um
yeah we have you know a full display of
uh the beauty of modern chess uh the
width of ideas with the white pieces you
can play 4h3 you can go down the main
path in the Carlsbad you can go down the
main path in uh Spanish
um where you can have so many different
ways to avoid the Marshall and it seems
that it's not easy for black to be ready
for all of this of course next time
things will be ready for uh this
particular line but next time young will
play something else so it's it's a
difficult uh difficult life of players
playing with the black pieces even when
they're as well prepared as these two
for sure ding has now taken 12 minutes
and counting on this move
um nepo has paced from one spot to the
other back again this entire time ever
since making his move he has an hour and
40 minutes on his clock so the result of
the game is not in question
Queen E8 is the only move that doesn't
lose the game on the spot because it's
literally I mean F6 there's H6 what do
you think is going through ding's mine
right now do you think he's actually
searching for a defensive move or is he
still in the long process of coming to
terms with what has happened you
sometimes see players inspecting their
score sheets in these types of
situations thing hasn't been doing with
that but his body language is his
posture everything seems to indicate
that he is about to resign but he hasn't
made a move just yet
yeah I think it's a combination indeed
of uh glancing over the position trying
to calculate the consequences of Queen 8
making sure you are indeed lost and also
just coming to terms because you know he
was under a lot of pressure the last few
moves he was in a Time trouble as well
so he was very tense and he had to try
and find the only defensive resources if
there were any and now that he has
reached time control he can relax a bit
but as he is a relaxing he also realized
that okay it's his last relaxation of
the game it's a time to go home soon and
so
um he's just taking his time there
Coming to Terms indeed with the results
at the same time
um so his mind keeps wondering about the
position he keeps thinking and
calculating but what is on the
foreground whether these are the
thoughts about uh him losing this game
or whether these are calculations at
this point I no longer know these two
are mixing sometimes you know you can
you can have a conversation and have a
position running on the back of your
mind as well right probably know that as
well and and this is probably what's
happening to him he's got these two
conversations on one hand he's
calculating 28 which he sees is lost and
he keeps going over these lines over and
over looking for a miracle but it's not
one and at the same time he's surely
thinking about uh
about the miserable uh miserable spot he
is he's in right now having
um come back yesterday yet uh having
lost once again and uh of lots of uh 360
turns in this match I didn't see him
losing this game but as I told you
already at the start so much decided
um at this high level so much is decided
in the opening so much is decided who
gets a pleasant position and Jan just
from the start he just took initiative
and just never never let go and it was
all his day today
and as you make your point Queen E8 has
been played and I don't think I think
Jan will spare us you know a 15-minute
think in King F3
uh should follow pretty quickly
um of course Queen E8 takes the sting
out of Rook takes G7 which was the
threat
I mean King F3 is such an easy move it's
such a natural move because it unpins
the Knight and it reinforces all of the
threats
uh such as you know F6 H6 Knight takes
D6
I think that move pretty quickly I think
it might be our opportunity to take a
look at the analysis board because
because I think dink is not going to
resign now that he's not there in the
board so we can perhaps take a last look
and just see if there indeed is no
difficulty here to convert because I
think there's still some variations to
look over here
so the more you suggest is King F3
and unpinning the Knights setting up F6
gf6 Rook j8 tactic right predominantly
now um let's just establish how white
wins after Queen A8
so let's say trade in F6
Traders
Knight F6 and King E7 Knight G8 I think
is an important move
95 also nice because your team has no
good
okay there's no good squares I think
right I was just thinking like she had
an H6 but it's probably easier and just
uh Crush
yeah the Knight just blocks the
blocks the rook and if I try to
um
go around
there are multiple ways too yeah I like
that the most primitive and Bishop
yeah in Knights H7 Knight f6a also yeah
yeah also this is a very direct as well
H7 here Knight F6 right
I mean the worst case
um it was actually King G2 here wins on
the spot
oh there goes no squares yeah it's a
fork this would require some conversion
that would be completely unnecessary
would ruin uh would actually ruin a lot
but it's not needed you have the skin
just to move so yeah the end game you
have 3.8 and the end game is probably
the easiest way to to go and um
yeah and nepo he's gonna enjoy himself
he has plenty of time he knows the
result of the game he's gonna Savor this
moment before the result has been
counted and you need to start working on
the next game you know this is a very
pleasurable moment for top players when
they know that everything is under
control
um and they know that they have it in
the bag
um and we are going to take this
opportunity to take uh most probably one
final break nepo is going to spend a
little bit of time and this game is
going to go on for a little bit longer
we will watch as nepo puts the finishing
touches on an absolutely brilliant
Victory this will be his second victory
of the world championship match and
therefore of His World Championship uh
career we hope you've been enjoying our
coverage and don't go anywhere because
we'll have the conclusion of this game
uh this game five of the fide world
championship for you but first we'll
take a short break and we will be back
with more nepo Ding and likely nepo's
second victory of the match in just a
couple of minutes
[Music]
thank you I do recommend Meetup to a lot
of my friends that are looking for
different things wine tasting movies
book clubs meet a lot of new people a
lot of new friends and make you more
social
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yep
all right I'm not finishing a granola
bar here but I gotta compensate the
world championship because dingley Wren
has not resigned ladies and gentlemen we
hope you've been enjoying our cartridge
GM Daniel raditzki GM anishagiri the
world number six
chopping it up for you game five nepo
again sting is about to conclude the
last moments of the game as king F3 has
indeed been played a niche
ding is prolonging the torture he's in
the rest area he's sort of asleep he's
coming to terms with his loss whatever
it is that he's doing the result of the
game is no longer in question
you know our chat members are saying
they're losing all the games to
stockfish with the white pieces here now
you should realize the chess is a very
different game
um across different levels so if you're
a beginner
what is winning what means winning
winning position and if you are a top
level player like Yan and ding what
means the winning position these are two
entirely different things and uh this
position it is clear to both the players
it's completely winning for white at
this point but of course uh if we take
uh you know if we take a look at what
happens in games between uh players
rated 1200 or
um even even above that well it's
definitely different story
but uh yeah so probably if you play
against stock because you'll lose but
Jan essentially has this one in the back
he has already found the wind here
calculated all the possibilities to the
end and this is already a matter of
formality here
it is indeed and you know we're
expecting to eventually come back to the
board and accept the inevitable um and
he just did that he's gonna write down
the move and I would guess that he's
going to play Queen a pretty quickly you
know first he's going to take a sip of
water we have an interesting stat for
you though
um which is all of the players who have
hit 2800 and above obviously that is a
huge milestone it's a milestone that's
been hit only a couple of times
throughout chess history and Jana
palmushi
um has hit 2800 uh live He's
27.99.7 but that was before his loss so
he's dropped a little bit but page one
of uh the 2800 Club has some incredible
names on it obviously Magnus Carlson
achieved the highest rating ever in 2014
uh Gary Kasparov as early as 1999 he was
the only player over 2800 by a country
mile His Highest at 28.51 as we look at
this list uh Anisha and admire these
names do you think 2900 is ever in on
the horizon
and that name on the bottom there of
course
yeah no it's uh 2900 is uh
is a difficult thing especially because
it seems to be that there is no
inflation happening on the top as the
younger
you know young players keep stealing
rating from the top players as well and
somehow
for a long time already
the number of players that are 2700 is
not uh you know it's not it's not
changing definitely not becoming bigger
and so without inflation
I'm not sure
not sure it's easy to get rating as high
as in the 200 you have to dominate chess
like Magnus Carlson did for a long time
without having a single misstep and even
Carlson he does these missteps from time
to time and
yeah ding you know is also very very
high very high rating at his Peak but
now today you cannot you cannot see you
know you cannot see the 28 16 player
back the point the point of you know of
course you can if you're a great player
you can get a high rating but to to get
even higher you need consistency and
consistency at an incredibly high level
and it's difficult even the players at
the match now you see just two days ago
it was ding who played the brilliant
chess and um today it's yeah on their
best days they're playing they're
playing wonderful and he plays grenade
now going for that lost end game but the
consistency maintaining that level if
you haven't played every game like you
played today he would be to 900. if ding
played every game like he played the
last one he will be 29 2900 but
unfortunately for them it doesn't happen
every day maintaining this kind of level
it's really really hard you need also
the opening to go your way you need um
to to have you know the energy and
everything has to be right and it's just
difficult okay Jan is forcing the end
game he's calculated it already to the
end
I just love that he's playing quickly I
want to repeat that I you know that
confidence and it's not misplaced
confidence he's calculated it and Jan
doesn't take unnecessary time once he
believes in something and once he's
figured it out he goes for it and he's
taking exactly zero seconds on these
moves F6 is played and at this point
resignation has become a very likely
option
yeah I suspected GF will still happen
but after GF Knight F6 Kink E7
one more move perhaps Knight j8 as you
mentioned the cleanest one
that could cause the
uh the handshake and ding also is
visibly
um well he is visibly Disturbed he
doesn't hide the fact that he's dead
lost and indeed at this point uh
resignation at this point it becomes a
realistic possibility I think we will
see it quickly both players have a lot
of time but no need to waste time
tomorrow is another day another game you
have to rest you have to prepare so I
suspect ding will uh make a few moves as
a formality but we'll eventually
eventually extend his head
yeah and of course on the topic of
raiding inflation I just want to add
that the number of grand Masters has
obviously increased uh over the years
but you cannot attribute all of that to
quote unquote rating and title inflation
people have actually gotten better and
opportunities for most players have
increased across the world so unlike you
know even 10 years ago you can become a
grandmother more American Grandmasters
or more Norm tournaments around the
world and I think all things held equal
that's a good thing obviously that
raises some concerns of the title
requirements not being stringent enough
and I think that's a legitimate
discussion to have but on balance we
just have to acknowledge that people
have gotten better at chess and that is
a good thing and there are going to be
more title players and more GMS but I
think that the fears of you know the GM
title for example not meaning anything
that all of that has been you know
exaggerated and I don't think we're
anywhere near that point
of course I mean it's not easy like you
know this fantastic uh chess players
like Gotham chess um or Sagar Shah I
mean they're really good at what they do
they play chess their entire life
they'll tell you a lot about the game
they read a lot they see the tactics
they tremendous chess players in fact
and they struggle to become Grandmaster
we saw you know this whole drama about
Levy trying to become a Grandmaster uh
you know it's been ongoing for a long
time
and now it seems to finally have come to
terms with the fact that he isn't a
Grandmaster and um
he you know it is just a very difficult
very high level that okay by now more
and more people achieve but it is not
obvious and it's not a given and so
yeah you could you could make one more
title to to somehow separate the the
very top of the world from the other
Grand Masters but you also have the
rating and there is the unspoken super
GM sort of um Super Jam title that
people uh kind of uh quote unquote
receive once they reach the radio 2700
because 2700 is rating that only around
40 40 50 I think usually 40 people in
the world uh have and okay that's that's
Elite enough to to get a name like an
elite Grandmaster or a super Grand
Master
you could actually try to make this
title official for fun like uh score
three super Grand Master Norms meaning
three tournaments where you score 2800
performance and you reach rating of 27 I
don't know 21s or something in your life
but uh you don't need to make that and
uh
and of course yes the I'm really not
sure this inflation is happening nor nor
I think The Grandmaster titles are too
easy I think it's really really
difficult and the kids that are getting
at early ages they are extremely good I
mean you can try playing these kids and
good luck beating them they're very very
strong at chess
defense with G6 but uh but this is um
empty play I mean at this point you can
resign
yeah
yeah and I think we're gonna see a
handshake right now or maybe King F7
first will be tried
yeah I think you'll make a move still
um he'll still make a move
yeah nepo kind of looking up at dang
like all right let's uh I'm hungry I
want to sample asana's finest
restaurants a little shush leak and you
know
I would imagine
no not when you have to play the next
day but strashlik is definitely uh
definitely on on the menu
um
okay ding is trying to activate the Rook
but um
I think I think
probably many roads that lead to Rome
but um ding is attempting to
take on B2 and then hopes to pressure
the F2 Pawn but um
yeah I'm sure young will figure figure
it out here
okay dang
uh what's the simplest one here
is it right you need to actually you
actually need to think here which is I'm
sure Jana's annoyed but I think he's
enjoyed this is the task that he enjoys
the ears turned red he uh he briefly
panicked but I think 95 Knight H7
probably does it now he see his ears he
briefly panicked he missed the rookie
too and he he's he is in the complete
State of Shock now he thinks okay did I
did I ruin it because he doesn't have
the engine barrier he doesn't see the
the barists all the way up he kind of
panics a bit there completely red he is
actually now also from the front but uh
well luckily for him he'll come down
realize that nothing has been uh nothing
has been lost
um but wow here is definitely having a
moment of uh well he just didn't expect
the fact that he has to now think which
it's not the fact that he's not winning
I think it's the fact that he now has to
hunker down and find another move where
he thought the work that he did came to
an end I actually think King G4 King F5
also might do the trick which is not a
satisfying quote unquote in the moment
that it's in the sense that it's not all
that Force but I think it just ends the
game and I guess we will need the
analysis board one more time well we
will need the analysis boards and uh
well you know there is so little
material left on the board and actually
young I think uh he is legitimately
worried uh not only that he didn't he
has to put some work in but there is the
thought going through he said that maybe
here uh maybe he messed it up of course
he's confident that player that he is
and with his understanding he realized
he must still be completely winning but
it could be not so trivial any longer
and the main problem white has is that
if they go for let's say Knight G5
Rook B2
Rook H6 which would be sort of the
attempt to Checkmate and then after uh
yeah of course because after Rook F2
King E4 you have a move like uh King
Geet or King Jade and Good Luck winning
this after F7 I can just sacrifice back
the exchange so I don't think this is
the way to go I I felt okay I I saw this
idea of king um going up the board as
well but I was wondering so can I try to
force it with Knight G5 Knight H7 or
will you have D5 that are in the end so
95 from B2 Knight H7
yeah you you have actually
so yeah if I go rookie 7 or something
F7
is there some before counter players
unbelievable there's B4 of some sort
maybe not here Maybe not immediately but
but this is not this feels iffy this
feels iffy
um what is there why is the engine
giving almost equality
um oh could it be like King C6 and then
D5 at the end yeah maybe but I have
rookie 6 check for example well maybe
okay let's try to
ah well sorry before it's just CBS so
before it's not not it
maybe it's a waiting move and after f8
takes X before so you're saying
something like work F1 I'm not sure yeah
no no really not he doesn't like it but
still plus three is not an is not a
convincing assessment here because B4
will come and white will still have to
work I actually think that the easiest
is in fact to play King F4
give up the pawn go King F5
and basically black has no moves here
because sure let's say before then just
Rook H6 rook h8 and Knight G5 is a
mating net
yeah and you're lucky with white you're
lucky that the black can never play D5
because uh
well you know the young Deutsch the
small bullet there I mean he was
completely winning completely winning
and now he suddenly uh uh it's suddenly
almost close but okay if you're asking a
four king of five it'll be all good
it'll be all good yeah the last hurdle
because King F4 King F5 you just have to
you know you have to
come to terms with the fact that there
is no quote-unquote forced win there's
no mate and once you realize that you
know involving the king is almost always
a good bet do you think John is going to
take a long time
yeah yeah well luckily here's one and a
half hour so it's one of these moments I
can tell you from experience and I've
had many of these so if you know if Yan
will now find king of four king of five
we will not will not talk about the end
of this game we will just keep it in our
uh recap we'll just say there was this
mistake that mistake and then Jan
converted the crushing victory but if
Yan Now does not find it then we will
have to go a few moves earlier we'll
have to go here say that King 2 was
easier
remember I was winning on the spot we'll
have to go
probably here saying that um
I have six maybe easier you know there
were some more direct ways of six H6 and
uh all sorts of uh all sorts of
improvements will appear along the way
where he could win much more in much
more easy fashion I have to say credit
to ding for finding this G6 and through
K2 idea well definitely making Yan sweat
there a little bit but once again if Jan
finds king of forking at five
is so much time but if when he finds it
then it will be all fine and we will not
speak about uh missed opportunities but
you know I personally I've um I've
ruined positions like like that before
and especially when it gets uh when it
gets difficult okay the good thing for
young is that he has so much time it's
so much time
if you had five minutes here I mean I
could have easily seen him play Knight
G5 and go for that line and you know
allow B4 and then we would have been
singing completely different tune we
that's what people have to understand
that when when completely winning
positions are ruined like this you never
understand how it could possibly be
ruined until it is like until you find
that one pathway you never truly believe
that uh you know a winning position can
be spoiled and then it is spoiled you
know and then you're like oh well you
know of course but you never know
exactly how it can happen until it
happens so NEPA doing a great job here
just settling himself down taking as
long as he needs until he's 100 positive
because the margin for error has really
narrowed down we're in an end game now
you you know wins are off the board you
can't mess around
he's so nervous I can feel it even
through the screen uh he's very nervous
right now and uh
yeah
I don't know if he's soaking a 4k5 yet
because I don't sense a relief yet uh I
I think the their ears are still
extremely red his body language hasn't
adjusted from from the initial shock I
think he's still looking for that king
of 45 and he's trying to make sure it's
indeed winning he's far from sure and I
think he's very very
very very disturbed right now and um
well I saw the chat asked if um there
are odds that Ding will win it well it's
not the question if Dingle window this
question if ding will be able to hold it
I mean I odds are there I I don't think
it's very high I think it's
um maybe four percent maybe three
percent
I mean if he plays Rook if he plays
Knight G5 then this would be one of the
this would be one of the craziest
comebacks in definitely in world
championship history and I hate you know
superlatives that are exaggerated this
would not be an exaggeration but again
the fact that nepo has an hour 24 I
think is what makes these chances three
percent and not 33 percent
yeah yeah exactly no three percent I
thought I thought less than one in 20 is
fair enough don't you think it's better
less than 120 I think that's pretty fair
I think it happens really it happens but
it's not not happening to happen very
often
it's happened to everybody that it's
among the most painful feelings in
general if you spoil a tournament game
like this to spoil a world championship
game
that can change the course of the match
is just unimaginably painful and
sometimes the pain goes through your
head even before you spoil it which
increases the chances that you're going
to spoil it because you know
self-fulfilling prophecy and everything
and we've all been there I think where
we start sensing that we're letting the
wind slip and it's still a completely
winning position but the doubt starts to
creep into your mind and it influences
your search for the best move
and you know we all know the rest humans
are capable of spoiling anything
yeah and you have to Define for me what
you mean with a completely winning
position I mean completely winning in a
sense that if white finds the best
sequence it would be completely winning
but at this point of course
um not everything wins so yeah it's it's
quite tricky now and um for young fans I
hope the body language will soon change
because right now he still as red as
ever and uh he's constantly changing his
posture appears very nervous yep I mean
it's not looking good there is not a nod
in his face there is not a realization
of king of four king of five being a win
okay he has time but he is an impulsive
player
I hope for him that he will realize that
nothing is lost yet everything is still
in control king of [__] F5 is indeed
very strong
absolutely I mean I feel just watching
him I feel extremely nervous
he's changing it all the time look how
nervous he is he's he's extremely
Disturbed
wow look at that no he's just uh
your your you know your throat starts I
know that everybody knows that feel your
throat starts to close up because it's
the worst is the realization that the
game isn't actually over that you still
have to work harder and then you start
realizing wait a second where is the win
I think he's okay
no yes King and he found it King G4 same
thing
oh well it dodged bullet dodged
wow no because the I was very worried
because he was about to make a move
without
um yet recomposing himself so I was
really worried it's going to be a bad
move but uh yeah I think he is totally
panicking but he is hoping that okay
this is still winning and it indeed is
yeah
he's winning yeah Rook takes P2 and I
think King F5 is going to come very
quickly because you don't play King G4
and not King F5 it's probably working
Rook H6 I would imagine also wins
is this F4 ruin it completely or
okay
yeah and he's done it
okay Rook H6 still a good yeah still
good
yeah still good
although listen I really yeah
and the really nice thing again this D5
Knight C5 that's a blessing that you
black cannot play D5 so you kind of gain
a Tempo and The Rook on the second rank
as long as nice on e4
it's kind of it's unable to to give
checks from behind so this this gives
white uh gives away some extra time
the only defense
I think it's the only defense and then
white plays King F5
and a lot of things I guess yeah I mean
even just like a 495 whatever
okay yeah white is winning of course
completely still but okay yet he had to
he had to you know get his ears red and
recompose himself and think for a while
yeah
but uh
okay he seems to have done it and he'll
he'll manage a little bit of excitement
there in the end it's always nice always
nice
and definitely credit to ding he he was
using that time to think he wasn't just
uh you know in in denial or
you know grieving the loss he was
genuinely coming up with the most
resilient defense and he did and it
failed and
you know now it's essentially time to
resign I think King G8 is still quite
likely to make I think in j8 is a sort
of uh only move let's say though there
are no moves at this point that are good
because they're all losing but King j8
is the move and then after King F5 okay
then you have a choice whether you try
something or you're doing it well I
guess you tried B4 or something like
that and you just and then you resign
okay yeah King six is good to him and
then you resign yeah
no you don't go before okay don't allow
King G6 you go maybe rookie two or
something
maybe you do
yeah no it's the king of five King G6
actually is a nice nice threat
yeah it is and I guess that's why he
played your Rook H6 first kind of
clearing the path for the king okay here
goes thing again head on the table
and I think he's about to move but he's
been drinking the cup to the bitter you
know to the dregs
that's how you should play I mean even
when uh okay you don't see the bar but
even when you're dead lost you have to
look for the last chance because you
want these two percent you want them and
because it's three percent you know in
hundreds of the games you will save
three so you have to go for it
again sicaro in a Blitz game I would be
far from confident in a position like
this
so even in a classical game
yeah
nepo has resumed his pacing
from one end of the hall to the other
which we know is a sign that he leaves
the result of the game isn't in question
is everybody relieved now I think um
yeah he had a brief moment of uh
I'm pretty sure he had a brief moment of
planning there but maybe I'm looking too
much into that and reading too much of
that but I'm pretty sure that he did
otherwise he wouldn't have no idea yeah
and uh now okay yeah
relief that okay after all it is indeed
winning and he hasn't ruined anything
yeah we have a feature chat
which I'd like your opinion on Dr phonia
masks is this the most error-prone World
Championship in recent memory
and you know I think it definitely is
the World Championship where we are now
more used to using the engine to look at
the games and we have the eval bar we
have the assessment of the moves right
on hand so I would caution that we you
know we're now more capable than ever of
determining mistakes right as they
happen but how would you rate the
overall quality of games
um obviously the entertainment value of
the match has been incredibly high would
you say that the quality of the games
has been abnormally low or do you think
we're just more capable of detecting
mistakes because we have very strong
engines at hand
the question because my English is of
course not native so the question
implies that this is like a lot of
errors
I would imagine that yeah error prone
yeah prone to error says what it means
like a lot of errors but
but based on what is I mean I there are
very few errors don't you think
I think yeah I think this comes back to
the I think this comes back to the
importance of distinguishing between an
inaccuracy and a big mistake whereas a
lot of people when they're newer to
looking at games they see any change in
evaluation and they just assume that
it's a mistake but mistakes are on an
incredibly wide spectrum and a small
inaccuracy and a big blunder have
absolutely nothing in common other than
the fact that they might
introduce a change in the computer
evaluation yeah I mean if we look back
uh at the game so the first game
so dink has made few inaccuracies to
land in a worse position then Jan has
made one big inaccuracy to let Dingo and
then one more inaccuracy to get the
position completely drawn
which okay it's very few mistakes like
in your average Karana Carlson game was
much worse if you look at it this
meticulously looking at the second game
that's the one that Jan won so from
Yan's perspective the game was I think
flawless
From ding's perspective he made
inaccuracy with nitex F6 instead of 95
and then one
probably one real big mistake with
Bishop D3
but to lose you have to make a mistake
so again okay okay one egg is one
mistake the winner of the game played
flawlessly completely which is not at
all a given in the other game uh ding
played an inaccuracy with Bishop D3 yeah
played an accuracy with Knight A5 and
then ding played almost flawlessly and
Jan made one large error
and today we have ding making
an accuracy in the opening and a mistake
later on
also close to being in an address like a
very small mistake no blunders today
ding lost without blundering a single
thing by the way Dingle just lost uh
with a few small mistakes and Jan so far
hasn't made almost a single mistake
apart from one inaccuracy with ninja
force of the queen F3 so no I think the
level so far has been extremely high and
uh
given that there are three decisive
games uh assuming this would be decisive
I think given that there are three
decisive games the level couldn't have
been higher I mean you could have like
maybe like okay first of all Carson
karyakan like the the games
they were of much lower quality at the
start I think Carlson had winning
positions that he kept ruining
with more than one mistake
and at the time we were like very I
remember he made some mistake in the
position with Rook at night and then we
were saying for five days how difficult
it was and so on so no I think we are
much more strict with the players now
because indeed the tools have been much
better the engines are much stronger and
much faster so we are much more stupid
the players but I think so far they've
played extremely high level chess
I agree
I I think it will make yeah
I just wanted to say that I thought I
even questioned my understanding of the
question because I assume the question
would be is it the highest level what
temperature match in a long time but
actually the question was is it the
lowest level so it kind of I I know I
think that's uh definitely not the case
yeah and if you look at the mistakes
like Carlson Anand matches much more
mistakes this there was this blunder
um no okay we are still early of course
but I think yeah for sure not the the
level is higher than what I remember but
it's close so far all of these matches
players have played really well and
because also they have a lot of time
they have a lot of time to prepare and a
lot of time to play long time control so
they're not making uh many big mistakes
and that's understandable
yeah I mean a point that I wanted to
make which is not directly related to
this question but it's related to the
2800 club that we were examining earlier
which is that we just have a lot more
access to top GMS and to their games and
to their thinking patterns you can
basically tune in at any hour of the day
and watch uh you know a top GM streaming
their Blitz Games or streaming a
tournament game
whereas at least you know when I was
growing up and I was maybe you know 10
or 11 to me like a GM was was a God you
know and when a Grandmaster was giving a
symbol I was you know awe you know I I
would just point them out in a room and
I would try to keep my distance whereas
now we realize that GM's just human
human beings and uh you know they've
been demystified and I think that's a
great thing you know that regular
players have a lot of access now to top
players but we still
should celebrate how special they are at
the game and how incredibly good people
in the top 10 are and how capable they
are of handling incredibly complex
positions where almost anybody in the
world would blunder almost immediately
so our standards are high we are strict
and we have the computer at hand but
nonetheless there's a very good reason
why the top 10 players are the top 10
players
and why they don't essentially you know
don't drop
out of the top ten
no and it's a good point that you have
access to all this uh Grandmasters
because my like I grew up in Saint
Petersburg and it's a place with lots of
Chess clubs and many layers of chess
players so I didn't see a Grandmaster
until
until I was already like 2100 I think a
pretty good player and I played that one
open tournament where there was one
Grand Master literally one Grand Master
and he's okay I don't have to tell his
name because it will be a bit weird
um now that the story will come so now
I'm curious but okay yeah no no but so
and I was totally like I was like holy
like there's gonna be a Grandmaster in
this tournament and I'm gonna see him so
of course I was coming up to his board a
lot
and he had this incredible eyes yeah
like he was looking at the board and
sometimes he looked at me also as I was
like I thought like oh this is the Grand
Master eyes like you know like I
understood like oh this is the Grandma's
like
of course it was just his eyes yeah like
he's just here that when you associate
that with someone that you're in awe of
so you think everything yeah exactly you
know this is yeah this is what a
Grandmaster looks like exactly exactly
and okay I mean actually he maybe he did
have a particular stair more than anyone
else let's say more than your average uh
but of course it was just him he had
that stare but I thought it was because
he's a Grandmaster I assume like okay
the grand Masters they might have like
they have this Grandmaster eyes or
something you know so I was also like
already as like a proper player and uh
having studied and played chess for many
years and so on so I was of course also
extremely impressed and I expected I
expected him to be special and he really
was he had the special eyes and the
special stair and I was like wow this is
a great Master yeah but so yeah now
indeed it's um it's a different time uh
but you know I'm the first to preach I'm
going to criticize like man if you want
I'm going to criticize all you want I I
love criticizing it's my favorite thing
that's why that's why I do this job I
absolutely love it uh it's not the money
it's the ability to criticize everyone
but that said I mean if you want to
criticism you have to look for example
last last four championship match
between Carlson and young that amount of
unforced uh horrible mistakes Jan was
making in the second half of the match
was crazy like it was on I was honestly
shocked like it was honestly
inexplicable it was honestly horrendous
with a lot of time on the clocks and
blunders completely obvious and
unnecessary when he went at some point
Bishop takes B7 and had the bishop track
with C6 it was so Elementary he will
himself now tell you he doesn't know
what happened to him some kind of
hypnosis he completely lost his mind but
uh in this match so far it's just not
the case it's just a very difficult
tense games with a very high level of
Chess it's just it's just how how I feel
it is here and I'm sure as attention
keeps growing and people will get more
and more players to get more and more
tires I suspect the level will go down
at some point I think so far uh so far
it's uh really good stuff
oh ding looks like he will take the rest
of his hour to come to terms with his
defeat
um but
yeah he uh the results of the game isn't
in question anymore for those just
joining this is a Surefire Victory now
for young Department black is out of
resources King F5 is coming and uh you
could just sense the shift in yon's
posture he was doing what he's doing now
earlier then ding found Rook A2 suddenly
Jan with a little bit of panic exactly
five minutes of it he found the correct
move again and now he's resumed uh you
know the pacing kind of waiting for ding
to to resign but I had a similar
experience on it where I uh
you know when I first
okay and I will interrupt my story
because ding has just resigned the game
you stop the clock the handshake has
occurred and Jana punishi once again
holds a one-point lead in the 2023 world
championship match three decisive games
uh out of the Lost uh sorry two decisive
games out of the last three
no three decisive games that I lost four
John one
then it was a draw then ding one now Jan
wins again
what an incredible bounce back really
silencing the Critics on ish who keep
mentioning Jan's match against Magnus
this isn't like his match against Magnus
and that's exactly what you were just
saying
yeah no it's incredible and
the difference uh what makes this win
different than the previous two games is
that now there's no rest day
so if ding wants to come back tomorrow
he doesn't have the time to recuperate
he doesn't have the time to take a good
rest and prepare he has to choose is he
going to rest he's going to prepare how
he's going to spend this day that makes
tomorrow's game only more interesting I
think it can be anything uh it's I
expect a likelihood of a decisive game
or even backfire on Ding and Jan could
take another another point like I think
tomorrow is going to be wild
it's going to be an incredible day but
let's quickly run over the important
moments from this game just really
really fast because this one uh is one
for the ages one of Jan's really best
games ever this was a Roy Lopez that
started in pretty conventional terms Jan
refraining from Bishop takes C6 which he
tried the Deferred exchange which he
tried in game one instead here he goes
more mainstream with an early D3 and uh
besides on the line that alireza farusha
played against uh you on ish with an
early C3 followed by H3 uh this we could
call a sideline this is not all that
popular and he kind of got ding out of
his preparation rather early ding was
executing moves quite quickly at first
with Knight A5 and C5 but Bishop G5 is
the novelty that I think is a major key
of yawn success in this game
yeah yeah so we had seen I mean we got a
standard position well a relatively
standard let's say the one that uh
appears from these Marshals uh but uh
thing was not familiar with it he took a
lot of time and I think the key moment
came on move 19.
so far dings play all the natural moves
bring the Knight back and then we were
talking about this choice of trading the
Bishops or keeping the bishop uh moving
it back to C8 and then I'm kidding the
rook and then going for 97 and uh ding
he did this slightly creative slightly
weird manure Bishop d8 Bishop B6 instead
of the usual just super G7 and that
combined with the trade of the Bishops
was not very nice because after
apps 93 and then H4 Jan was able to get
the spawn to H5 it was a very nice asset
there and already white was having some
initiative and I think the next Turning
Point came indeed on move on 29
the ding was defending is pretty
reasonable so far but was already under
pressure and here he could go Queen F6
immediately he would also take and play
Queen D7 both of which you uh suggested
as Alternatives but he did the most
natural taking Queen F6 it was also my
first instinct if you remember it's what
I did when I just showed the line very
quickly it was when the first thought
that comes to mind but he missed this
incredible resource of G4 down the line
where uh he defends this F5 pawn and
prevents before and this is really
incredible defensive move in fact G2 G4
being a defensive move now how often do
you see that and uh this really this
position it is as bad as unpleasant as
it gets and it's no wonder that he lost
it Jan's king of one was very very
cunning getting out of the queen C8
check confusing Ding and then ding kept
waiting but missed rookie four followed
by G5 this was really The Clincher and
the rest was just conversion and it got
only exciting at one point when ding
found this incredible resources through
K2 but a long thing by yandere
incredible
Incredible use of the king king E2 King
F1 King E2 King F3 and then after the
trade on G6 Yan wins upon Rook A2 with a
little bit of counter play John hunker
down and then found a uh the best way to
win activating his king throw a five
upon which the mate uh mating patterns
are totally Unstoppable and so ding
resigns the game uh on move 48 an
Exquisite Victory by Jana pomnishi uh a
game that's definitely gonna make uh its
way into janaponishi's best game
collection uh an incredible way to
bounce back from the disappointing loss
in the previous game as we look at the
scoreboard you know the draw in the
first game uh was already a sign that
this was not just gonna be a draw Fest
right this was going to imagine which
both players into the table armed with
great opening preparation this is going
to be a Yanda palmnushi that resembles
the one we saw the candidates rather
than the one that we saw in Dubai and
Jan's showing that yet again today Anish
and once again the pressure is on
dingley Reno and as you said no rest day
tomorrow he's gonna have the white
pieces so if he had the black pieces
tomorrow he would have had the luxury of
kind of trying to play without risk he
cannot just come to the board and make a
quick draw that would threaten to dig
him even further into the hole so are
you expecting major risks from dingler
and tomorrow
yes looking at things White games so far
he was taking a lot of risks already
and especially now with no time to
recover indeed draw with the white
pieces would be no good news for him
with one more black gaming coming and
being down on the score it wouldn't look
good for him I expect crazy risks and I
wouldn't be shocked if it backfires on
him
nothing would surprise me anymore
do you think he's likely to repeat 1c4
tomorrow
it depends on what ideas he has as he
had said I think it's impossible to
predict his first move but whatever it
is it will be something where there will
be lots of life in the position it will
be an equal position with a lots of uh
lots of pieces on the board I predict I
predicted to be a very double-edged and
I think Jan might get chances of his own
ording might crash again I have I cannot
predict anymore what's happening in this
match the storyline has been too
complicated I lost the plot completely
it's just uh it's impossible so more
more twists than a Hollywood drama and
we'll have one more twist for you folks
just like last time we will be bringing
you the press conference live as it
unfolds the players uh are contractually
obligated to sit for a press conference
and answer questions by a journalists
and reporters live from Astana so ding
has already uh assumed his seat at the
press conference nepo is still making
his way over the moment that press
conference starts we will bring you that
press conference live and then offer our
reaction but for the time being we have
just a moment I need to let this sink in
to let yet another decisive game at the
world championship sink in we're just so
used to seeing draw upon draw upon draw
to have a world championship where the
players are going after it Blow trading
blow for blow uh is is an amazing
feeling and I have to say these four
hours past so so quickly
no truly uh truly unusual and in a very
good sense we're very very fortunate and
spoiled and I think the players already
assuming their position I guess
the press conference guys here we go
here's the press conference
welcome everyone at the press conference
after game five Jana pomichi won the
game and the final result is three to
two
uh we're starting with the questions
from my side and then I will give the
floor to journalists my first question
is to Yan did you feel in control of the
whole game today
oh well it's hard to say so
uh so
if I'm in time to put H4 and H5 I think
what is better and uh then okay I'm not
sure so uh probably it was it was the
way to defend better for black but uh I
felt like white was pressing yeah so
let's
that's basically it and um yeah any
other time trouble I think he blundered
this G5 route 49ers for idea
and yeah it looks like uh at this point
white is like almost winning so
thank you
um I think where did you think that
things went wrong for you in this game
well after the game I think the critical
moment was uh when he played Knight F5 I
think I should have played Queen F6
instead of 1965.
to
yeah I just
oh I missed his mooji for which is quite
strong the pro not only protects a five
pound but
also to come my king size space are very
I don't have so many moves
in my
mind so yeah it's a very good gameplay
by him
and
I was
on a defensive side throughout the game
yeah maybe
I should have played Queen F6 after that
it's a very difficult position to defend
I say uh
yeah and you have played about 90 moves
within just few minutes to be more
specific in like two minutes and you
were walking a lot around the playing
venue very confident
um has Dean got into your home
preparation today in this game
uh well definitely the position was uh
was a part of my prep uh but I should
credit that for the most of the game he
plays quite sensible moves uh yes so
well it's
quite normal I think yeah so uh due to
some weather issues it was a little bit
too cold into the venue so I mean into
the lounge so that's basically forced me
to stay in the venue F4 for for like all
the time
[Music]
right
um
and I think
you have spent some decent time on the
clock
uh when Jan played Bishop to G5 was that
a surprise move for you and
um
why why you spend so much time at that
movie you disliked your position
yeah I didn't expect this line from
today so I try to find the plans
afterwards instead of H6 I also
considering Queen D7 but he will also
take only B5 and play Knight D2 I like I
have to play H6 anyway
so I think my play in open for instance
not so bad but still the position is
slightly unpleasant to
to pray
um and my
and then I'll give the floor to
journalists
um to yarn during the opening stage you
were constantly looking at ding
did you expect some body language to
reveal anything important and did he
give away
that he was caught in in your
preparation
uh
actually as I said my preparation tree
was not like as as deadly as uh probably
I was trying to uh as as it could seem
here but uh
yeah I mean after after his day uh yeah
I already missed him yeah so a little
you missed him yeah a little
okay
time for questions from press
I guess I'm being called on yeah my
climatechess.com my question is for
Grand Master Yanda palmnushi it seemed
like in today's win you outplayed your
opponent as opposed to your first win
where some inaccuracies by your opponent
led to the win do you uh care about the
style in which you win a game or is it
win a win in a match does it not matter
to you at all
well I think I think like the great
Lasker said like always a good visually
to Victor yeah uh so
I mean I felt like it's it's going to be
a very nice game if I don't like let
some counter play suddenly happen
and uh
well I mean at some point I was quite
quite unsure what to do like
should I play like C4 after Queen C6 or
and then let's say he plays Bishop A5
and it's like or let's say rookie too so
this is clearly very very good for me
but then probably he's in time to play
H5
as my queen is not going to active
squares like F3 and G4 so that was like
uh
I mean more or less a coin flip for me
like both moves uh was uh I like I like
both moves but okay I decided to
uh to make it a little bit a little bit
more more straight because once I put my
Pawn on H5 I mean I'm always bettering
also in all sorts of end games and so on
uh but yeah overall I guess it's quite
quite a small game
thanks
question please
a question for Mr
how did you spend uh the day of how did
you manage to relax and uh to recharge
your batteries
no princesses
[Music]
foreign
well expanded like in a business as
usual mode I try to relax I try to tune
my brains to uh the next game because
the preceding day
hadn't been the best
uh before the uh
okay next question yeah okay go ahead I
wanted to ask the same question today
let's go uh yeah
uh
so Ian uh did you walk uh have you
walked uh yet today uh did you walk
yesterday because you mentioned uh the
climate conditions uh uh did you decide
just to stay indoors
uh
uh yes of course uh yes uh yesterday yes
I did I did walk uh yesterday but today
uh I kind of uh woke up and uh looked
out of the window and I wasn't sure if I
felt like going for a walk but then I
kind of thought uh why not uh Just Dance
some clothes and uh go for it thank you
before we go to the next question I
would like to ask the same question to
dink as it was the free day um how did
you spending the free day
uh well and go for a small walk and
spend most of the time to rest
yeah so I listened to some music so
just not
too much things happen
thank you next question please
our question is only to Ian is a player
who is more experience playing the World
Championship matches we already
mentioned the weather today it's really
cold and you have experience playing in
Dubai where it's quite the opposite very
hot so uh discarding the fact that
you're staying here in the hotel if you
were to choose to play in the conditions
like this or the opposite which one you
you prefer personally
yeah thank you for your question but uh
once again unlike let's see football
players here we play normally inside not
outside here so it's not uh some
satisfacture
so
I mean
normally normally it's better than it's
like so so yeah like not too cold not
too hot
so
probably
I don't know
let's see what's going like to be with
the weather in next few days but yeah
hopefully it gets better
since it's it got it changed
dramatically here we have minus seven
and heavy snows uh will this affect your
daily routine I have questions to both
uh players I think I'll go to yarn first
do you think that this heavy snows can
change your daily routine
well uh normally
normally if you're a driver that that
affects you yeah like okay keep his nose
here like like in Russia they say like
uh some special services are never ready
because like snow is always a surprise
but since uh I'm not like
uh I'm not going to drive somewhere yeah
basically go by
uh by foot so I don't think it changes a
lot but yeah perhaps it's maybe maybe
it's just too cold to to go outside but
yeah we'll see
and to do you think will this snow
change your daily routine as you uh
paragraph and tell us that you like to
walk outside
yeah it's it's a heavy snow outside
so yeah it's
normally I won't I like to leave the
window a little bit open but today when
I come to the restroom there's a
the paper
says it's
better not to open okay you had that
recommendation after European yeah
okay
all right thank you next question please
from press
I'll give her I've already asked a
question
yeah
so a question for in uh which decisions
just decisions were the most challenging
uh to you and which what are the moves
you're maybe proud about
uh
um
[Music]
foreign
decision was to play either C4 or 8
uh five or those options deserved my
attention
and uh you know the uh the move King uh
F1 was also uh not an uninteresting was
quite an interesting movie because it
really mattered uh it was really
important to move the uh King out of the
diagonal
um all right next question please my
climatechest.com this question is for
both players in the last couple of World
Championships it has felt like one win
is a huge lead but as we're seeing in
this one it may not be as big of a deal
so does that allow you to play with less
stress knowing that wins are happening
quite regularly
go with you first
uh
I don't know what to answer
I mean winning is better than drawing
drawing is better than losing like
that's it
ending since you've already won one game
do you feel like you're not as stressed
about being behind in the match again
yeah of course I
this time this loose
even hurt more than the previous one
because I thought I was
totally
oh fine
so but okay and we have still have many
rounds I hope I can recover from this
tough rules and just to be clear you
said this loss hurts more than the other
loss is that right
sorry did you say that this loss hurts
more than the other loss is that what
you said uh yeah it can be said like
this okay thanks
we do have a question from commentary
team
it's a question for ding you know when a
white took e takes F5 and you had this
choice of where to move your queen queen
F6 or queen D7 were you trying to make
me in D7 work and what was your problem
with it
yeah at this point I have many Choice
here I thought I was very close to equal
so I
was a little bit on patient at that
point I thought after Bishop C5 I have
B4 next but I totally overlooked the G4
which they're quite strong move
it's about loser focus and concerns
during the game
question for Jan
um your chess players are not so
emotions on a scale of one to ten how
happy are you inside right now
um
more than five surely
but less than 10.
okay it's between five and ten but like
five and seven and four uh I I won't
specify okay
thank you very much for the questions we
have one more question from press yeah
my question is to ding
um uh I just arrived today and I don't
know if somebody else asked this
question before
um but in the media center I couldn't
find any Chinese journalists
how do the media cover this match in
your country
well I don't know since I I didn't
follow the medium too much
so I can and I
I don't know how to answer this question
if I make an answer this question
because I have seen several videos of
news in China the the match is reported
in the country I can improve that
um okay do we have more questions from
press yeah go ahead please
um
so a question a question for miss junior
Promenade
this evening this night
uh Orthodox Christians in Russia Russia
is celebrating uh the Orthodox Easter
and there is a tradition to
bake a special Easter cakes the
coolitches or the special Easter cakes
and also to paint uh chicken eggs are
you going to do anything of this this
night
foreign
Exchange
well thank you very much for your
question there are lots of you know we
do run into
holidays every now and then
there's been there's recently been the
day of uh space travel for instance uh
this space of cosmonautics no I'm not a
religious person although I'm not a
religious person of course I will gladly
will happily enjoy a Coolidge a Russian
Easter cake and maybe wash you down with
a a drop of tea with a cup of tea
[Music]
thank you Katie mikeclanjust.com final
questions for yawn Napoli before the
match began Magnus was asked who he
thinks will win and he said I literally
don't care you probably did not know
this but at the beginning of your game
today he posted a picture of himself and
it said Astana calling which suggests
that maybe he is starting to get
interest in the match if you had to
guess do you think he's following the
match closely uh
as they say I literally don't care yeah
well said I guess he's turning into his
Stream area or something
uh since this is a famous quote from
from another a very very strong player
thank you for that thank you Freddie for
the answers and the questions uh now
it's time for Twitter segment please
just say hi my name is Jesse February I
have some questions from social media my
first questions for ding from Irene
circonda is it your first time working
with Richard
sorry is it your first time working with
Richard oh yes
and does your playing style differ to
Richards
yeah a little bit okay
and how's your energy
how is your energy
right now right now or after that Lewis
of course it's exhausted
it's very tired
so
all right thank you and for young
congrats on your win uh if you were to
compare this match to other tournaments
what is the biggest difference in your
preparation
yeah thank you for your question uh it's
me she's not some kind of tournament
it's a title match it's like
uh it's just different yeah
I mean not everything is referring but a
lot of things
considered using any of your published
material in this match
uh thanks again for the question I guess
it would be wiser to use some
unpublished material rather than
published uh yeah and then like
struggling every day uh like with my
team like team tells me that there's not
to play King's game which I say no I
should
yeah and that's what we do instead of
preparation probably
thank you
thank you very much do we have more
questions from press
maybe now it's the last last call and
I'll go with the my final question to
both players about the time control do
you feel comfortable with this time
control Yan
uh I'd say that
uh previously in Dubai it was pretty
much new to me because I think this time
control is quite rarely used and the
candidate control was different but
since uh it's like the one format for
all the tournaments like I mean they're
all cycle tournaments let's say uh I'm
I'm getting more used to to it yeah but
yeah it's
it's probably the top one yeah like uh
the classical seven hours plus time
control but
uh yeah it's at least it's hard to
everyone
thank you very much and I think do you
find this time control comfortable
for you
yeah since I'm the one who spent more
time
so
um but okay it's it can provide some
dramas
when the time travel is approached
thank you very much for coming here and
here and answer to our questions it has
been a long day I wish both players a
good rest and the sixth round will come
tomorrow at 3 pm local time thank you
very much and good night
thank you
[Applause]
and as
as we look at the scoreboard there
Jana Palm Desi delivering once again
winning his second game of his world
championship career and now he holds a
one point lead the score is three to two
on the ball is of course back in dingley
runs Court we could see him dejected but
he's won a game already so Anish winning
that second game he's gonna have to draw
inspiration from the game that he
already won he's got the white pieces
and if this next game is going to be
anything like the games that we've seen
thus far
he's going to be able to pose serious
problems because the side of the white
pieces has been in charge thus far
oh yes absolutely and even though he
said that this is a more painful loss
than previous one and he said the
reasons because he felt he was feeling
fine and that's an interesting statement
there actually you know he he feels that
Jan beat him when he was in shape and
that indeed can also be quite painful so
an interesting statement there but he is
of course
far from dejected he has lots of games
to go lots of games with the white
pieces where he can indeed try to strike
back as I mentioned earlier of course of
course I hope for uh for an exciting
match and so comeback is very much on
the menu but at the same time
you know he's taking lots of risks with
white so far he's going for these very
double-ish positions one of these games
already backfired for him and I think
we'll see a three result game tomorrow
and well I wouldn't be surprised to see
any of the three results frankly just a
crazy match and a wild match so far
it has been a wild match uh indeed and
the match will continue of course a lot
of preparation to do for the players
particularly for Giannis he tries to
anticipate uh what ding is going to do
in between uh bytes of Easter cake of
course uh if he finds uh some time but
definitely a lot of work remaining to be
done there is no rest day tomorrow as we
look at the schedule folks mark your
calendars because there will be indeed a
game tomorrow it'll start at the same
time as all of the game's 2 A.M Pacific
so if you're in California
you're gonna stay up it's 5 a.m New York
time and 11 A.M central European summer
time
uh so game six coming your way tomorrow
at Sunday then there will be a rest day
no more than two games before a rest day
and then game seven will come your way
on Tuesday with Jana pomnishi once again
having the white pieces but next up is
tomorrow's game where dingley ran
attempts to level the score a niche
before I wrap up I'll pass it to you one
last time for your final thoughts on the
excellent display that we saw today by
iyanobamishi
no yeah absolutely I mean the uh match
so far is a treat and um
ding has to come back once again
we know he has that in him
but he needs the stage to be set he
needs that uh opening once again to go
right
I'm looking forward to tomorrow
and I think if these five games so far
are you know foreshadowing of what the
match is about to happen
then I think uh we are up in you know
for a big big treat I think the next
game and the upcoming games are going to
be special so far nobody can guess
anything nobody can guess the opening
nobody can guess the result of the game
it's all completely wild and
unpredictable the players are so
versatile nowadays they're playing
everything
it's uh getting chances you know
creating chances
I'm looking forward to tomorrow I think
we'll want to strike back but it won't
be easy
it will not be easy uh we hope you will
join us tomorrow at 2 A.M Pacific time
but for now we'd like to thank everybody
in the chat uh for joining us the chat
was hoppin as usual the tens of
thousands of you joining us across the
platforms and cheering on your favorite
player uh our amazing crew at chess.com
and our producer holla for another
amazing broadcast and of course
Grandmaster Nish Geary always an honor
to commentate with you
we'll see you tomorrow bright and early
for game six as dingley run tries to
battle back from another very difficult
spot he holds a one-point deficit and a
Yanda palmnushy will try to assert his
lead and come back to become the world
champion thanks again everybody for
watching We Wish You a fantastic rest of
your Saturday and we will see you
tomorrow for game six we'll leave you
with the best moments from today have a
great rest of your Saturday
this is going to be a long interesting
and very important game we see the
handshake there between the players
being following up with Knight C6 no
Petrov for us today and this is the
second Moment of Truth Bishop is off to
B5 so we have another Roy Lopez will we
see a more mainstream Choice by Yan I
think it's the next big question I
wonder if nepo's excited to reach this
kind of position and I wonder if his
team looked at age six at each there's
more stuff to grab onto and as I say
that Rook A8 has been played in the
Moment of Truth nepo has indeed uh
refrained I think it's a disaster from
black already this could get incredibly
unpleasant the thing ran back to the
board like when it really ran and he's
already played C4 so we're about to find
out
it doesn't look uh so bad to me to be
very honest I think it simply means G4
Rocky 2 is good
[Music]
and it reminds me of the second game
where he puts pressure on the clock as
well as on the board
he's he is losing it I mean he's losing
it I think he is um
he's he's done here thing has just
resigned the game stop the clock
handshake has occurred and Jana palmushi
once again holds a one point lead in the
2023 world championship match
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign